[Music]
thank you
yeah yeah
welcome to the realm now my levels are
sounding what's going on we got cars
going by
we got cars driving by
cars right back
what's going on realm talk to me let's
do some mic checks let's do some call
out some roll call you know what I mean
terminal Blaze what's up what's going on
Gerald MacDonald G tell everybody make
sure they respectful in here I heard
people wasn't being respectful
five nights what's going on what's going
on no doubt Matthew Ash what's up Isaac
Gentry was going on God's Soul God Soul
like that he's in the round he's in the
realm he's chilling
Malcolm X LAX let's go
what's going on Autumn 316 you know
Austin that's awesome all right I'm
right okay what's up Johnny warned
what's going on Psychonauts what's going
on time I appreciate y'all levels it's
good levels is good that's what's up
Carolina game we wanted 12 hour shift oh
look we ain't gonna give you all over 12
hours we can give you like four
lives of privacy my man is what's going
on Craig Hall again we got the goons in
here audio's good no doubt no doubt
what's going on Rock recording what's up
germ dog LAX what's going on in the
building full stack let's go that's what
I'm talking about death three let's go
y'all up here early I like that I like
that Reggie mobile number nine the knife
one
this is going on 50 000 what's up y'all
get to see y'all up here early Kuro Veda
what's up oh from Japan say word we got
the realm all the way in Japan
that's crazy that's what's up I like to
see that both slay what's going on IOP
West Western Rose what's going on John
Wolfe what's going on hold the line for
Sega listen I always hold the line for
second but you trying to you trying to
do suicide missions
[Music]
but yo we got my man from Japan over
here that's what's up no doubts ready
for the uh Xbox Dreamcast
job of laughing
um yeah yeah it's gonna be good we got
from Austria okay Austria Europe is in
the building while we International in
the realm we gotta watch the ropes we
got people from Beyond The Great Wall
you know I like that I like that calling
the king yeah yeah yeah yo make sure
when um it's uh the King's birthday
today y'all so y'all gotta show Extra
love to the cake you know what I'm
saying this is born day he woke up early
on his own day you know what I mean some
sense of love for him
yeah yeah he was out he was outside
addicts of Mike checking with attic
right now yeah so he's up in there okay
Chicago okay shout out to the building
he ranks what's going on K N oh now we
got enough k n updates yeah today's the
king man you know that's what's up oh
now I'm on my my homie what's going on
I'm International like I'll be outside
I'll be moving but gonna make it I don't
know I don't know
let's go another gcp the building see
you in a bit so yeah make sure y'all
show some extra love to the king you
know what I'm saying it's his birthday
he held a lot see a lot of dudes and
they feel it's gonna hold the line yo
what's going on with that why Deuce is
bad
yo that joke be killing me like just do
just y'all saying it got dudes upset yo
it's special it's beautiful oh [__] out
the Forte back from Vegas
okay no doubt C Unit in the building
Chris Jones log that what's up no doubt
yeah yeah it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be fun so look make sure we're gonna get
the birthday Lord I've been here sword
Attic in the building he already did his
mic check and uh yeah it should be a fun
one some good topics and all of that and
I will see y'all
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
oh
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and hell is be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers they don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my TV but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
you
[Music]
um
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know we're about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless of people don't
aim check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social know my city but I'm
still bi-coastal I got you
[Music]
um
that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable why can't
it be and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapper and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you're just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know we're about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
thank you
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard a boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell an Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up into your apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my TV but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot to get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless of people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you
[Music]
a problem
I'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't get
with that option you're gonna be single
player like Cyrus you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
vendor I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny work to carnido who cares if he
flies he's still a mosquito you swear he
ain't something but really be civil you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if he really was
that dude King David still be the king
of the statue sister juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we'll meet in The Crucible
other than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord then
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
the bike's about to be hot we cannot.com
y'all messy right now y'all messy and
the bikes are hot and we're live we're
live puppies the puppies the children
the good things and good things you know
about welcome here you hear you and we
are live and welcome to the islands
podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 311
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's date and
today we've got Microsoft versus the FTC
round two
Xbox oh yeah I know look at Alex
I was generally yawning oh okay I
thought you was doing your attic stuff
we will we'll accept that answer
so I can't help with that Crown right
now foreign
and Sony's remaining Call of Duty deal
to discuss so we go get right
so we can get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original gaming Knights the realm
here at the round table my co-host
Nicole Mouse my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord attic back to
back how we do it
doing pretty good King this is that
shirt I was talking about oh that's dope
oh my God why
hey you gotta leave your door open whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a dope brand name for something
yeah
he got me out of pocket
so I've been playing uh a lot more Final
Fantasy 16. you know I'm definitely
almost to the end of the game at this
point it's a fun game you know but but I
will say is like if you're a final
fantasy fan and you're co-signing this
I don't know did you ever like Final
Fantasy they can't like the game on its
own Merit stuff
I don't know it's but the thing is it's
not its own marriage it says Final
Fantasy
its own merits would have been a an
original Ip with a completely new name
untied to the Final Fantasy brand but
guess what Square Enix knew that
wouldn't sell so it's just like look it
this to me is the the highest quality of
a spin-off you can get damn that's how
you feel you feel like it's it's a
separate joint it'll be dope if it was a
separate joint but the fact that they
put a final fantasy name to it see they
should have just named it a spin-off but
the thing is they knew you know a Durga
Cerberus or you know there's a bunch of
spin-offs Final Fantasy X2 lightning
well I mean Paradise stranger apparel
yeah they should have made stranger
Paradise this game it would have done
better but the fact that they put 16 on
the end it gives me expectations on what
I expect from a Final Fantasy game and
let's say you put a whole hundred
percent of my expectations towards the
Final Fantasy game if it feels maybe ten
percent
so it's just like look it's like it's
it's actually worse like at least I like
the the Zelda games I don't mind this
game it's fun it's okay it's not like
it's no longer a game of the year
Contender for me oh
it's a fun game the 1080p
it's a fun game and it was worth the
podcast is money it wasn't worth my
money yeah it's just one of those things
where it doesn't look like
it's not a Final Fantasy game
yeah
sorry it's like it's like Fallout 4
compared to New Vegas and three it's
like breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom compared to Ocarina time but I
would put this below them like this is
worse than those because at least for
some degree to some degree Zelda
expanded on stuff that made complimented
some of the other stuff okay at least
Fallout 4 okay Fallout 4 there's not a
whole lot maybe this is below above
Fallout 4. okay but but I still felt
like I was playing a Fallout game I
don't feel like I'm playing a final a
Final Fantasy game like they they just
throw all you know efforts in here oh
Phoenix is in here Phoenix is a a very
popular song but he's not like a mad
popular Summit the the part that's just
funny is it's just like you look at this
game and I just I just don't understand
now you know what I like some Final
Fantasy fans
he love you you give him a week with
show it yep
all the flaws I don't like how how she
sleep when she snore my elbow no good
yeah
definitely fall out no I wasn't talking
about fallout 3. Fallout 3 and Fallout
New Vegas and all their expansions is
Fallout The Fallout template to Me
Fallout 4 is some a Fallout template but
the majority of it doesn't feel like
they took the speech out I'm not getting
into that I've ranted about that a
hundred times there's probably 50
podcasts you can watch to get my
opinions on Fallout 4 and breath of the
wild Final Fantasy 16 is a fun game game
it's not a Final Fantasy game okay
he heard it here first Atticus I didn't
have to put in the dirt
that's been in searches all the uh ff16
and that's it
yeah and and one thing too like people
in the chat people on Twitter stop
trying to tell me a final fantasy fan
how my expectations should be for our
final fantasy game like stop it like
first off people sit there and say well
I've never played a Final Fantasy game
so I'm not mad and I don't know someone
said that Chad I'm not really single you
know I am singling you out so it's just
like oh I get it you never played one
that's cool and I'm glad that for you
but don't tell me I can't be upset on
how a franchise I grew up with change
stuff dramatically not once not twice
but three times
back to you he said what he said
he's standing on it clearly oh shout out
to ducky the round good to see you
brother good to see you ducky no doubt
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo game on this for
the single player selfish experience and
also the soundtrack
The Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of
the iron bank PC Master race is wrong I
like own Lord sorry how are we doing sir
I'm doing good doing pretty damn good I
got to got I had a couple of days kind
of off not a full I'm fully off but uh
you know a little bit of rest for the
holidays so it's good so I got to to
chill out uh yesterday I played some
games let's go let's go even podcasts I
like that yeah unbelievable play some
games
um so I threw on I haven't played I
haven't played Ragnarok in a long time
I'm not doing Ragnarok on right it
hadn't really thrown it on threw that
off just as quick dude no hating I like
I like Ragnarok it's a dope DLC
I haven't played in like months right so
um you know it took me like 30 40
minutes to get back into the groove like
all my weapons
there's too much stuff
anyway
so the thing is I was at a point where I
and I'm not gonna spoil anything I was
like 10 minutes away from a fight in
this game with somebody who's shall we
say very hard to hit yes
and so I imagine coming off of a layaway
like that to fight this dude I'm like
well I'm done man I'm this dude that
murdered me I don't know how many times
but I got my groove back got my groove
back got managed to remember all the
buttons and I and I beat him
um but yeah I I like that game is it
long-winded yes is there a lot to it yes
oh I don't even know how close I don't
know how far from the end I am at this
point I still probably 20 hours out but
so I played that
um and I got to play what you got to
play oh we got the dude
am I gonna as well am I gonna talk about
this here
bring it down
aew fight forever let's get it
all right so as most of you know get
something to drink
because most of you know the Lords here
are old school wrestling heads we love
love love the N64 wrestling games by Aki
uh published by THQ back in the day go
wrestling so we have ux who are the
former developers of like the smackdown
game SmackDown or football games and
then they went on into the WWE games
right
um and then they moved on from WWE and
now they're working with aews
he out of pocket that's why we need to
see you shaking your juice we got to
listen to your Slanders
uh continue continue
it's not my fault you don't shake juice
in front of the kids I don't want to
hear nothing about people talking to you
about oh you know only fans addicts yeah
exactly they like stinks in the air
so we did that so now we have ux
developing the aew game in the vein of
the old school N64 games right some of
the people on the youth team also came
from that original hockey team not many
but at least the the the the the core of
that sort of the Line Design philosophy
is there for this game so when you look
at this game out of the box it looks
like a a spiritual successor to those
games
um in terms of how it looks in terms of
how it plays how it looks it's cleaner
right and it's obviously less detailed
than what you're going to see from the
big AAA budget WWE game but it looks
clean it looks good it doesn't look
overly cartoony okay now quick quick
question the comment we got chest out
block oh okay let's go let's go let's do
it let's get to it the combat if you
have played the old N64 games to the
extent that we've played the combat is
all there yes it is a hundred percent
those games in some ways I think in
terms of overall control scheme and the
amount of moves and stuff you're able to
do it may be because of it it's a first
effort it may be a little less in terms
of depth than a no mercy but but it's
all there okay it's all there and what I
can tell you is because I've done heard
nothing but bad things let's get to that
we're bad things there's no bad things
there's wrestling is wrestling it's Aki
wrestling is that bad I feel like this
is so mad but it's Nintendo energy going
on right now but it's Nintendo I mean
technically Nintendo so yeah the the
fighting system is exactly what you sort
of remember you have uh you have strong
grapples you have like grapples you have
grapples from the front you have
grapples from from the back you have
attack buttons you have a strong attack
and you hold the button longer and you
get a you get a you get a sorry a light
attack then you hold a longer you get a
strong attack right
um You have grabs and you have grabs
that you can like you can grab from the
front and you can come around to the
back you have counters okay strike
counters with the same thing the bumpers
right okay and then you have that you
have grab counters you can slap off
right nice same thing where you stick
the chest down
and when you don't do that it slaps it
off right nice then in addition to that
you also have like the test of strength
thing when you can put your arms up and
you can go you could go hand in hand and
you can try to go back and forth with a
test of strength fire in addition to
that it just feels like move to move
like it in the flow of a match it feels
it feels very good because again you
have greater frames of Animation than we
had on the N64 days it's very smooth so
move to move it feels super good and it
feels like the flow of a match is kept
intact now one thing that I noticed from
the jump playing I went into normal mode
and that is super easy yeah and and I'm
gonna tell you this I I remembered all
those moves in like 10 15 minutes I was
like oh wait a minute okay dude I got
this it took you longer to remember the
moves with God of War it did it did
you see when you love something you
learn to move it's in my heart it's in
my heart when you start to play
something ah it takes a half an hour to
get these moves down yeah
two buttons and no jump but let's say
continue so
um but yeah I had to put it up to the
hardest difficulty and the hardest
difficulty gives you that back and forth
where they cheap because they cheap you
hit me with two supers and I'm done or
whatever
um but at the same time it's like you
you feel like it's competitive like
they're coming at you and the other
modes the AI is a little dumb you allow
themselves to be beaten up on and you
can finish them pretty quickly even on
hard
this is how he don't finish his games
this is two weeks in a row about new
games
yeah he's always on the highest
difficulty yeah I'm gonna take my joint
to that but if this thing is going to
play on the easiest thing but this is
this is the thing right for these games
and what I've always noticed about these
games is these games are most fun when
you're playing with others with friends
yeah when you're playing with friends
like I love those games back in the day
but it is not the same thing playing by
myself absolutely playing with all of
y'all all the wild stuff we were doing
making up these bracket black
gloves oh man where they look into their
souls of black looking what are they
talking about yeah
he's just it's just floating teeth
but this so all I played is the single
player so far because I just wanted to
make sure that the gameplay was where I
wanted it to be and apart from like
little differences and maybe things that
feel a little bit differently just
because the frame rate's better and the
the the character models look are more
are dense and more attack you know it
doesn't have N64 Jank on it
um it just feels a little bit different
[Laughter]
but I'ma tell you like it it is the
closest thing that we've gotten to that
feel in a long long time and I think it
is a great great building block nice to
kind of take this and expand upon it
more like I said it feels like I feels
like I'm a little short on moves from
when I remember no mercy okay but it's
still all of the sort of all of the
things you could do in match uh in terms
of strategy and stuff like that all that
is there you could you know pull the
guys to certain directions so they can't
so they can't get to the rope and stuff
like that and
um then the wild matches that you know
the latter matches the bloody matches
all kinds of crazy stuff is it a um can
we play uh online yes oh yes oh yes and
it's cross play right that's cross Play
Always cross play and then I think uh
Maddie because he he win a review on
Duke because he was talking about how
like see what he was talking about like
kind of like is the spirit meter Factor
kind of like you get tone and you can
build up remember the stuff the team
stuff your brother Kai box oh you do
like two more you'll be beating the
moments do two moves
so the thing about it is that in aw if
you look at that roster you don't really
you don't have too many of those guys
that at the Goldberg Brock uh the rock
status guys would take to Shack the
division yeah yeah yeah exactly so those
gonna have those guys really there
everybody's more even like the AWS is
kind of cool like that that it's it's
it's eating off the fact that everybody
is kind of they they're making big names
for themselves right now they have a
couple but those guys aren't the big
brother what do you consider to be the
heavyweight champion wrestler you know
it's it's not that so I feel that it's
it's a super sort of balanced roster and
they have you know the ladies are
equally sort of uh represented all kinds
of different matches which I haven't
which I haven't yeah I you know you know
they build themselves up for the Bam Bam
Bigelow
motivate playing right now he said that
they they didn't add cross play yet but
it's coming coming according to Kenny
Omega that's what he said okay yeah so
they haven't added it okay they haven't
added yet and for me on the PC and this
is one thing that I saw that I hope is
not true but they said you can play with
other people on other PC on other PC
storefronts and I was like wait a minute
what happened to the full CrossFit
gotcha so I'm not have to buy this twice
but
um I I like what I see I definitely want
to play with you guys because again I
think that's where the main fun is after
a while even on the hardest difficulties
and did a nice emulation yes yeah we can
do that for a community today that would
be dope but uh I'm enjoying it I think
it's a great first step I I hope they
continue to expand upon it I really do
think it is a nice alternative to the
WWE games because even though the
quality of those has gotten kind of back
to where it used to be
um and 2K is undertaking that now it
still kind of feels that the formula is
the same year and year out so it's good
to see something that that sort of
deviates from that I mean we're going to
see something even more than deviate
with wrestle Quest coming up soon right
um so but that's an RPG but in terms of
something that feels like those old N64
games it gets it right and it just and I
do feel it just needs to continue to
build upon it it's it's it's there it's
there and it's good enough for what it
is right now that I because I thought
this was going to be an S show up and
down down and it is and it's not it's
not so Foundation is there the
foundation wait I spoke to Maddie
Maddie's greatest disappointment though
he really hated the career mode he was
just like man he's very disappointing
yeah oh yeah that's what I was waiting
for to see if he was going to talk about
that because that because that's why I
was like core gameplay he's like yes so
he's with you there but he would just
say like you know that they really need
work or that on that so that's pretty
much been it and of course I gotta say
happy born day to my brother The King
The King love you brother I was looking
for a room
yeah
you know no you don't Focus baby because
I'm focused he's focused baby and oh
speaking of which and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access gamer the prophet of Xbox
so I mean King of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
whole the line movement ooh beloved some
people in their feelings for that I
don't know why
but happy birthday happy birthday cake
oh man thank you so much well
um I didn't know that those little words
hold the line you mean these these yeah
man I didn't know that they was going to
put so many people in the feelings baby
you got people going crazy baby crazy
you using my phrase and don't even know
where to go babe
David
this is how you killed two people with
one rock
[Laughter]
and I ain't wasting my time on you
before
telling somebody to Stand Tall you guys
won't ever get it real dude stood up was
like oh hold on man my heart was from
the Kool-Aid for a second my bad king I
messed up man let me get back over there
with you bro
so me saying hold the line on FTC joint
throw up hey yo dude this is like y'all
need to demand more we did we the ones
that made Microsoft go back on that
raise the price hike and drop it back
down
um we don't want to demand it more
that's why they went out got Studios
he's the ones that demanded more that's
why they're in the ABK thing right now
but remember y'all was demanding from us
to ask them for more what we're gonna
settle for this for so we did now you
see the plans and the plans just buy
everything y'all like stop competing
don't compete like that we want y'all to
compete with the same three Studios
cause we know we can laugh nah son
competition is on right now and this is
how competition started remember when
y'all had the best handheld that was
ever made remember that yo I'ma tell you
that Vita was crazy until this
until this oh man this race
oh my god oh man Ally puts your Vita in
the bushes
I don't even know why you're coming out
with that Q light joint you know what it
is
that joint should be quiet because
there's a big raw guidelines
you killed you stupid
the games I've been playing this week
um Diablo for Diablo I hate playing with
people yes I was talking some people but
they said yo we try to play in King's
game and he don't be answering nah and I
told him what you said I said kid plays
a necromancer the kick said he already
got his videos
a single player game thank you very much
oh my God
and Mason in okay
these dudes is level 54. I'm a smooth
29. I'm doing my joint you know I'm
having fun I got my team with me
picking out stuff picking up stuff and
um
dudes is doing stuff in other places
Shack in the map don't check my map and
they talking about yo we're gonna open
our waypoints don't you open up the
waypoints
just you stick here with me and if I
need you I call right like if I need but
I don't need you because I'm I'm stacked
I'm kidding stuff I'm going through the
map and they trying to act like they
showing me so much wonders like dude
this ain't my first uh Diablo this is my
my fault I'm on my fourth but y'all not
showing me nothing I want to go I want
to read story Deuces yeah we've been
there wait till you see this country I
don't care for you know anybody
no I see messages King what's up I'm on
it invite me
leave you on scene oh man anti-social
kick I need some Fortnight no doubt I
was tweaking and twerking with my rug
Ally
God in them oh all right so let me tell
you all the wrongs about this machine
let's go
let's go let's go well I got it though
this is the worst user interface I've
ever come across in my life yo
um
I can see why people brought it back to
the store I can see first first when you
come in and everybody remember when
y'all first got your place I don't know
what it is when you get your PlayStation
5 now but I remember day one when you
got your first time you hooked your
PlayStation 5 up all the um no was the
PlayStation 4 it was a Playstation 4.
All That DRM that they had in it right
they had to remove it and upload new
bios to it so
when when you got it and you you put it
it was literally probably like 10 hours
it took for my PlayStation to to rip off
the the first uh operation system and
then put in a new one I remember and I
remember it like it was yesterday
and I was like this this is trapped this
is where my hate started out like this
is trash you want to open your box and
play your stuff perfect
this dude here
he do half of that he do a smooth six to
eight hours so I downloaded my downloads
I'm trying I'm getting ready I'm hyped
I'm hyped the first half from now while
I'm hype as hell yeah second hour I'm
like
updates okay don't forget your driver
updates hey baby did you get this update
over here baby and I'm like oh man when
I spoke to COG
it was like seven o'clock at night I
started this process at 3 30. and um I
said he said yo you make sure you
download all your drivers yeah I got
everything
I went to Windows and it said Advance
check for updates I said let me do that
oh it said you got 20 of them
I said see them all baby put it on up
there it did its download now I must say
let's go to the game plan I put um fours
on oh man I'm so Wifey I'm like yo look
that was good and she said oh you got a
little TV okay she thought what I was
looking at was was television it was
YouTube she said what's that fast and
furious I said nine baby this is the
game she saw the game playing she said
oh I see why it's worth that money yeah
yeah yeah she said I see then I started
playing fist
um that just got released in Game Pass
oh my God nice Unreal Engine five
beautiful side scrolling nice indie game
very fun I love it it reminds me a
Bionic Commando very dope game if you
want short bursts to fun I'm having such
a good time where they had sword on
somebody's showcase I think it was a PC
showcase not too long ago and I was
interested in it I think he had came out
in PlayStation Plus like last year
didn't get a chance to play it but now
that it's on Game Pass CC some can drop
over there but it's like you know
training Forest that falls I don't
nobody hear that [__] yeah
[Laughter]
I am not gonna lie
um get when the game's just running on
that yeah Second To None there's nothing
second yeah two non games amazing user
interface second to track second to
trash so I gotta talk to my um my big
homie Care Center because there's some
things I got to do because you know my
tears and my kingdom
I know what you doing I know what you're
doing I see you can't shout out to you
to chat
I know what he's doing we're not gonna
discuss that on the ground he already
got the DM we are not discussing that as
well moving on help me wipe my test
because
but no that's that's uh what I've been
playing I I think I think it was like
one more one or two more but um no man
oh Final Fantasy that's what it was oh
yeah let's go let's go all right so
yesterday y'all saw that we was having a
cookout you know Fourth of July weekend
cookout so your family's over you know
my brother and I mean my son-in-law he
was uh spitting in in in Spanish he's
like okay guys he just made it over here
he just came through Venezuela and all
that stuff and with backpacks and
yeah it's not a game man that's not a
game it's not you Brave the actual
jungle and he got here and he spitting
so I was just like yo if I could I could
put it out in any form you know somebody
like his his music or whatever so we had
a good time yeah I said let me download
this Final Fantasy because I lost last
week y'all won we had a thousand likes
and I gotta play this stupid game
so I'm downloading it I was like let me
do a video I'll do a video tease these
dudes because y'all think y'all in some
exclusive club like we can't get in uh
I'm a bot I got the keys to your house
all day
[Music]
my problem with that game I was trying
to launch on my twitch on my Xbox
I can stream to my twitch mad easy yes I
was having a problem I don't know I
think maybe I had too many more delos
last night yes possibly like you know
what I'm gonna figure it out today so
everybody that didn't get a chance to
see me stream it I'm going to stream it
today and it's gonna be on my twitch
channel it's not gonna be on the IOP
Channel but I'm gonna give you all the
Final Fantasy and maybe I might like it
more than how addict is because attic is
putting a lot on it me personally I'm
not I I like Final Fantasy they're not
my number one RPG yeah book one and two
is my best RPG so maybe my opinion of it
will be a little bit different you know
so hopefully y'all get a good review for
me no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the Shinobi Lord
Cognito spreading that release in the
remnant IOP not telling what you want to
hear but what you need the headshot the
finally do kind of going over the you
know round two like we want to do you
know of the FTC versus Xbox shout out to
eat boxes man I'm holding it down old
Flashpoint days Travis was on a mission
going to do some things that we can't
talk about as under NDA but we will talk
about when he returns which would be
dope so check out last word again next
week that'll be dope like y'all I've
been doing my Ally I've been wronging it
up and rocking it up um Streets of Rage
lies of P demo excuse me street street
fighter 6 demo finally did that very
impressive very impressive love what I
was saying in a model controls man wow
such a revolutionary thing yeah that's
so cool man
helps a lot of people out but um
I've been doing that I actually played a
lot of Dusty this week I finally got a
chance to do the new dungeon ghost of
the deep I highly recommend addict and
King do that dungeon for reasons that
they will like from OG Destiny trust me
I think you guys I haven't already
download it yeah I got it I never took
mine out at it because I know older
moment because I know these dudes
uninstall it it's like yeah something
happened and I saw something this week
too that I wanted to do so yeah you're
right should be rocking that doing that
and then the storyboard obviously it
started to wrap up try to finish Diablo
I really want to finish it this week but
I just got caught up but I'm really
kidding I gotta get I mean like act
three act four whatever it is got to get
that dub the story is is phenomenal
diabolous is really good so yeah that
has been it um question um have you
tried it on the Rock yet Destiny oh oh
yes oh yes oh my god
listen so cool he said we so close to
get out of it again look just look for
me look you could do a 1080p you're
gonna hover it in the 50s you're going
to be for the most part fine however if
this is where there's certain sections
that will test it and Neo Muna the new
DLC it's that cybertronian cyberpunky
everything's going on that's when the
stuff that came after they got purchased
right
um I would say I mean these things are
done in development earlier yeah but you
know sometimes you know you just just
put it out
anyway anyway yeah I guess anyway but um
yeah so that is what I saw the frames
really tank is very intensive there so
for me I do um 720 with AMD rsr in that
bra off like Final Fantasy I'm chilling
I should afraid everything's lit going
crazy phenomenal yeah the rock is here
would you say like 720 is the sweet spot
now
is the new 4k I know what you're doing
I know what you're doing sir anyway
[Laughter]
all right super test this might be from
the last week I think I'm not sure uh
Robert Kelly five dollars Super Chat
Xbox doing the spider verse art style
before PlayStation I think I read this
one side of the midnight looks stunning
and I can't wait to see more of that
Atlas being there was huge yeah this is
like two weeks ago for whatever reason
it stayed in the document
um Hollywood rules and remember for 17
months Lord silver happy Sunday to my
NYC V cousins and best pod ILP
f-t-c-a-k-a Sony's lawyers looking
incompetent and very happy birthday to
the general King 98 David
bless his blesses and we got Robert
Kelly Two Dollars Super Chat happy
birthday General yes DC losing is a
great gift it has happened
relax y'all popping bottles early relax
listen yo [__] I'm I'm Gonna Keep it a
buck with you
um the only person that I have to uh
prove within the Shadows is the FTC
Microsoft has to introduce doubt so much
doubt here baby
that that's the way law should go
hold the Libations hold the Libations I
like that I like that salute then we
have the Nintendo Cooper before about
two dollars at happy born day General
King David blessings thank you blessings
blessings we got Chris Jones five
dollars Super Chat lagnet's finest lagna
in the building yes here to see if Kai
got the Morrowind receipt oh yeah
you know what's funny about it
so that's because I have to see you he's
funny because like he always tried to
act like he got receipts on somebody and
I'm like the gaming history which
predates his time
like me and G to try to explain like you
could tell he does not understand so I'm
just like all right we gonna have to
educate him you know so Michael we got
to get in the dojo because we can get
either educated yeah say just imagine
this you still swimming in testes and
around that time is we was trying to get
our I had the alpha account for Xbox
Live yeah and this is what we were
trying to get this Xbox Live didn't
exist yet this wasn't there yet so it's
like it's funny to hear him say that
because I was like yeah
yeah but before before but we love you
Chris we love you we was worshiping the
sun
good to you Harry happy birthday my
brother King have a great show hashtag
hold the LIE
yeah we have Lord Turk as addict is
heating up his hot pocket or something
microwaves
yeah
taking juices juices chicken thighs what
are you doing over there the oldies fans
out here
we have Lord Adventure remember for when
you're two dollars which that King got
that special Duty Legend this morning yo
yes uh yes kinda yes yes yes
delicious
excuse me
now we have our Rd uh two dollar Super
Chat oh the Lord's buying a Gary Coleman
new series s wow
it's crazy moving on
moving on how is the original Little Man
Mr Drummond
it's Sam and Arnold I'm not doing this
I'm not doing this let's move on let's
go get it yeah we got a Dragonheart yo
remember 40 year five dollars happy
birthday to the living legend King David
listen man proud of your existence keep
inspiring us all all words of
encouragement now are there any words of
encouragement hashtag peace love life
yes my thing is never watch another
man's Pockets Endeavor never let another
man occupy space in your mind
some people they hit that whole Atlanta
baby
[Laughter]
Augustus member for 22 months Lord
bronze happy birthday King All Hail to
the commander of Xbox give this man his
roses if it wasn't for King some of
y'all would run for the hell this is
true I told people stop moving they're
like what
hey man we here thank you bro I love
this day for IQ no more no less
with the five euro Super Chat thank you
appreciate that then uh once again for
IQ no more no less with another
five-year-old Super Chat appreciate that
then we got Robert Kelly five dollar
Super Chat so the fact it's not turn
based means is not a real Final Fantasy
come in the Attic if this isn't Final
Fantasy and I don't want to play the
older ones then oh you don't want to
play the older ones then
um I understand from I I personally was
turned off from the action joint right
um I like my oh my RPGs like traditional
turn-based playing
card game wow and the action aspect I
think you should be able to give the
option to the consumer to play uh turn
base or to play action right and I think
you can it can work that way
um when you change it and I can
understand a lot of people saying it's
not Final Fantasy because of that yeah
it's funny because they supposedly
there's a mode that unlocks afterward
called Final Fantasy mode that a lot of
people thought was oh this is the RPG
mode nah it's just New Game Plus
we got zip David chat
I'm happy we finally have a new burnout
game to enjoy in 2023 whenever I play
ff16 on my console um my console crashes
and burns man I'm gonna take the Wings
off and take some pictures today uh we
got a thousand people in the chat we
only got 499 yeah
um it ain't gonna be a good show if we
don't get a thousand likes bro
we're gonna um oh you know what we get a
thousand likes addicts are gonna show us
thighs that was the only phase we're not
doing the only fans I see his wall right
there look nice none of that none of
that Casting Couch addict stuff I had to
get a nice twerk on
that's right you tried so hard to move
away from here to move away from it yeah
I already know what he's doing
butterflies
continue There we have let me see we
have four IQ no more no less until five
euro Super Chat as a wise man once said
he who goes to sleep with an itchy butt
wakes up with a stinky finger
this one is Sunday damn what's happening
aside have a wonderful birthday cake
happening today y'all out of pocket
continue yeah this is out of pocket then
we have C dub 813 305 5 super chat are
y'all going to get into in in that crap
show of the rock I guess it's not fair
are y'all going to get in on that crab
show of the rock Ally burning SD cards
don't use an SD card crashing definitely
need more time in the kitchen I guess
you could the thing is you could say
that about any Windows PC to be honest
with you
the UI stuff is is legit but y'all
forget that we are what in year two in
change
and steam deck came in Hot Pot the same
as with that same as it was they had
their own setups right right
uh let me see Dragonheart Yobe remember
for one year five dollars which had the
creative director who was behind WWF no
mercy hit the Yuki iwashida is also
behind Five forever so that's great
things that's a good thing because now
you know that the sort of brains behind
it
is are still intact and then to me you
see that when you play that game you
definitely see that
then we have Let's Play
Let's Go I get too excited let's go
let's go five dollars of a chat I'm a
wrestling fan too we have so much in
common I love wrestling in real life as
well
he's very creative he's very great I
have to say I have to say yeah very
creative can we have oh no it's Alex
absolutely salute I'm gonna need David
to head on down to my place and jump on
some chairs for a video
Five Seasons
salute though that was Alex told me
salute then we have cw13 305 20 Super
Chat honest question considering the
state of Halo gears redfall and a few
other releases do you think the
acquisition will make things better or
are we at the point that we look at game
passes Walmart quantity over quality
it's been there for a bit the quality
continues to grow and that's that's why
you getting the Starfield tax because
they can see they can see the road map
and the road map hopefully means quality
down the line so again it's a lot of
growing pains some games didn't hit
that's it but I I just think we're
acting like Game Pass ain't got dope
crap because you know what it is they
don't think about the third party stuff
to them it's like it's the first party
stuff hitting that's their business if
you buy Game Pass and you just only
playing Xbox stuff that's on you jack
I don't I don't care for what just just
to be fair at a curiosity do you give
do you get PlayStation props for having
Diablo
what inside this door you're not just in
the platform itself
Xbox on that oh my God
the thing is is like you can't get props
for people having other people's stuff
like most the time judgment is on what
they deliver no we're talking always
game pass as a whole so Game Pass as the
whole as the business model you need
third party third party day and date
games that come out this is what shows
what's different third party day in Day
games aren't launching in the
PlayStation uh Premier Service that's
it's just not happening like that this
is a good test bed for those unknown
titles to come out I think it works well
and then on top of that you have first
party AAA bangers that go there that
works
this chat in the chat you'll see what I
read it oh no see when I read it
out of pocket out of pocket right now
remember for two years two dollars we
said happy birthday General King David
hashtag Hold the Line slow happy born
day the king that we have let's play
with each other's joysticks once again
two dollars a percent speaking of
fisting
wow wow wow
you did that on the Lord today wow
my goodness okay Hollywood rules
remember for when you're 10 super chat
in Nola with the lady for the weekend
just wanted to show love thank goodness
for G Cloud so first exclusives don't
matter now Microsoft using brute force
uh Colin flip-flopping more than FTC
lawyer stop crying be nice
he said he said some left field stuff I
was looking at him like man oh man look
we could agree to disagree listen your
opinion is also valid yeah
totality of your box I got I'ma fight
like hell too
then we have face 23 bkny oh
20p is also on Jedi Survivor Xbox series
he ain't like kick going off and I'm
telling people that's the new standard
so so so if you like Jedi Survivor and
you like Final Fantasy you should be in
favor of that 720 720 baby
I don't want to hear nothing about you
guys talk about games not in 4k oh we
need to have six don't talk about
resolution and none of that no more
because y'all have destroyed your own
argument your favorite games play at 720
babe let's go
I'm gonna purposely read this one
incorrectly because it's uh
[Laughter]
thank you pinega Grandy
not called it by the correct
pronunciation I know exactly what he
said slick slick he would have got at it
yeah
sure then we have young uh young dread
52 young dreads 52 two dollars for chat
baby doing viral Lords I got you happy
birthday King happy birthday to the kid
they put the crust in the chat for Craig
hole again
make it so everybody has memberships
thank you appreciate it that's nice
that we got mad for ten five dollars to
protect good day Lords and happy
birthday General no doubt thank you
salute
Craig hooligan once again member for 10
month Lord bronze we got over a thousand
people in here hit that like button for
King's big day yes I don't want to see
attic Stars
[Laughter]
I mean we got a lot of topics for none
of uh no King gas to show up so that's
fine oh I Gotta Give It Up
that we have Mandingo Big Thicket five
dollar Super Chat
uh why are the ponies acting like the
avk deal is the end of the world you
think Xbox caress them in their no no
spot with the way they're behaving Jesus
oh my goodness show me on the teddy bear
where they touched you
this time time we got it let's put the
crest in the chat for panga Grande
yes welcome to the realm pinega Grand
deal we gonna get somebody set up
somebody
got a good guy with that baby then we
have Jacob Novick with a hundred sex
did threaten to not send ABK PlayStation
6 Dev kids if XBox uh the ABK and since
Phil is under oath to keep Call of Duty
multi-plat doesn't it mean that Xbox
can't make Call of Duty for px6 and the
next Xbox all together no
what he means is he's not gonna send
them the van stuff to figure stuff out
because they're sending it into the
competition exactly you get devil kids
when they're finished and we'll send it
to you but this symbolize the rub
because normally when you have the dev
kiss the earlier that you get them is
the earliest that you can start
preparing for the platform most of the
time they send them to very early right
and so what you're doing is you're
ensuring that you're going to have an
inferior product so you want Microsoft
to get breach of contract this is Jim
playing a game long down the road
all right we got stage 1X two dollar
Super Chat much respect our Lords happy
birthday King no doubt blessings brother
thank you so much we have sagging nut
sack
attack we're getting old King happy
birthday what's your take on the battle
of the Undisputed Canelo versus Charlo
um abbreviated version please very very
quickly but this is some things that we
have never seen before the fact that uh
Canelo left uh the zone and is going to
the PVC that means that he has to a
chance to fight both Charlo brothers
aerospence and um David benavidez he
chose to uh to fight Jamel I mean uh
yeah Jamel he was gonna fight Jamal
Jamal hasn't been in the ring for two
years haven't seen abbreviated yeah but
you know he's a boxing fan
um so Jamelle stepped up to take his
brother's weight and Jamelle has three
belts that's Undisputed canelo's
Undisputed this is gonna be the first
time it's gonna be a double Undisputed
fight they're gonna get a catch weight
and I believe that um Canelo loses fight
because Charlo has his problems with
boxers that move Canelo is a flat-footed
boxer that box is right in front of you
uh Jamel Charlo is a boxer mover and he
will give Canelo fits if Canelo can
catch him he can knock him out but I
don't think he's going to catch uh Jamal
I think Jamal wins by a split decision
No Doubt we've got Chris Jones five
dollar Super Chat Xbox still gonna buy
Square announcement before my birthday
next year March 3rd 2023. see you again
that's gonna be hard you mean 2024.
then we have heart gets to need five
dollars with chat let's play with each
other's joysticks is definitely holding
somebody's line yo that's cogswan I mean
um
my bad beefy my bad oh man yeah I own it
it's the beefy and chunky show
beefy season let's go yeah
why addict the only one without an Asus
Rock Empire
he tried to get my steam deck he's
trying to get steam legs
at the end of the day I'm I don't care
if I handheld like that I might you know
mess around with a steam deck but like
the Ally let one of them get that I
don't need daddy's life there you go
until they get in he playing that
something something that's surprised
[Music]
PlayStation 5 is a new George Foreman
Grill it's cooking
that we have wolf of Darkness with the
18 aeds I gotta look that up I'm sorry
uh greetings everyone wishing Xbox
Community Legend King David a very happy
birthday Hold the Line yeah thank you
hold the line Jesus we got chunk come on
give me one second uh Spartan goes 17
two pound Super Chat man oh man keep it
a buck 50 Gonna Keep it a buck 50 Colin
was capping dude that's like three two
three weeks ago already yeah but they
just put that video up yesterday ah
no we got pixel bit G remember for 41
months Lord bronze thank you sir
then we got black Ronin 357 let's put
the crest in the chat for Lord silver
appreciate you this pragmatic Eagle
let's put the crest in the chat for him
he gives the ten aisles
get those likes up guys we got over a
thousand let's go let's go we have Zach
dopney four pounds five pounds Super
Chat uh Xbox three behind but they've
got the friendliest and most welcoming
ecosystem and Community around happy
birthday to the king and love to the
Lord that is true would agree we gotta
we gotta save the New Jersey swamp moose
[Laughter]
solve when you get a chance Stage One X
is seeing his Super Chat when it's
missed but that's I read a stage one
accent okay no you may be good then okay
I definitely read it much respect iron
Lords happy birthday King if that's the
one okay we got it just in case okay uh
Zach Dabney I read that
um
Craig hooligan gifted one IOP membership
thank you brother appreciate that yes
Cedric H who gifted five IOP memberships
thank you so much I appreciate that then
we have Adney angrid for ten dollar
Super Chat forget Marvel and DC Phil
should get invincible dark man the
shadow make GI Joe like big Team Battle
Halo okay crazy they just recently
replace mechs in Titanfall with Autobots
Decepticons go after Thundercats acquire
the 80s okay hey they just recently said
that uh another Spawn movie starting in
development so yeah oh okay I know it's
supposed to be horror film yeah all
right that's cool then we have slow mo
back slap five dollars happy birthday
David and GeForce now with any laptop is
greater than any handheld GeForce does
it's popular now it is what's up then we
have Greg hole again once again two
dollar Super Chat for the swampy moose
Knuck
see your writing talent I know I want to
shout out to the entire team see
everybody up in there from the team and
do anything you know love to see that
the competition is always kind of thick
for this award and just the the quality
of the ride we really appreciate it we
had a lot of people kind of coming and
going but getting into that consistent
flow so again congrats Lords of
gaming.net team but now it's time to
celebrate you know a particular scribe
of Lords gaming.net that went Above and
Beyond in the month of June it's summer
games Fest coverage was absolutely top
tier because consolidation of the Xbox
game showcase also devolver showcase was
pretty dope and informative so we
proudly present the latest of the Lord
dizzy logneck scribe of the month to the
Magic Man returning again Lord Gene
shaft by how we doing sir all right I
just want to say we're super busy I'm
working on two previews I wasn't gonna
come on but then I thought it was
David's birthday and uh I want to come
on and wish you happy birthday
I appreciate that geez how much I love
you so bro easily the top four of my
favorite Lords of all time
well done well done well done well done
well done sir first of all is
oh
meant it that boy's minted man I
appreciate you brother you've been
killing it and we got more we'll show
some more things we got to do this [__]
right we we're gonna we're gonna be
seeing you a little bit more maybe
potential uh playing YC or some things
maybe well uh we're still talking to the
people at TGs to see if I'm gonna go to
Japan and then guys I'm hoping to reach
out to you guys to see if we're gonna go
to play crafting if that's still a thing
that's happening or not but we'll talk
about it no doubt put the crash up lord
it's a game down there so G my brother
appreciate you brother always top
quality work and again very Fierce
competition oh yeah yeah thank you all
right brother
and uh secondary plug that award in
honor of my brother dizzy Nutra of
talent this is behind the scenes at
lordsgame.net basically given the proper
credit to the unsung heroes who do the
lifeblood stuff the teaching you know
the editing you know making sure that
we're consistent in doing what we got to
do so in the month of June this editor
stepped up when a lot of this at your
team had a lot of responsibilities so
them away from log that but this this
editor stepped up into the role kept
things going smooth with his his
champion of octopath and the triangle
strategy I consider his his coverage
very complete dead of course that Lord
he's the lord of the very Paradox and
all Warframe news he's got his Warframe
shirt on he's doing it big we proudly
present the winner of the latest Lord
dizzy log debt editor of the month of
June my man Lord flame AKA Joe Repco
what's going on sir
thank you very much fog but obviously
whenever it comes slick Road I always
have to give it to the team because
without them I'd be basically nothing
basically without people like Gene who
have been killing it all month without
tying their amazing coverage of
everything regarding blizzard and
it covers other things I just can't
remember
oh dude listen to Warframe dudes
Warframe dudes getting out of pocket man
yeah without Chris as well whenever he
he recently reached his uh 100 articles
very emotional very though yeah please
it's a really really amazing article
very emotional it goes over his entire
Journey how he's feeling inside and
everything like that and being
vulnerable like that and putting that
out as an article is very
tough for some people yes
let's touch my heart so I'm really
trying to say thanks to the entire team
and thank you for keeping me around
you are very smart I appreciate it I
love the spice yeah yes we know you love
it I always vote for you
no absolutely yeah you are definitely
one of the key cogs literally to the
site and to see your journey and your
growth you know give you your flowers
has been really tremendous and you're
just like the epitome of consistency and
reliability so salute to you brother
holding it down my man Joe Repco log
there go check out the site sure a lot
of stuff go check out the must read
section we're really putting it down
over there and again the team is working
extremely hard like flame set so go
check us out are we good are we good
everybody
but unfortunately uh it's about 20
minutes before then so unfortunately I
can't go that's good brother hit me up
hit me up so I can get you you guys here
you're stuck right away yeah so you get
it away you get it two moves later yeah
happy Fourth of July to everyone in the
U.S the General's birthday at the same
time as the U.S
from Judge Corley in the Sony case with
their lawyers from the FTC this is
Microsoft and we are caught up by super
chats a quick shout out a personal shout
out for me yeah two friends from La Isla
del Encanto watching us hanging out with
them earlier this year
um so shout out to Jezebel and Angel who
are watching they send my wife a picture
like this is what we're doing right now
and me me reading some unruly Super Chat
no they understand English
like it's not Mandingo you gotta worry
about it
but thank you guys I appreciate it and
that's it we are caught up all right we
are caught up give me a second and get
stuff sent so I will I will pay bills
after yeah let's do that after after
Xbox Sega and Bungie we'll do that in
the middle guys
how y'all gonna wanna see Buck more than
y'all want to see addicts die actually
before we do that last week's balls
those [__]
to the question with Microsoft claiming
Sony actively signs exclusive
third-party games to skip their platform
and reduce Xbox Survival on the market
how do you feel Xbox should respond the
winner of the four-way ILP poll at 48 of
the vote was Xbox should acquire more
Studios for ownership coming in at
second place at 18 of the vote was Xbox
should invest more in their currently
owned Studios to compete in third place
super close 16 was I don't care put the
FTC on the stand and then last place at
very close 50 percent was nine
third-party exclusive games of their own
Lord attic the people want Xbox to own
more Studios thoughts
oh definitely yeah I think the biggest
thing they need to you know after the
Activision thing I do think they need to
stop like actively approaching companies
it's just like because we have seen some
forms of mismanagement with the studies
that they currently have and I think a
lot of that is just growing pains from
massively growing as fast as they've
have instead of you know just naturally
doing it a lot easier because I mean if
you grow a studio here and there over
like the next 20 years it's a lot easier
than we got five here we got seven here
and it's like it just happened so fast I
think they're still learning a lot of
you know Communications between
everything but I I think unless it makes
sense don't really overreach as of much
right now no doubt no doubt so that's
what we got so we're gonna get into it
this is a lot to discuss first before
I'm sorry again so one super chat before
yes please please JD game or 100 Super
Chat brother appreciate it Happy
Birthday King David it's been a great
year with you keeping these frauds in
life but letting the general come out
and rally the troops it's been a
wonderfully entertaining year and here's
for many more to come and we still out
here holding the line thank you so much
brother I appreciate it now salute JD
gaming we got our Geeks Chinese uh Super
Chat yeah so we got a song yes sir all
right so look first of all before we
start the topic shout out to the Realms
to see what half of gcp up in here
ksante what's going on my check sir can
I hear how we sound one two one two can
you hear me crispy crispy very fantastic
and then we got the homie making his
debut PK live in the building got a
chance to build with this brother out
there on the west coast and also Four
Guys record his own let me get a mic
check sir
yo there we go thank you thank you for
letting me in just more select fireman
in all entertainment right here A whole
host of 4gq TV
um definitely your cousins from along
the way thank you for letting me on
today no doubt appreciate you appreciate
it yeah hit me up in the DM it's like yo
you know get up there we got to talk
this topic because I was like yeah
that's great but I don't do the bookings
it's all good it's all good now we good
we got it we got it straight give me the
lane go get them do the alley-o we do
the alley you no doubt so no probably
gonna be talking for a little bit y'all
so bear with me because obviously
there's a ton you know stuff to discuss
here Microsoft versus FTC round two we
try to avoid most of it but look we have
to talk about is one of the hottest
things the trial of the century so to
speak and a lot of key points so look
I'm not going to talk about everything
but I have to focus on a couple of key
points that happened this week so excuse
me for my rambling all right Bobby kotik
takes the stand he has some things to
say um doesn't want to make Call of Duty
exclusive when asked if he ever thought
about making Cod exclusive to what
platform he said no we would alienate
over 100 million monthly active players
half of them play on phones but the rest
of them play on computer and PlayStation
and you would have a Revolt if you
remove the game from more than one
platform Bobby also said that it would
be very detrimental to our business to
take Call of Duty off PlayStation he
also talked about the Nintendo switch he
didn't think it was at first was going
to be popular he also admitted he was
wrong given that switch has now sold
well over 100 million units Bobby said
it was a mistake not to put Call of Duty
on the current switch and he briefly
spoke about how Activision will approach
future Nintendo consoles based on these
uh comments it seems that you know Call
of Duty will come to Nintendo consoles
once he gets detailed specifications but
any low-key reveal Nintendo's consoles
performance and power the new one will
be similar to that of the PS4 and Xbox
One so Five Below key like that went out
he also said Bobby is going to be the
most elected it's enough to run Cod at
60.
clearly yeah that's what it is he also
said oh Bobby said PlayStation will be
fine if the acquisition goes through he
said that Sony has an enormous
competitive advantage in its ability to
develop new IP and he decided the last
of us as an example of taking a video
game IP and turning it into a successful
multimedia franchise he expressed
confidence if the deal goes through that
Sony would remain competitive saying
Sony has the best game developers in the
world Sony is the most successful Bobby
he was his most successful consumer
electronics company of all time
Bobby said they have distribution
no
[Laughter]
Bobby said they have distribution in
every country every small town
everywhere in the world
what's that BDC even take a small town
and tie it down that's where he at like
Bobby was on the stand like he also said
degrading a PlayStation version of Call
of Duty doesn't make sense he argued
that the um Microsoft he said that um
they wouldn't do that saying the vitriol
would follow from Gamers and ensuing
damage to the company would be well
deserved he said that developers take
pride in their work and want to make
good games he's never heard of
developers making a subpar game for one
platform compared to another and this
was also reiterated by good friend to
the realm Lord Patrick rennet respawn
who didn't mention his words on Twitter
he said No Game Dev willingly tries to
put out an inferior release with less
quality and more bugs no one would do
that we want to make things that people
enjoy and we'll always try to ship the
best product despite any circumstances
for Jim Ryan to suggest otherwise is
asinine these are his words I'm just
repeating what he said all right and
then the other details that came out
after Bobby's
people took the stand he saw him there's
pretty much you know as far as such
there was a Sharpie that was yeah real
quick yes you know how they say when you
always accusing the other people of
something you probably doing it yourself
right it's like oh God we we do that
they might do that now
some other details was revealed in the
case someone with a with bad Sharpie
skills got in trouble because they
unsuccessfully attempted to redact
information on Sony and Microsoft
documents thanks to this we now know
that Horizon forbidden West and The Last
of Us Part Two costs more than 200
million to make uh shout out to games
industry.biz this revolution explored
the economics exclusivity where Sony has
certain advantages that enable it to
spend much more money on its AAA
offerings whereas most Publishers need
to rely on post-launch purchases such as
season passes and micro tracks
transactions to recoup course
exclusivity deals offering alternative
so by becoming a PlayStation exclusive
games like Final Fantasy 16 more or less
end up having the economic advantage of
a first party title Sony has most likely
waived most if not all of its platform
fee for the game and almost almost
certainly absolved some of the marketing
costs so that came out and now we're
here for the main event because I see my
man ever built so I'm gonna pull that
might check real quick sir just want to
make sure I hear you crispy yeah there
we go there we go go down real smooth so
for the main event shout out to VGC
Microsoft explored the possibility of
acquiring Sega Bungie and IO interactive
in recent years in November 2020 Phil
Spencer emailed CEO Satya Nadella And
the Company CFO Amy Hood requesting
approval to approach Sega Savvy with a
view to acquiring its game studios we
believe this is Phil's comments that
Sega has built a well-balanced portfolio
of games across segments with global
graphical appeal and will help us
accelerate Xbox game pass both on and
off console Phil added Sega is the most
attractive neck X acquisition Target due
to its Global PC catalog presence on
mobile and agent and Global brand
Affinity on Console through its classic
IP I like classic IP solve I like that I
like that I love that too well it's
unclear how Nadella responded to
Spencer's request Sega was also listed
on the mergers and acquisition's final
watch list this document was from April
2021. Bungie which was also laid
acquired by Sony and Zynga which would
go on to merge with uh Rockstar take two
uh was also both of those were also on
this mergers and Acquisitions list so
look a lot to unpack here you know a lot
of standouts a lot of talk you know
let's start with uh ksrt first man K you
know obviously it was a lot to unpack
here and then obviously the uh the Sega
Bungie you know in news as well so just
any thoughts of stuff that happened this
week and then obviously the Sega and
Bungie I I will talk
in general uh it's been an interesting
week right uh uh I I think we've learned
more uh I think somebody on my show said
that that uh that uh uh ABK versus
versus the FTC is itself an RPG and
we're the ones that are gaining all the
experience points yeah you know we we're
all galvanized at this process and you
know we're trading we're trading stories
and And discussing what some of these
things mean uh you know at the end of it
all I if we ever go through it again I
think you know if nothing else we we as
a community have learned a lot in in
this short amount of time with all the
all the the legalese that have been
thrown at us and things like that so I I
just found that super interesting I mean
I'm over here you know I work a
corporate job I I I will say I am
somewhat in an upper echelon in this
corporate job so I have people that rely
on me and instead I'm here fooling
around with speakers blaring because
we're trying to hear this thing and Mr
Mr ever born soccer couldn't get in so
now I'm blaming he's on speakerphone
just so he can hear what we're doing we
did this all day this is what was going
on nice you know it was it was just that
kind of a feeling you know so so for me
it was just super super entertaining and
super interesting and the the uh I've
always been kind of into the the minutia
of of processes so this is awesome I'm a
guy I'm one of those people that that
watches like like legal dramas you know
I mean so this was great yeah you're
getting all the dirt you're getting all
the details exactly exactly you know so
so in general at a high level I thought
that you know the it was a very
interesting process I appreciated the
fact that they let the the public at
least listen I wish we had been able to
see you know every once in a while they
kind of let it slip and the video would
come out and be like this small and then
they'd take it away you know for those
of us that got into the stream you know
but no by and large you know the uh um
um it's no it's no mistake that uh um
that most people who have been paying
attention say that the government has no
case and because of that they've been
kind of trying to find other ways around
to thread the needle I personally don't
think they did that with here but it was
very interesting to me to see all the
various ways they tried that you know
tried to discredit that right you know
things things like you know they'll
they'll they'll use they'll sit sit on
the fact that there is a there is a
marketing uh contract with PlayStation
until 2025 so that's good but the minute
that Microsoft talks about their
contracts no no don't believe them
that's the contract this fine print you
don't see it it's really fine but no
they're Liars who lie don't listen to
that you know it was very very it was
very you know the way they kept
threading that was super super
interesting very interesting you know he
they'd be on the stand and literally
under oath say the the most black and
white thing and then you the the lawyer
would then spend the next one you know
20 minutes poking as many holes as he
can and some of it was like kind of
naked on its face to the point where
even the judge had to be like come on
bro move on yeah just curly was outside
with moving things along yeah that's
right you know the the wrap it up B
music started playing you know
definitely some wrapping up the energy
let's say it takes for sure yes yes you
know yes yeah just call time
exactly you know so no but at high level
I really do think it was super
entertaining it was super interesting
for us the community to be a part of it
you know uh I I think we being as
galvanized as we were was necessary
because it kind of gave a little bit of
pressure to all sides of the official
proceedings because even though they
won't listen to of the console Warriors
and the and the Fanboys in the crowd
they do still see that man our 1 000
limit stream gets locked yes
every moment like there are some people
who waited the day before you know what
I mean
just just really quick now you said that
they don't listen to us but I spent five
days listening to the FTC using Pony
sure sure yes sir yes sir yes sir I
stand corrected yes absolutely they
don't listen to it absolutely well I I'm
I'm I'm presuming that you know while
they're going through the business of
doing of doing you know proper work
they're not listening to the kids in in
the hall yelling about it but I do take
your point that they probably listened a
little too much than they should because
some of those talking points
most like craziest Fanboys on Twitter
that's their brother or sister man this
is what you guys say this is what's
going down
[Laughter]
protecting the branch that's what she
kept going on you don't think that would
making any difference yeah she was she
has a very pointed comments I noticed uh
in reference to trying to understand you
have to see lawyer arguments and things
of that nature but uh what I think
before I pass it off from you um ksrt so
like in general like the other because
again focusing on the Sega and the
bungee part you know like now that you
see this information you know and it's
it's huge M A you know watchless man
like what was your thoughts when you saw
did you see the full one where they had
like the verbiage that said this is the
pros this is the recommendations yeah
like like what was your thoughts on that
so so I have to I have to be I have to
be absolutely honest and I'm here I'm
here in the realm with all my family and
all the all the Gaming Community my
first thought was oh damn I'm never
gonna hit it anyway all I thought about
ever bought a song
because I'm sitting there and I'm like
bro we authenticated like it's so good
to see but but we're going to go let
everybody get this moment because you
are his co-host and you you know
sometimes you try to keep our brother in
line with his expectations but to read
his words or these words of the paper
validating him so how did it feel so so
to be clear to be clear you know he and
I by and large feel almost identical in
in all all things okay I'm excited for
all this but as is our Dynamic he's the
Ying to my yang we keep each other in
line you know you know what I'm saying
so you know seeing this and it was like
as as pong Soul likes to call it the
honey-do list it was just so detailed I
was like oh my goodness it was so down
to the down to the Fanboy levels I was
like these guys spend too much time on
Spaces they were spitting about the
value
absolutely absolutely no but I I will
say like jokes aside yes I appreciate
the fact that what people have been
complaining about from Xbox for a long
time now oh stop the Mia culpa be
aggressive show some teeth they were
doing that they were really we're doing
that you're like that though that like
that's too much
Sony in the background was doing what
Sony do to you know try the new sniping
absolutely absolutely see I like I I the
the takeaway from all the background
that came out of this was I gotta put
respect on Booty's name man you gotta
put respect on their name you know
and I'm not I'm not gonna go there
because it's PG-13 today I'm not doing
it I usually can't help myself but I'm
gonna fight I'm not gonna do it but no
honestly you know people and that's
that's that's that's the thing we hear a
lot in the community oh show some teeth
be aggressive you know they don't put it
on Front Street but clearly they are
hearing you and they're taking those
actions and I thought that was super
interesting how it goes from here we
shall see yeah but I I the fact that at
least on in the emails and you know and
when they're talking amongst themselves
they are as Cut Throat as some of y'all
want them to be that is refreshing news
The Next Step I gotta talk about my Sega
bro ever born Saga you know us us is
often say the kids we didn't have a home
you know say at the start of the whole
generation you know what I mean we were
looking for a place to go and it just
felt refugees you know we were left
refugees and we just felt like Xbox was
the place to go they seemed a little
familiar right so you know what I mean
you saw you saw some remnants of Sega in
there you saw some titles on the OG X
Box right and you're like okay baby I
could I could you know have find shelter
here but we figured what happened out to
our beloved Sega so ever bought a saga
man like when you get a chance to read
these documents you see Phil's comments
you see the aggressive push and the
descriptive nature of why Sega is value
to Xbox and why they wasn't crowded how
did it make you feel brother
he's quiet he's overjoyed
it's Beauty clearly he muted sir he must
be muted he's Beauty he's building it
he's always muted there you go that was
that was Jim Ryan
so how does it feel something that's
what I gotta say let's go is they
thought I was wrong but I knew it all
along
now now check this out all right and I
want to I want first of all happy
birthday to King I already told you in
Italian
now I want to give a shout out to King
David because he gave Phil the first
name which is Phil Dominus Maximus it
really is Spencer but but King also has
introduced a new form to fulfilled with
his Darth feel
Darth Phil the Destroyer
oh my God
and so uh and I want I want to point
this out and this part is a little bit
for you sobs you know
Bill heard that Starfield was going to
be exclusive you know what he did
he said I want all that you want to try
to make Star feel exclusive cool I'm
taking sentiment and then and then Bobby
K came up to uh Phil and was like if you
don't get out and lay down I'm gonna
pull Activision content off you know
what Phil did he said I want that
Bobby that was that was a stick up Bobby
said 80 20. take it or leave it that's
right okay he took it all right
guess what let's go now there are people
that said this one's for you song
Atlas they just don't they don't care
about
Xbox they're never going to do anything
and then we find out just like Cinemax
just like Activision
oh okay Atlas you don't want to put
Persona on the platform Target on your
back
oh man it's on site and if we if we if
we look look at the final hit
Sega was on there as of April of 2021
yes right now I want to now that could
have been all going on then we get to
know then we get to
um November yes
when uh that's when we heard the uh
um the Activision talks first started
yes yes so
we're talking to Sega we're working
something out you know what else got
announced in November of 2021 it's
called partnership on super game yes so
they said Hold On
and they said by the way anything Atlas
does if Atlas sells a dime bag
announces a new game oh it's gonna be on
our stage
so they skipped us all this time but not
anymore
are you saying that that that Microsoft
gave them this uh strategic partnership
and told them hold the line for a moment
s
good at it I was gonna say imagine like
them getting uh flight tickets in the
mail and it's like why are we going to
L.A they have to come say oh you're
gonna be on Microsoft station next week
uh say what
so so the thing is right and I can't
find the Xbox
right so so now because what we want is
we we want Sega to be back in the
platform business again okay so that
Nintendo and Sony
uh can can can uh so say you can get
their revenge on them
how does this open the door I'm saying
doing their own thing they're going to
be they're going to be running that show
oh this is Deliverance
everybody soccer.com go check out the
book this is a great series are you
speaking from like the term that they're
about to like take over from the inside
one of those things where they burn a
curtain bro yo Sega gonna walk in the
building right they're gonna get bought
they're gonna be like yeah so you know
how Bungie gets to put all their games
on all these platforms
and we're gonna be like nah you ain't
fun [__]
to be fair though in that in the
documents
I saw that yeah but the re the reason
for that and I I think it's smart even
though I don't like it right right now
Xbox is kind of non-existent in Japan
right we can all agree that yes so they
would have to go to Japanese regulators
and say good point one of your biggest
Publishers yep we're effectively going
to pull them out the country because
nobody has an Xbox
I think it would get shut down and they
have to do that until Xbox raises uh its
presence in the region oh something you
don't like it but we got we got to deal
with it but that's fine I'm 100 behind
that right well yeah it's just like Sega
trying to take over Xbox with the inside
look don't feed everybody with these a
couple of years
hold up a couple years they're on stage
King and they sitting up there and they
talking like we have done as much as we
can as the Xbox brand they just burn the
front it's like slower man now we're
second 2.0
doing a lot of the stuff that Phil does
now it's like we we've come to Xbox
because we've believe in their vision
and their Vision was our vision 10 15
years ago but but let me finish this up
so the thing is
um when they asked Sega about this
Sega didn't say outright no they said
not right now take it easy
right because they had to ask Sega
because sega's stock price on this news
was the highest it had been since 2007.
right yeah so we know they got the
partnership for the super game we know
Atlas can't speak unless they talk to
Xbox first
show me a lot you can't say that I'm
wrong you told me you talking again so
we know that they can't stop talking
about how good Xbox is to them in Game
Pass and then they even said when they
got asked about this what they said Xbox
value Sega more than anything oh yeah
Sony values Sega yes and they said well
would you consider a operation they said
well easy right now not right because
you know what it's hot we know not right
now means they're in the middle of
something right now when they're done
with that it will no longer be right now
so we're gonna spin the block we're
gonna come back right and I just want to
point out to Mr K Asante you know who
wasn't in that let's Embrace a group oh
we'll be doing that was before but that
was before embrace it was doing a full
conspiracy theory there with the titles
of embrace actually that they're hiding
for Microsoft was in that direction I
actually yeah I I have a different
conspiracy theory oh so we all have oh
go for it
thank you actually solve solved you have
to send me a 10-pole hat for a problem
and wrap it around your head let
everyone cook and then I gotta get PK I
gotta get PK Sega uh uh Square was also
on the list because Phil's anybody that
was pulling games from XBox they was on
The Hit List
this is ill this is it hold on I'm sick
okay okay I'm saying fit matter of fact
that booty is Agent 47.
you're the basic writer
your creative juices are flowing so you
telling me so the plan was okay they're
locking us out of exclusives right
they're taking these third-party
exclusive deals so we gonna Target the
ones that they have made exclusive and
own those companies that will be doing
everybody that's what that's not what we
doing that's what they did is on the
paper in the documents
this is the thing so we all listen we
can see right now from this trial that
Xbox has to play by a double standard
not only in the media we always knew
that but also you can see it in the
court that this whole five days was how
dare you make a plan to have anything
yep the whole thing was true how dare
you not operate as a for-profit
organization we thought you were
absolutely
right so the all the nice talk that you
see in public is because they already
knew that they have to operate by
different rules as Sony but in the
background
it's world domination baby it was Order
66 or I won't stop you right there
because here's the point of contingency
and then like after this I got it when
you respond I gotta get pkn all right
now here's the big point of contention
that I'm seeing right now in the streets
right a Christian I couldn't find
tinfoil my bad all right no doubt so the
court point of contention
oh I couldn't find aluminum yeah so the
point level boy is that people are
saying you know that there is a distinct
difference there's one thing to make a
third party exclusive but it's another
thing to own the company and then this
okay
but I just want to be fair to the other
side the other side is saying these are
Brute Force tactics right away they're
trying to be fair to the other side they
don't make no sense half the time we're
being balanced here
we gotta uh protect the consumer not
Sony
Bros
are like the FTC one
it wouldn't make sense yeah I'm sure
they got beefy checks over there
corporate [__] always respected the
gangster of Jim Wright where y'all were
making nicknames I didn't I didn't
engage none of that Hyperbole and I told
y'all son got influence in them in the
territory everybody and then when the
blocking went down anyway this is not
about me moving back on them so the
question yeah the question is is it
wrong to be cheering on this aggressive
Brute Force nature of owning a company
versus doing it quote-unquote the
traditional way which is the third party
exclusive organically
I got you I got you so here's the thing
if it was just business then
don't cry now right so if if you want to
talk about business and these see here's
the thing the status quo
benefits the haves it becomes power
right now and that whole idea of let's
continue to do it the way you used to do
it because that happens to benefit me
we've see we've seen this in every Walk
of Life and in every argument of it of
everything nobody wants to upset the
apple cart and it's only the people that
benefit right now that tell you this is
the true god-given way of doing things
but but here's the thing even if you
want to take it from uh why are we doing
it this way why are we doing it that way
the people saying that would be totally
fine if Microsoft went the way of Sega
they won't say that out loud but they'd
be absolutely happy if that was the case
here listen to this right if you do not
if you're not the market leader right
you now if I want to go do a final
fantasy deal I have to pay Square
more than they expect to make off of all
of uh of Sony's uh what do you call them
so it's gonna cost me three four times
the amount plus whatever they're
projecting to making profits from the
thing so that just goes that narrative
just do it out outbid sold it yeah right
so you could do that but then you have
to weigh that against how many new
customers will this bring into the
ecosystem and how many how much will
those customers spend in order to make
this a positive financial transaction
and how long over how many years will it
take for you to turn the tide so that
you were the market leader and these
things come down right every one of
those deals you do would be you'd lose
money on them if you lose money the
course of a decade and no one is going
to do that so
you're either gonna lose money over a
decade for the hope that you will bring
enough people over for IP that you don't
own because we saw this happening in the
360 area right talk to him he did all of
that and then when they were no longer
market leader all of those games that
they launched on their platform I don't
even know you remember you remember Mass
Effect yes right you you you remember
you remember uh pray you remember all of
these other things that were were on
exactly on Xbox but they got no benefit
of that they helped develop these things
they money had it and they did all of
that no benefit when they were no longer
on top so the amount of money they would
have to spend
it's almost cheaper for them to just go
and buy the publisher and then they make
a decision of where they're going to put
this and put that so everyone is the
mentality of renting versus owning it's
the mentality so short-minded
individuals that rent and I'm not saying
you you do what your wallet calls for
right right so if your wallet calls for
you to rent is beneficial for you to
rent if your wallet calls for you to own
is beneficial for you to own and there's
certain perks that comes with ownership
we've said ownership you can rent to the
renter right you can you can say hey
Sony you like this we will rent this to
you right because you own an IP and at
the end of the day when you raise the
price to The Brick if the brick get hot
and it go up in stock in value you have
Equity instead of
um options you're able to say well we're
going to raise the price oh well we
can't really go well then you have to
leave you have a 30-day notice
and we will get other people that can
afford our prices right and that's
that's what ownership is about the
problem right now is you have a bunch of
people with the renters mentality
looking over at Microsoft saying man why
don't you rent yeah Microsoft said no
there's equity in owning we understand
what owning is we did that renting stuff
for years and we have nothing when we
left we left the apartment and all we
did was take our stuff that we came with
now they know better they do better you
guys are upset because they know better
you do better so so and that's the point
and this is the last thing I'll say on
this if you if you ever ran a business
right do you go and guess whether you're
gonna lose money for a decade because
that's probably what it would take to to
turn the tides around on on IP you don't
own would you do that just to make some
people on Twitter and YouTube
or would you say I have the money
I'm gonna buy the IP why why should they
spend more than the other side of
spending to make you happy
it doesn't make sense and they know that
it doesn't make sense but they're saying
this as though they're on a moral High
Ground oh Purity talk worshiping a 100
billion dollar company versus other
people that are fans of a two trillion
dollar company you're not on any moral
High Ground you said it was just
business when content was taken away
from people now you're crying because
content might be taken away from you I
have no tolerance for that argument at
all
walk it don't even walk down my street
with that argument
I mean it's just it's the scale right
it's the difference the difference is
just scale yeah the scale right because
it's one of those things where okay I
take one thing from you and you slap the
whole tray out my hand
yeah so and and that and that is the
thing and the argument comes from the
fact that they can't go there they can't
go there
wait a minute let me let me call Reggie
fesame when I say that Sony's problem
yeah that is not mine and by the way if
we want to talk about scales and ratios
and things like that did you know that
both companies spent 3.3 percent of
their market caps at the time when they
made these Acquisitions for Bungie
there we go
33.3
my 3.3 versions
3.3 get you a bag of chips my 3.3 get me
a spread on the ship
3.3 looking like this oh man yo put your
3.3 back in your pocket
kid you gotta stop talking yo that's
what you
pulled your 3.3 out
loud
they're going there to buy a car from
the dealerships like look we don't got a
car for you but I can rent you something
there's a lot of it's a lot it's a lot
of pocket you're getting a city bike
when you go over there
last day I gotta get PK come on the last
thing we keep talking about organic
growth while we ignore that all your
favorite games from Sony came from
Studios that they acquired went to
Spider-Man they acquired that studio
they don't even own that IP you point to
naughty dog that's a studio they
purchase gorilla they purchased them too
right 21 Studios
is what Sony purchased in in their
history and right now
if we're not counting ABK because that
didn't happen yet I think x Microsoft
might be at something like 28 including
the ones that they closed so so again
let's not pretend that you're on some
moral High ground or there's some
virtuous cycle
box was doing
service games Sony's making 12 service
games but right hoverboard they care
about the industry the consolidation of
the energy is there they don't care
they're this is I this is you know
what's the worst thing for me when
somebody talks to me and they think like
they think I'm stupid
like if you if you if you're gonna make
an argument make an argument like you
have some respect for my intelligence
you know what this is about when they
say these things and I'm tired of it and
I'm telling you right now if that I've
been collecting receipts for the last
eight years
I'm not joking I know you're not joking
you're crazy
listen come on you got it we got to be
better we got to be we gotta if things
happen the way they we anticipate
potentially they happen we got to be
respectful with it
you see why we argue
you have been you have been storing
those receipts for a reason
convince you I know they got beefy
checks over there you don't need none of
that yeah
can prevent
from speaking
is Elon Musk with his Tweet stuff that's
the only person you should be worried
about right I'm gonna tell you right now
once the deal happened because people
with this stuff once the deal happened
we're gonna have to lock corporate Cog
out
these news here we're gonna have to say
it's gonna be one of the things where
it's like if you get us I'm not going to
be able to lock that behind like a like
ratio I'm saying you know we get over
500 likes no it's like we get five likes
just so they get the message
you know I try to keep it fan bass
Evermore those are bars gotta get PK in
the building they're very patient
brother so obviously we see a lot of
information that's been going on with
this trial this week and obviously you
know one of the highlights was Bungie
you know what I mean as well as Sega you
know what's your thoughts on the trial
this weekend just in general about the
potential of you know news of them
acquiring them
so first I want to do a shout out to
everyone in the chat thanks for coming
through definitely have any thanks this
is Dolores house I am a guest for the
Lord says I appreciate that appreciate
it um shout out to everyone and
definitely ksati I haven't seen these
guys in a while so shout out to you guys
I'm gonna definitely want to make sure
you guys got your fire out and you want
to answer her up
my thoughts my thoughts is I put it this
way listen
um
there's a lot of stuff that came out
that's just kind of validated what we
already knew
um
you know we know we also had some
surprises you know Elder Scrolls 6 in
2026 yeah
um
and honestly watching or listening
because I got in the zoom call every day
you know oh nice so he was up in there
I was trying to figure out
is this real
[Laughter]
no I said I was serious thinking I made
it clicked on the wrong link because I
promise you I didn't think this was real
like they were really I yo first I also
I want to give a shout out to judge uh
judge uh Jack Corley for allowing us to
listen in on Zoom this is abnormal right
this is not a normal thing so shout out
to her for even putting up giving us the
ability to listen in to this uh you know
these jab turkeys anyways up
is like like check this out man let's go
I want to say for everyone who's out
there who is emotional all right don't
be emotional about this all right
first these people go so hard about this
this tribalism Brands right Gamers go
where games go right ain't nobody gonna
stop and we all got a preference and
that's cool that doesn't stop you from
playing anything
all right it doesn't oh and this is my
slogan I go I stand by live by you play
games and not companies relax all right
relax stop pocket watching nobody even
talked about anybody going buying 500 uh
psbrs to play mediocre games nobody
cared about that and you that means you
paid a thousand bucks so when you talk
about all the judge thinks everybody has
a PC
that we talking about your phone cuz
your favorite game is Twitter you spend
most of your time trashing on the
console you don't want you don't want to
play that's why 15 of you don't buy the
first party games
like that oh man am I am I tripping 15
yeah
I'm sorry let's be real
Persona has more stock than Final
Fantasy I'm just being honest right now
hello Persona has more yo it does so at
the end of the day Persona goes
exclusive if that should that ever
happen that's gonna rock the house over
there and it and look you know what's
crazy Japan is so small
Xbox can keep that multiply there but
only make it exclusive in the West
that would be interesting think about
this anybody in the in in the chat tell
me and I'm sorry I I just want to know
is PSO 2 online is that on PlayStation 5
in the US from my understanding no I
think no it's not I don't think so and
get them absolutely yeah it's a natural
okay I see what we're doing good it's a
natural progression
to go ahead and have this Xbox Dreamcast
as the next console let's just be real
let's just make it Dreamcast 2 is the
net code name you sound like other boy
I've been seeing this for a minute bro
anybody could tell me that the the Xbox
is the Spirit uh successor there okay
now I agree with you yeah no I believe
it or no for sure absolutely I agree
with that like we was refugees
America came from over there came to
Xbox got it together and here we are
right Peter Moore shout to them Legend
that's right yeah they started he
started the the rambunctiousness yes yes
right right so and then I want to ask
how many of y'all who all have an
opinion it's not the panel this is
everyone you know the PlayStation stands
because we all PlayStation fans but
there's some that go to the extreme side
of things and I just want to know how
many of y'all run a multi-billion
Million Dollar business and then you
want to give your opinion on what
someone should do with their money and
things you buy let me just ask you
something if you go buy a car
that maybe it was used and somebody else
drove it but you bought it but since you
bought it I want you to remain allowing
the public to ride around and drive
how would you feel about it I just want
to ask with that same mindset would you
be okay with making your car public
property because you said
you saying that just because you buy we
still want you to share I just think
it's crazy that you know reading Jim
Ryan he's like yo
I'm not signing this until you give me
all the Bethesda games back and make
sure that every other Activision
Blizzard games are still Multiplex
ain't that his right to do that as a
Siege of the leading company with
leverage trying to understand well I
mean ain't that what snitches do oh let
me tell you a snitch is going to tell
you I know all your secrets I know where
you pump it I go tell the cops right now
so if you're gonna give me the brick for
under this and go ahead and and I want
the other stuff that you was giving out
there too back I want it back I want it
all back baby so you don't think that as
a CEO trying to protect his spot his
spot is rocking if you open up across
the street with the best product you
think he ain't gonna he gonna stop there
he gonna he gonna send the cops to you
everything right or wrong is that now
you ain't saying that but the truth I'm
just putting out there and asking
questions right so I'm trying to
understand
if y'all haven't ran a multi-billion
dollar company a business how do you
have any input right and they just like
the spot
they respond to go
across the street
this is hilarious we don't want our our
favorite pizza place to move but you
know things it's got to happen
if I open up a hot and ready across the
street your DiGiorno gotta go hey hey
some people still want Blockbuster
around but guess what we had to get them
out of there we gotta adapt and move it
yo and for those who say organic growth
let's go where's that same energy yo
nobody complaining about ATT they didn't
have a cell phone cell phone division
they just both circular they bought
DirecTV come on man Apple Amazon are you
implying that consolidation happens all
the time outside all these industries
and that this is An Occurrence that
happened
I should be afraid of this I should be
scared and this is the death of the
industry PK that's what I was saying
it's almost like it was the first time
it ever happened like just be careful
okay don't you think that the people
that they that they like organic growth
shouldn't play Spider-Man because the
outside gardening in the back that's
what they should be doing they shouldn't
be attended today garden spider man come
on we couldn't even get Spider-Man on
the Xbox or PC version of Adventures
yeah but guess who played the game
it wasn't them so they wasting time and
money and and and let me just say this
Jim Ryan was so he was such a man you
know he thought he you know he's a man
in these emails but why can't he just
sit down and get his teeth fixed I'm
sorry oh come on all right
all of this stuff is just saying to us
that yo these companies are doing
exactly what we always thought they were
doing now it's just coming now it's
coming out and I'm just saying we're not
we're not The Crazy Ones is what I'm
getting yet they call me crazy and we
understand how business works but what
I'm trying to tell the other people out
there that is Extreme is first of all
you got to relax you gotta understand
that if you're a true gamer would you
call yourself
then you would go with a games play
because guess what if you want to play
Mario or Zelda where do you go yeah for
people to have a problem
what's your problem what you feeling to
see is they will go with the games go
but what if we take that platform away
from them
I mean you you gotta go where to
platform is I don't want I don't like
that because I don't like the box look
I like how my PlayStation
most of them haven't even tried that's
the problem I don't want to try it
I mean it looked like it I like blowing
in my controller oh come on boys I know
some people like to blow oh
I got a microphone these two I don't
like these two together we got the
PlayStation Wars
we got to clean this up gentlemen we got
to clean this up
for real yeah I just want to say that
everybody in this panel and everyone who
understood legit logical sense of this
whole thing know that hey you talking
about I know Microsoft the problem is
they look at Microsoft as the company
and not Xbox's division who has to self
Supply them cells right right and and
don't they're not trying to separate
that they but they have to because
they're two different they have to
supply themselves in order to be
successful so if this is the move they
gotta make and he has to go to the
chairman to get the funds to get it done
and the Chairman's behind you that means
he sees the vision you gotta understand
it's not us fighting against
corporations I'm trying to tell people
stop vote for your wallets you want
competition because that's how you get
better products like a long time ago
when I used to work at Time Warner Cable
I told these people the same thing the
the the
CFO got up he was an older lady she told
us in in a company meeting that people
don't want fast internet I swear to God
I am not making this up until Google
Fiber hit them in Kansas City and came
out with one gig and only thing they can
offer is 100 Megs for the same price oh
then they had to change their own
strategy
that's all I'm saying is good point so
it's it's competition drives Innovation
you gotta have it and I'm sorry I'm I'm
around with this but I'm just saying
that's why I keep telling you guys and I
want you all you guys out there who
don't understand and may disagree and
it's okay if you do but listen to this
tagline and let it sink in play games
not companies and I swear to God your
life would be better talk to them PK
on that point right like uh the one
thing I will say like I like Jim is was
doing what he was supposed to do he took
a gamble yes I think he's gonna lose
that gamble but that's what he was
supposed to do for who he was
representing because it was like
basically why am I going to help you get
this thing if I am I'm gonna try to get
everything out of it if not I'm gonna
tie my hand say what I say and there's
really no sweater off my back fine right
but at the same time don't don't cry
because you know what that made me think
of you remember dark night when the dude
was like oh I know Bruce Wayne is Batman
I'm a tell and then and and then Morgan
Freeman was like you mean you wanna
say something about the billionaire who
beats people up at night for a living
good luck yeah you want to threatening
this guy who right so so okay you wanna
you wanna try to play hard you know like
you want to get xenomax Activision cool
good luck but to but again I I think you
your your point is is very like apt
right these are uh businesses and they
they are well within their right uh to
do business and we gotta take morality
out yes let's stop pretending one side
is more virtuous yeah
you got to look out for you facts that's
why it's funny with all this period you
talk about the right way to do things
it's kind of hilarious continue because
yeah no no no you're good I'm just
saying that's why you want this to
happen you want them to compete so that
both Sony and Xbox step they game up
because Amazon is still it's the largest
cloud provider in the world I don't want
I don't know if I I know that a lot of
people don't think Amazon games is going
to make a splash but they got the cash
and they got the the the the
infrastructure it's not like they can't
make big big moves too and then you hear
uh Comcast trying to get into it too
come on man everybody sees that money
and they're gonna go for it so do you
really want to go down that route and
have these that don't really care grass
snatch stuff up and then you have to go
get a Luna you don't even know what Luna
is you don't even know what that is yeah
get Comcast you said we go where the
games are yeah but I'm just saying you
see but that's two different things if
they happen at the Capitol in order to
clean up the industry in the way that
they see fit Money Talks BS walks so if
they happen to get it we got to go play
Luna right I mean under your logic the
logic is we gotta go where the games are
and uh for the record I will tell you as
a person who's played Luna it's pretty
good it's not bad it's Windows based
it's pretty good the reason why they are
not you know promoting it is possibly
strategic but from a gamer's perspective
you will play Luna and have a good time
that was the frustrating thing about
this whole uh case and all of that nice
that we talked about regular everyday
competition as though because Microsoft
was doing it it was anti-competitive
right if you listen to all of their
testimony they were they were basically
like how dare you consider making
anything exclusive
and we spoke about that on the show and
I still haven't gotten you to give me
that answer and I want someone to
somehow make that make sense because
it's to your point exactly what you're
describing right now even if they took
the entire thing exclusive and this is
the new nuclear option what I mean by
that is not only is Call of Duty
exclusive they then look at the
PlayStation store and rip away any and
every Activision game found on the
PlayStation short today that's the
nuclear option full foreclosure right
based on the government's own numbers
right all the numbers translates
eventually to potentially 5.5 percent of
the existing console based switching to
PlayStation uh to Xbox so if you're
talking about a high performance wait
only analysis are you talking about the
same people who would switch from
PlayStation Xbox for a Christmas skin
okay
so if if we're talking about just that
5.5 of those people right and of course
this is the government who's also tried
to say that the Abacus forgive me the
Nintendo switch is now part of the high
performance console market right no but
for real like let's assume they're right
it's not part of the high performance
console markets and I was one versus the
other right so you're telling me that in
this market where it's one versus the
other and only 5.5 will switch so then
the rest are still on PlayStation and
still we're having this conversation
right this is Eva bonus point right and
and well I'll take it a step further
right because what is frustrating about
this forget about being an Xbox fan or
whatever really a Sega fan who's just uh
what you're fighting this time
but
you're watching the the Federal Trade
Commission get up and say it is our job
to defend a corporation from losing a
marketing right and and so and think
about this right this is not me saying
it this is not hyperbole as they Define
the market high performance console
Market with only two players Xbox and
PlayStation and acknowledge that
PlayStation is the market lead because
you know only PlayStation and Xbox are
have ninth gen consoles right well
either two of them have knife gen
consoles by definition their entire
argument is to defend PlayStation I
don't care what however you stand on
whether Microsoft should or shouldn't
get this the ftc's argument is we need
to protect PlayStation and it was so bad
that the judge had to remind them so we
are not here to protect Sony we are here
to protect consumers and 80 percent of
the testimony and all their things were
about PlayStation potentially losing
five percent five point five percent
market share even that was based on made
up numbers but we can talk about that
later the point is if this is what we
are this is what we're doing this is
what we're spending 18 months doing this
is what we're fighting against this is
what we're going to a federal court to
say that the market leader cannot lose
5.5 market share this is what your tax
dollars are going for um and and we are
The Crazy Ones for being incensed by
this
look these are bars these but I got to
get the lawyers I got to get the Lords
in because it's a spicy one Lord addict
you know court case Guru you know person
that listens to all of them
I did listen to the Jim Ryan one I
didn't listen to the other ones I just I
was very interested to hear what Jim
Ryan had to say you wanna one thing is
you want to combo it or you want to go
on a second no I can wait for the gym
Ryan okay no doubt all right when it
comes to the the second thing I do think
that's still a possibility I I don't
think that that chapter is closed
if you notice around the same time they
say they approach Sega is when Sammy
started separating all their assets and
and financials from Sega so I think
there's a reason they did that if if
they didn't buy Activision I'm convinced
they would already bought Sega because
once once you go into this process for
Activision look Sega and I have uh like
my little Square Enix Theory like even
though those companies are dominant and
they have a lot of pool a lot of ips
they can't compete with a Call of Duty
you know if they can get their hands on
Call of Duty it benefit them drastically
from here going out Call of Duty King
blizzard you know it's like the trifecta
ABK is literally everything Xbox
currently needs yeah it is a dominant IP
for something like uh Game Pass which is
Call of Duty it is a huge presence in
the PC market which is Blizzard and it's
a present in the mobile market which is
King it's literally everything Xbox and
play in uh Xbox and Microsoft needs
that's the reason they dropped
everything you know I wouldn't be
surprised that list they would have
bought like five to seven of them by now
but when that Activision thing popped up
they're like we have to drop everything
we have to go straight for for this well
because there will be never another
opportunity
where one of these platform holders can
own facts Call of Duty blizzard
and King I actually feel like I feel
like Square Enix was probably a good way
in development of buying Square Enix
because like
I remember Jess Gordon post uh posting
an article saying that some of the
issues between Square Enix and Xbox is
Xbox's fault
and if I go but if you go back and you
look at remember it's a 2000 at the end
of 2019 is when they did the proposal
for square inks this wasn't like an
acquisition letter or they weren't just
on a list this was Phil Spencer
uh you know it was it was a a prompt to
buy the company right and I think that
that went farther because obviously even
if they started in late of 2019 guess
what ended up start happening all the
final fantasies just miraculously
started coming on Game Pass day and day
when they came to the platform you got
the Dragon Quest games those came there
you got occupied traveler out of nowhere
that's true it's not even on PlayStation
yeah then you had Phil Spencer talking
very highly saying that they were going
to get Final Fantasy 14 on the platform
and that never happened
then something happened in 2020 to one I
I don't know what I think it was
it was a variety of things because at
that time too the Final Fantasy
7 remake exclusivity should have started
being running up and it didn't it was
extended for no reason to this day we
still don't know what happened with that
it's just a lot of things don't add up
unless Microsoft was and talks to them
maybe they didn't come out to an
agreement maybe the agreement fell apart
and they were going to buy Square Enix
and it could have been all the way up to
they're like look let's see how the Game
Pass things do in 2021 then we will talk
about this in 2022 and then what
happened yeah ABK happened interesting
Dairy and then since APK the
relationship hasn't been the same so no
it hasn't been the same for a while and
it's just like how you go from having
that much
of a good relationship with Square Enix
in a matter of a year and some months
because if you look at it they announced
APK in January
they sell the Western divisions in
August
ABK uh
Square Enix did yeah yeah Crystal D and
Crystal D yeah so they sold them in that
month and they keep in mind
every Western Division that Square Enix
sold
is working with an Xbox Studio like it's
like there was a contracted place down
Galligan the crew it's like there was a
you know it's like there's a contract
that was in place oh you you you were
implying things look
I I I get it people that's why I set the
tinfoil how I actually really did look
for it
I couldn't find aluminum foil
I'm sorry I actually I messaged Grace
and told her to bring me a little bit
you would try to get into character look
I feel look we got we got to move
forward this is a long one but uh some
of us been patient a lot to process here
fellow Sega Brethren you know we come
from that reading all this stuff about
that and Bungie which we really haven't
talked about either and IO and the
general news of the week where do you
stand with all this information round
two Microsoft versus the FTC
I mean it just it really does go back to
the idea of the worry on PlayStation's
part is that
Microsoft is doing it the Playbook is
the same it's it's a choir it's it's put
these things under our umbrella the only
thing that the scope of what Microsoft
is able to do just outpaces them
dramatically where you have one one
Studio purchased then you have a
publisher purchase it's a different it's
a different Dynamic completely and it
has it does have the ability to shift
the Dynamics of how everything is done
right so I understand that fight and
that argument I think what baffles me
about this hearing is this continued
argument about things that on the
surface as people who look at the
industry and pay attention to it none of
these arguments ever were gonna we're
ever gonna hold weight none of them not
a single one I can't believe that
they're still sitting here questioning
Bobby coding and Satya Nadella about oh
can you play Call of Duty on the TV in
the cloud
um what does this mean what does that
mean and it it goes back to sort of the
incompetence of the people that are sort
of arguing these things and and the fact
that if you were really in Earnest
trying to stop this from happening the
arguments would be totally different and
they're and they're just not so it in
looking at all of this like I just I
kind of look at it and I'm like yeah it
makes 100 sense that Xbox was going to
do all of this because Xbox challenging
Sony uh on the on the basis of the
status quo and how Sony has been
successful it just was not working it
was not working whether Xbox was not
able to get their studios off the ground
and games off the ground in a way that
we're able to compete at a time when
Sony took all the PlayStation 3
generation to figure it out and then
come out shooting gun blazing in the PS4
generation with with this sort of
process of how to make these these
quote-unquote AAA games that are
appealing across the board and then the
fact of the matter is that they hit on
those as well right we could have had a
bunch of pretty Duds in p on the PS4
generation that didn't happen and of
course Microsoft stumbles or just
exacerbated the whole thing made it far
worse so Microsoft went and they did
when you look at it on the surface
you're like oh they're doing something
totally different no they're not all
they're doing is that's different is The
Game Pass aspect of it right and to
speak to the Game Pass act aspect of it
those of us who those of us anyone who's
arguing yeah the exclusives and they're
standing together remember one thing
also said under oath that is not his
decision
it is Darth Phil's decision they live in
a world defined by Sony where the
exclusives are a necessary evil he ain't
got to like it Saha
for those of us who believe
that Xbox
when they talk about exclusivity they
talk about that box they talk about that
box they talk about Game Pass and Game
Pass is fine gonna be everywhere I'm
just telling you right now the moment it
is no longer viable for them to make
that box
they won't do it
maybe maybe maybe it'll be overfilled
dead body you said there'll be an app
there will be an app they will be an app
and the King's book I know Kings always
says PlayStation will be there first I'm
not sure about that okay so stubborn
please he's a stubborn yeah they just
get beat up right I'm telling you right
now when you start talking about this
exclusivity and where and and the
Paradigm shifts that these possible sort
of Acquisitions are are are are talking
about
it's not about Xbox the console
that is the least
thing or that is the smallest thing on
Saturday's mind so we really are talking
about
what they're trying to do is completely
shift the industry right and again I
look at it and I'm like why aren't there
arguing this why is none of this being
argued why are you continue to do this
every time you do this everybody adapts
to what you said
somebody in some office is clipping
blows you off
listen I'm tired of your points being
brought up on everybody else's podcast
and then everybody else run with
Sovereign thoughts
is a whole different week of sovereign
nights is all over the place and
sprinkling your Sovereign
drive around your brand new car hell
yeah and I'ma charge for every single
one
fact that's called Airbnb
but if y'all think if y'all think the
long-term pay for Xbox ain't that that's
exactly what they want to be that's what
it is so so my thing is this it's like
I feel and looking at this the same way
I looked at it last week I was like you
know what man these arguments are so
asinine this is just pure entertainment
and comedy right now none of this makes
somebody because it's gonna make a
certain segment of the population sick
when the end when when the comedy show
is over and they say
That's all folks good night and they
give you the verdict a lot of you dudes
is gonna be sick nothing will change
because the PK's point I think at the
end of the day people like saying things
on them wait wait you said Ain't Nothing
Gonna Change anyway I know I'm gonna
change it over here we're gonna we're
gonna get a whole bunch of YouTubers
flip-flopping a whole bunch of YouTubers
gonna change that they're trying to
Rebrand they Channel
how many times have we seen that a lot
of people out here so they gotta Rebrand
oh man I know what you're doing behave
yourself behave yourself shots in the
1300 people in the chat man listen
Phil
when the chips were stacked against them
let's go yeah it really was Order 66 and
he was like I need permission to talk to
this one and that one and this one and
that one and this one and that one and
obviously you think again market
conditions whatever the case may be
things that you know I to addicts point
because the Activision thing I remember
remember out of nowhere but it did
remember when I when I shamed me for you
but the moment but it was one of those
things is that when you when you when
you see the wounded animal yes you you
you you have to take advantage
up until that point you did not see
Activision in that in that position of
weakness it was a position of weakness
that even made feeling think about going
out yeah
so you had the team
sexual harassment what yeah
where's your 80 20 now Bobby
once this is over one way or the other
whatever happens
that Sega conversation is real it is it
is awesome
made sense and I'll be it I will be
happy to give you and cognis if it
happens baby that's it I just sometimes
see this is my issue with Sega okay Sega
attempts to overestimate their own
sometimes
he make it with Mario
Sonic is out here doing it again
we overestimate we
overestimating our worth here
Rising above our stations
I think somebody should fill sovereign
to Let's explain the terms the two games
and the week explain the terms of what
is going on right now
it's me finally getting what is owed me
this is that's what I see this as let's
go
yes yes now I have two podcasts and for
some reason my two podcasts have the
staunchest
of Sega stands right so I got Mr ever
born so I got on one side and I'm sure
he's in the chat shout out to him
oh boy Mr John Wolf on the other right
absolutely right they are they are
adamant well well first it was John and
John seems to have brought ever born
into the fold and I'm so happy yes they
are adamant that when when Sonic Mario
Brothers uh wonders
when elephant Mario releases
but Sonic Superstars aka the rat
not the rat oh man and to make matters
even worse even Spider-Man now my bed is
hell what all of them now my bed is
because there's three of them my bed is
my bed is let's go somehow some way
Mario elephant Mario is gonna come out
on top I agree that's not somehow some
way that's something that's a fact
all right
if it is real quick to defend your
position everybody Saga oh my God you
feel the sake joint is going to outsell
all right so we had a previous bet last
year oh okay he goes
wait wait we're putting these on this
y'all right this is me okay there's
these on this let me tell you that let
me picture
see we didn't get him on that see but I
was about to say by the way we got
slow-mo on that because I was trying to
do this too because we got slow morning
and now we have a photo of slow-mo being
backslapped by Sonic
over here
is attacking go boss is better than
transformed
so I'm okay so I okay
you guys swapped in terms of what I who
I thought was going to be supporting
what okay okay
um okay all right you see obviously
Sonic being on all platforms okay
look at the logistics of it it's Mario
but see that's the same that's the same
argument he made against God of War
against Frontiers
let's be very clear let's go let's go
the god award numbers those books were
cooked because they included
Frontiers like went half price a week
after release and it's the same deal
the game wait a minute wait a minute who
was higher on the Amazon chart it's on
Black Friday God of War or sonic the BET
was the Amazon charts
gcp we know what the debt is yeah
and then they included god of war with
the PlayStation that's why sure sure
now this new BET is that a lot of people
don't know that you got a 2d Sonic
coming back with with updated Graphics
which people have been asking for for
nearly two decades everybody's excited
about it the socials are going crazy
about it
and it is coming out within three days
of Mario Wonder a 2d Mario one that
everybody's been asking for all right so
in the month of October I'm saying that
Sonic because it's on all platforms and
this is a game that everybody's been
asking for it will do bigger numbers
than Mario is only on the switch I'm
just gonna I'm just going to tell you
right now this is where you gonna die on
this hill all right and I'm and I'm your
friend and I love you
yeah this this side is going to be
pretty horrible it's the same Sonic that
they always do they just updated the
graphics and made the four players right
probably give you one or two different
levels this Mario is a completely new
Mario doing new Mario and you know what
it wouldn't even matter if it's a new
Mario it's still going yeah but I'ma say
this though
there's more people interested in a new
side scrolling 2D Mario with new stuff
than an old Sonic with four people to
play with so it's good graphics yeah we
did it we finally did it after 20 30.
we updated the graphics and hey you can
play with Amy with a hammer
that is actually be out here doing drugs
and I'm Gonna Leave Sonic and his four
friends alone and I'm gonna get them
later okay I don't mind taking your
knees too
any
and he wants to smoke yo he's going out
hard
this is biscuits in the gravy you know
what this is this is I got King's knees
I want yours too everyone all right so
there it is easy
Superstars right now we're holding the
Line
This is a flimsy line this is a very
let's get back
see like everybody got a piece of his
knees I just want to call cap
look move it on sorry face your boss I
gotta get kicked I gotta get it all
right no doubt King the adventure of the
week
and then obviously the news about you
know by yourself acquiring you know
Bungie the whole bit just what's your
take this week go wherever you want to
go with it okay well first um we have uh
almost 13. 1300 hit that like button
what animal we saving 100 lights let's
get that up to a thousand let's share
that out let's get everybody involved in
this yes yes just hit that like button
this is King's birthday come on y'all
hit that like button it's really the day
guys exactly um
let's go Bobby's my dude oh I told dudes
going into it Thursday Friday
Bobby gonna be Bobby I love you Bobby
Bobby says
Sony's the most powerful Bobby says this
won't affects Sony and Elise Bobby's
credible because Bobby been paying these
dudes 800 million every year so Bobby
can tell you nah man they're forced to
be record with we rock with these dudes
nothing we do is gonna stop them we see
everything there about everything they
touch is greatness
that's not the dude you want to
understand
you try to show you weak he's like so is
it true that uh Sony can't squat uh 1600
pounds that's nothing I seen some spots
would you talk about Sony be knocking
dudes out yo we had deals in the
background where we was locking content
off what you said that wasn't the FCC is
yelling out objections
objectionable questions they asked Bobby
Bobby tell it telling I love you Bobby
Bobby getting this deal done Bobby said
you are not taking 68 billion out of my
mouth
Bobby got both dreams it was nowhere in
Hell Bobby was gonna let you run around
with that rhetoric after you stabbed
Bobby in the back gym
get to Jim's testimonies I love all of
this this week showed that the judge
ain't dumb as you think you thoughts you
thought y'all was gonna get away with
stuff the judge said
which was dope
so Microsoft stepping their game up
putting games in a service making their
service better wouldn't that push
competition
I've been telling y'all before I gotta
cut you kick it she also said why
doesn't PlayStation increase the value
of this they say service better why
doesn't PlayStation see
when a judge that don't play on none of
these platforms can look at both
platforms and say oh that's piss poor
and they're here fighting the judge can
see through the Veil these guys is given
substantial amount of value in them in
their ecosystem and these guys aren't
and they're the leader they're not
leading the the consumer anywhere
actually they're leading the consumer
into the slaughtering house because
they're bleeding y'all out there's no
benefit to y'all why would y'all be
fighting for a corporation that tells
you yeah we could do date and date but
we don't have to because you suckers pay
more anyway and we like the way that you
suckers pay so but about why we've been
fighting for that why would why would
the the Federal Trade Commission fight
for that well see we're gonna get to
that too but the problem is first and
first and foremost because I'm gonna
stay on these dudes Heads This is where
the boot in the neck you want attention
I'm gonna give you attention right you
you want to demand more but if a judge
can see that you aren't demanding more
from your services and you're allowing
these practices to be this way you have
emboldened these fools to go in there
and tell you no they like the status quo
how the status quo is and they like to
pay and they know need value we don't
need to give them value because they're
still Patron Patron us we got 80 percent
of the market because these fools have
drank the Kool-Aid and they don't want
change and Microsoft is fighting for
that 20 worth of change
the FTC was supposed to prove between
the shuttle before a shadow of a doubt
that Microsoft will harm the consumer
so when the judge said I don't care
about Microsoft Harman Sony
this is dog eat dog if you come in here
with a weak dog your dog will dock
Death to Your Dog God damn all right
I don't want them to die King why could
you ask for the industry I want them to
die because they're doing bad things
step it up and then fix it maybe I might
want them around maybe not but if you
weaken a space asking for more money
than the person that is better than you
I can't respect you and then if you're
gonna go snitch and rack on somebody
trying to make this situation better
than yours because you fear competition
because you don't want to spend some of
your Advanced bonus
on getting games they told you all the
games cost 200 million to make so that
means they got to spend more money they
say hell no we want all our money back
we want everything they gonna pay for it
they go listen we put the game over
there six months they take it they don't
care
yo we gonna make none of our games back
compared to that PlayStation VR these
are anti-consumer practices that you
guys are Champion Microsoft made
everything back compact y'all dudes are
like nobody want to play old games I
remember that okay so keep that same
energy when that PlayStation VR2 come
out and they say no back to pack y'all
don't want to play the old games they
heard you your big mouth
well because Jim said they would like it
Tim said they would like it and they
love it and they got no choice to do it
this is what it is I love where the
judge mindset is director's cut
all Microsoft had to do was prove doubt
throughout this whole case is doubt are
you sure they would do this or are you
sure they do that the judge has to ask
you would you take Call of Duty off the
platform
oh no no we give him that why the hell
will we take it off when we can make 800
million from you you just told us what
you bring in a year I know Phil said
what I thought it was at least 500 it's
800 that's an extra 300 million the
boy's gonna love me this no I I don't
want you to stop paying I don't want
Microsoft to ever pull Call of Duty off
your platform at first I did yeah at
first you did well but now I see it
makes your first party titles greater
because only 15 goes from your first one
let that 15 go God is the 50 15 yeah
worth 15 percent
we like them to funnel some of that over
here we want to make Halo great again
so shout out to you fools that thought
the FTC
shout out to you
I'll be within your quarter shout out to
the video from Jim
it's been a great week and it's a
birthday week yeah next week I'll be
popping bottles
early oh avocados now oh man look I
jumping y'all everybody killed there's
not much I can add on everybody's on
fire with this look at the end of the
day like some of it said if we we're
talking about pure logic and Mark who's
the market leader and you know all the
relevant information and to be the key
that I just see is that no one's talking
about it's like
Call of Duty is not being removed from
PlayStation as a result of this and I
just think that you know a lot a lot is
being lost there and the key thing is
also what king said it's also from them
the judge said it best like
shouldn't this be more pro-consumer if
this happens you know wouldn't this
benefit the consumer and I think someone
documented how many times the FTC said
PlayStation versus the consumer and I
Gotta Give versus seven go ahead
everybody's the one yeah bro it's very
interesting to me the other thing that I
thought was interesting was everybody
and pertains to the you know the Sega I
mean the whole acquisition stuff like it
was like this gotcha moment look look at
all the evil things that Microsoft is
trying to do by you know acquiring all
these companies look how they had it all
listed this is why we have to stop this
kind of stuff this is the Takeover that
they're doing look corporate Cox here to
tell you if you don't think your
corporation has them save m a list
you're fooling yourself you are fooling
yourself I don't know what world you
think you living in if you don't think
there is an m a watch list and and
everyone is evaluated accordingly
strengths weakness risk that's how it
works so so it to me there was no gotcha
moment because this is what they do and
the funny thing is the same ones that
were in the list Sega munji I mean
Bungie and also excuse me was in the
list they ended up getting acquired by
others so it's it's it's interesting to
me this resistance to consolidation as
if there's this new thing that's
happening like PK was talking about as
if oh my God we have to stop this this
is the death of Dentistry no you're
holding on it's to me it's dinosaur talk
yeah like they're fighting over a
company called Activision Blizzard King
it's like bro it's like we grew up in
the air it's like Blockbuster talk
fighting for Blockbuster like bro things
are going to evolve whether you like it
you can hold on as much as you like but
it's going it's eventually it's going to
happen so I just look at the sign forget
gaming like PK said it best look at the
size look at Disney look at what's going
on incorporate look at going on with um
Services everywhere this is what's
happening now you could be opposed and
you may not like what's going on but
like nine times I'm telling you you're
not leaving gaming so stop you know like
there's a lot of this moral High
grounding as if that you know we have to
protect it you cannot stop what's about
to happen so if you are so disgusted get
out again the problem is you're not
you're on Twitter you that's the game
you're playing you're not really caring
you're carrying it because it's it's
about the jersey that you rep you
repping the set that's what you always
get in your jersey down the block you
just rapping this up because if it goes
in your favor you didn't have any
problems with third party and exclusive
deals you didn't have any problem when
one company was getting locked out and
had to come up with a plan to survive
they reinvented their own strategy to
survive this is about capping for a
trillion trillion dollar company this is
just literally the economics of what
they intended to do if they were truly
serious about staying in the gaming
business let me ask you a question let's
go what if instead of buying Activision
Microsoft took that
68.7 billion and did third party
exclusives with the entire industry and
only left Sony with their first party
games you think these people they're
saying that that's the way to do
business that's why those people are
saying oh we shouldn't feel bad for them
because they have all this money they
should use that to compete what do you
think buying Activision exactly and what
it is is there's a difference between
you know being rich and being wealthy
and you have to you have to make the
correct decisions that's going to give
fruit long term right yes I'm not going
to deny that they're a short-term loss
with the Game Pass model this is the
they're in the investment stage right
they're trying to own corporations so
that look we've already seen the game
development cycle it's four to five
years now bro all this two to three
games are taken they're way expensive we
see how much money these games are
costing us being exposed and they're
taking long to develop so if you're if
you're if your Mantra is disservice and
these games are taking four to five it
behooves you to own companies you have
to feed that Beast you can't have
organic [__] I do what you do I mean the
mark that isn't that organically uh
acquiring stuff like historically
putting my money over the table and I
organically get historically companies
have acquired yeah so what does that
call Sir is that called capitalism yes
in economics capitalism is good yes
I'm just saying I'm just saying so if a
larger entity sees a entity that is
weaker and instead of letting that
entity die the larger entity takes it
and gives it to a home and you know
nourishes it back to health but also
absorbs it into the larger entity where
it can flourish isn't that a great thing
to a business model that's letting it
die that that is what's been status quo
lately so okay so I mean but that has
been status full forever right
that's how capitalism Works yes so
we should not be opposed to
consolidation and growth in an industry
so we can um mitigate death right I get
that but In fairness In fairness because
you know I got to keep it fair In
fairness the the only concern I would I
would say that is legitimate is that
okay you have a company who historically
from their first party standpoint has
not outside of the burger shaking fries
of Halo Gears of fries right you know
has not shown that they could
consistently make those type of games
because as their competitors wasn't they
um uh wasn't they per uh what is the
producer of the Year publisher of the
year yeah 2021 yes yes no absolutely
absolutely it was just recently that was
just recently yeah yeah yes it was so
you could say that and I'm just asking
you know because I need to add because
I'm not clear but um I need to ask you
know because the constituents needs to
know yes
um somebody with a recent pedigree of
that nature and dropping high five Rush
after that um only mess up was a
Bethesda game which was shipped in four
get 4k it was shipped in 4k 30 frames
per second I mean it lacks certain other
things but it did kind of Hit the
metrics going forward so my question is
showing that their pedigree has changed
in acquiring new IPS and also being
there as they are to become publisher of
the year do you think that is a good
establishment point for acquiring new
companies and keeping the same pedicure
my only pushback would be three four
three and the initiative
but how about this how about this how
about we just look at the numbers okay
right and we say let's go back to 2019
okay and let's look at every game that
Xbox game studios has published right
right and let's look at what that
average is yeah the Metacritic average
is very solid it is very yeah no
absolutely for some reason we just
completely ignore that you're absolutely
because they don't have a just one and
action just one is bad no no I know what
you're saying but it's all because they
don't have a just one that we can ignore
all of that so at what point and I ask
hey this all the time at what point do
we stop do we get to say okay they've
figured it out right no no yeah if if
they can release a game we talk about
Halo and that game was rated at 87 meta
good point everybody loved it I don't
understand it didn't have the legs that
they wanted for the live service but
let's look at what they [__] yes right
let's look at gears tactics let's look
at uh Ori and the Willows the Wisps
let's look at uh let's look at uh Forza
Horizon
you can look at pentiment right you can
look at all of these games right and
they're all up there so it never really
makes sense to me when we say well they
can't ship quality and the other thing
and these are all just because these
double standards we know it's double
standards why is it that everybody is
saying oh uh look at Xbox saying that
they CA they can't compete without Call
of Duty
isn't Jim Ryan saying the same thing
aren't they saying they can't compete if
they don't have access to Call of Duty
no absolutely absolutely no no
absolutely it's just it's it's these
like I like again there's a difference
between readily accepted information and
actual uh facts right and it's it's
almost like the difference between Dr
Lee's quantitative and qualitative
so so Dr Bailey's uh uh information was
based on Telemetry right she had
quantitative analysis our data yes Lee
was based on who made it up Dr Lee
trust me bro oh man that's the photo
roll you bestie
long way of saying I don't know that we
can say that they don't know how to
publish high quality games I agree
because we don't the numbers don't back
that up I understand all I'm talking
about is you know the track record the
recent track record you're absolutely
right right I'm just talking about
historically prior to that and what they
learned through the Xbox one generation
of ownership and not having that and
then you lose these IPS that you can't
control and I think there's a shift
let's be honest there's a subset of
people who are afraid of this shift and
I think that's what's going on here but
the last part I will say is that I want
to talk about the watch list I wanted to
talk about just say in general obviously
you know Sega kid through and through it
was cool to see it was cool to see the
way they were described and the value
proposition they would present to
Microsoft if required but I'm with
addict and I'm with soft I just think
what happened with Activision was too
good to be true it was perfect time we
could not believe the availability of
this would ever happen especially with
past relations with Bobby and how things
played out so it was the Golden Goose
and it's like we have to pull the
trigger on this now what's up
isn't it funny how my man was moving how
I said he was in the building yeah facts
yo you called it listen you've always
said Phil was that dude and don't let
the you know the the nice guy thing fool
you when you read the letters and you
see what's going on as far as the
aggressor and shout out to Matt booty as
well we gotta get that shoot him yeah
like a lot of people always talk
Microsoft needs to be more aggressive
Microsoft needs to make these
Acquisitions so I'm with ever born in
this don't cry now don't cry now when
they are doing the thing and again the
key point is getting leadership getting
executive leadership to buy in and see
the financial benefit long term because
executive leadership ain't buying off
anyway you ain't making no money I'm
just going to tell if you ain't making
all this sound cute about being
aggressive that's that's why your man
gets a lot of respect for me King
because it takes one thing one more
thing please oh real quick
the the the Xbox Community who's always
been been like out there saying come on
we want to see some aggression they
showed you with one thing and that seems
to have been lost in this a big deal a
week ago yeah right now it's just lost
in the sauce but this would have been a
deal what did they do they saw Indiana
Jones and said nah that's mine and they
paid the difference that's never
happened
he specifically did that because Sony
did Spider-Man right and then we talked
about what last week about what attic
talked about which is the the Bethesda
situation went prior to the acquisition
we've learned death Loop ghost wide
Tokyo and then Starfield themselves were
going to be set up to be solely
exclusive so again if you live in a
world where you are not the global
market leader you do not have that brand
recognition and you're in third place on
the console scales again what
alternative do they legitimately have
because to everboy's point if you just
say oh just just need to outbid that's
not smart money that's not that's that's
not a good investment if you could spend
less and then own have ownership in
control of that that's the better play
and again it's about what PK said being
smart owning a trillion dollar company
and making moves that's going to benefit
long term so we'll see how it plays out
that's what it was I just want to shout
out um we got to give just go to the
Jeff Grove their flowers because they
were getting raped during that time when
they were saying Microsoft was going
after Bungie and then I love you bungee
if you pause you got to come to the
front of the congregation he was like
that was false none of this is happening
bro
no oh boy oh we talk about the pink why
are we not see I don't see if you get to
it up there I don't see it I saw people
yeah I mean I'm talking about up in the
in the brackets yeah I don't I didn't
see you know nobody talking about how
Pete was talking about yeah we wanted to
be for the streets but if you don't fall
in line and be quiet like why are you
talking man no no we ain't gonna be fair
today
with the games everywhere outside of
Game Pass
you know it's star feelings you know
what the play was bro yeah
no no no no no we ain't doing that that
that defeats the whole purpose the
purchase of the purpose was dudes was
acting out of pocket and you had to show
the pimpan of who you are and what we
really do right so you got people
talking about well my games is this and
I really want to stop it man if you
don't sit down
redfall was not good I guarantee you it
would have been better on other
platforms
the numbers would have been better
another platforms We're not gonna go
there we that's
just because red fall is what it is and
y'all want to make up some of some
imaginary numbers we already know they
don't buy games over there 15 shows you
what it is over there so we don't We're
not gonna chase these little numbers but
it's just mathematics
that mathematics says that Sonic's uh so
Mario
listen mathematics is this they
purchased those companies for billions
of dollars mathematics is this you don't
get up on the stand and start talking
Your Truth yo you keep your Truth for
your stomach B we'll talk to you when we
get to the house
that's in the supermarket talking out
loud like you like you're listening all
right don't get that cereal right there
because that cereal costs too much what
do you mean mommy we ain't got the money
to get that cereal you're looking at him
like ditches
they'll do feet like that don't feel
like that I was looking I was like just
dude no listen I'm what I would say what
I will say in the other emails that Pete
was involved in this is where I do have
to push back on y'all with corporate
[__] in the sense of that even though
I'm about the acquisition I Am Lord
acquisition they it behooves them when
you acquire your communication has to be
airtight and some of those letters shown
that hey piece like yo we're sending
Todd out there I'm just learning about
the ABC okay thing now right you know it
would be behoove y'all to educate us on
what's going on because now we're here
in that day game Call of Duty is going
to be on Playstation where our kids is
kind of like like yeah how you gonna
look over at somebody else did talk
about we didn't negotiate better man if
you don't sit down you need to stop
respect ah listen listen and and and and
and and and Phil said this is above your
pay grade no listen the thing is this
right there's a need to know faces and
you ain't need to know you need to know
if he going to another thing and
journalists are going to ask you
something
let me throw a little bit of flame on
your fire again
now we listen to this test sorry guys
we saw the email
and Pete Hines this is Pete Heinz own
words I was the one who suggested uh
death Loop and ghostwire to be exclusive
yes you suggested that which tells me
you was probably the one who suggested
Starfield here double lasers
nah don't do that
is under oath okay you suggested and you
had no problem yes saying that red fall
sorry not for a a death Loops go to
PlayStation facts now you sending emails
to Tom Dick and Harry
and you want to know why you got to be
exclusive now that you under now you
under ownership you want to know why
I'm tired
just not acknowledging that PlayStation
constantly hits your face in every
single day and and so the businessman is
not going to be willing to give okay
it is never listen I love Xbox they will
never have the popularity of a
PlayStation never because numbers could
be there
it will
never be like one is not the same than
the other wait a minute wait a minute
let's go here's the problem with your
arguments let's go let's go like xenomax
is already owned it doesn't matter how
much they make why is he fighting to be
on PlayStation and multi-plat when he
don't got to worry about what it is
because they know that for the streets
because he knows the Xbox he knows that
Xbox is for the streets he's just not
telling you that yet
he knows the Xbox is straight up for the
streets guess what you still don't know
that you know that yes what did Phil say
everything is exclusive
you don't want to break your heart yet
that's the
there are emails that are that are part
of the these these uh these are sort of
these uh proceedings in their emails
that did not make it there their emails
that made it to the bottom of the
Shredder and the ones that made it to
the bottom of the Shredder indicate that
where Xbox is really going and where
Xbox is really good I'm just saying this
I'm gonna send you a new way to say
before no ah tin foil hat I'm not the
one this is the Sonic because emails
that don't
existence
is it the multi-trillion dollar company
you're gonna tell me that the
multi-trillion dollar company doesn't
have an elevator that only goes down to
the sub basement where they burn you see
what I'm talking about tell me that
I'm gonna destroy your whole argument
right there oh let's go that's what
we're saying would have helped Microsoft
in the case so it would have beenhooved
them to say here's the email saying
we're gonna be for the streets why
wouldn't they show that to the FTC and
the judge and everybody Because
unless it unless it didn't exist because
like like King says you don't want to
put out the truth right and you don't
want to put out the actual truth and and
have them smarten up and actually start
arguing you on points Microsoft knows
that the argument's against them is
stupid they don't they're gonna let you
keep arguing that I want you you really
want me to believe this is a two
trillion dollar company would put at
risk a 70 billion dollar deal to hurt to
stop from her all I'm saying all I'm
saying is that it makes sense to me my
thing is this my thing is this yeah I
keep acting like Xbox popularity wise is
on par with places no that's not an
artist so so
why things are rigged when you argue and
why things are rigged and when you
arguing why the executive of said
company is like I'm willing to give
these guys two exclusives
I I respect exactly what you're saying
and I get exactly what you're saying
what I'm saying is right this guy get up
there no this guy gonna sit there and
say you know we want to make our game
though you know and and this is the part
of the contention of really what this
all this whole thing boils down this
whole thing really boils down to
Starfield everybody thinks that McGuffin
is Call of Duty yeah it can't be the
Call of Duty can't beat him a girlfriend
because
Microsoft has shown a willingness to put
it every and anywhere
the only game that they've been saying
you're not getting besides Indiana Jones
is Starfield and the other game that has
come up is not specifically said game
but all the games coming from Bethesda
and xenomax and
we want that that's what send Jim into a
frenzy that day like oh I tried a little
bro this dude and this dude bucked up on
me I'm gonna show you how powerful I am
going you know to other uh other places
I said Don't You Buck up on me Phil and
Phil was like yo you're not gonna be
junior in me all the time bro like we
went we had the conversation you knew
you was getting Call of Duty so that's
why Jim could say it's not a Call of
Duty play this is a star field play and
dudes know where Starfield is and what
it can actually do for a generation and
what it can do for generations to come
but
when you get Pete Hines up there
oh God and them bro
listening
is looking at the greater growth of IOP
right now
no no no no no no listen my thing is
views and opinions expressed by the King
on his birthday has nothing to do it so
I will give you the difference
they're talking about your opinion is
she at Starfield should be for the
streets well God and them that is not
the rhetoric going into the household
that we was talking about so you think
he went off script yes
to his feelings and said what he felt he
wanted to speak his truth right okay
good morning as he said baby I'm nervous
going up there said baby you go up there
and you speak
when you get in front of those people
you tell them everything that you got
inside
the email to Jim Ryan and told him ask
Phil if you could get Zen Max Games
the thing that y'all lose it losing
track here is this and I see all this
scared talk stop it the thing is
the thing is this y'all keep forgetting
about the mentality of zenamax pre
acquisition
exclusive games on PlayStation right
they were going to take the bag they
were gonna take the bag and that's how
it was they would not they were fun they
were trending downward everything they
was doing was not a go 76 then the
multiplayer wolfensteins you know what I
mean they would
um all the other stuff that they were
doing they went from a single player
making company and that's not making
bread the Dishonored all these
masterpieces are not making bread they
shifted it starts to not go well here
comes Sony with the bag you take the bag
in that world so again we keep acting
like they were acquired back then that
was the mentality that's what I'm trying
to say when Pete is talking it behooves
Microsoft now look I'm with y'all on
that there's levels to this right like
when Bungie got acquired by Sony
they like
we put our stuff where we want to put it
right and we're going to advise you on
Naughty Dog scrap that that like you saw
the level of this new child that came
into the house it is clearly Above the
Rest of PlayStation game studios that's
what's happening here Pete had the
realization that oh okay they're going
to have to Activision Blizzard King
the rules are different with Call of
Duty this the only thing I do agree with
Pete though it behooves Microsoft that
when you make an acquisition you have to
disseminate that information that's all
that was the only thing I had an issue
with yeah let me let me say something
man let's go let's go we're talking
about the rise of Darth Phil yes sir I
don't know if you noticed this yes sir
he who again suggested uh death Lupine
and ghostwire go to PlayStation
exclusives now when money's not the
problem he wants to be everywhere we
Let's ignore that for a second okay but
Pete is sending emails to Phil Spencer
talking about why you didn't consult me
I'm the head of marketing so you feel
that's out of pocket wait a minute wait
a minute did you know that Pete Hines is
no longer the head of marketing exactly
correct he's running publishing so
correlation might not be causation right
but you send the email to Phil and you
no longer in that position anymore
your problem I feel you and but here's
the thing you're forgetting is the human
element these dudes are all friends
right Todd and him is close Pete and
them are all close so now this is where
friends and business comes in the line
right so it's like yeah you by man
you're supposed to let me know but on
the business side fellas like there's
levels to this bro and we have to do
what we have to do and we haven't seen
the responding correspondence either
there's still stuff that's redacted
that's all I'm trying to say but you're
making a good point but I know where
you're going I know what kicks I'm just
trying to get the timeline in order and
then the the mentality of xenomax yeah
Cog the one thing that I find is super
interesting especially consider what
you're describing here with timeline and
that's the needle that I think the FTC
threaded successfully yes they were able
to mushy that middle and make it better
it's almost like we're talking about
today they're literally taking talking
points from a third-party developer
right and uh like asserting it to now
the first part of developer saying why
are you saying that they were in
different mode this is 2019. that's what
I'm saying you know what that's the
reason why Sarah Bond like knocked it
out of the park on this thing they tried
to do the exactly the same thing to her
and she went yeah that's true but that
was dead that was dead right all the
others aren't able to thread that needle
so when you're having this conversation
and they removed the date yes you know
and it gives sec to smoke a gun like you
see exactly that's the thing they're
using like this fuzzy fuzzy timeline to
make it seem like see even your own
co-workers don't don't do that they
buddy
she understood the assignment she knew
she was playing
they were you know come on they're
stupid so I mean asking her do you
require Windows Keys oh God right you
don't even require a Windows key to use
Windows that's right that was crazy
streaming got to do the windows no
you're right I know what they were
trying to do oh yeah look what they're
saying is they could have went to the
argument of this
what about defending the workers oh God
we don't bring none of that none of that
came up none of that none of that what's
going to happen should you re acquire
this large publisher or that we gonna
guarantee that people gonna maintain
their jobs and and maintain a
competitive job market facts none of
that none of that came up but we we know
what's going on and we know what the
priorities look we got to move this this
topic this part Waits
I'm not coming at you you won't fight
I'm just saying all of us in general
this was great no you good we're gonna
be doing our thing we got them we gotta
move on I saw how you want to handle
when get the super chats or you want me
to lead in the gym Ryan and I know we
gotta pay bills we got a lot of stuff
let me um let me pay the bills okay and
then do the super chats and it is a lot
of support
well he's not we're gonna pay the bills
now you super chats then pay the bills
let me do a super test and I'll pay all
right cool okay all right cool no doubt
no doubt this is paying the bills as
well this is not mutual money no no not
yet yeah he's gonna let us know yeah
foreign
[Music]
hello Lords happy fourth King happy
birthday and what's up with reforged
trying to clown the whole the line
movement well that's when you don't have
context of what it means you know so you
make up your own thing but you know he
should be able to hold the line he's
pretty good at touching stuff
whoa let's move on stop it selfish
burrito with the six uh Euro Super Chat
uh Final Fantasy 16 running at 720p with
an 8K logo on the PS5 box can't make
this stuff up seriously though something
up with that SE Engine
I don't know what is it what was that
the image uh re-image yeah
remember for 27 months Lord bronze feliz
cumpleanos King oh listen brother thank
you so much then we got enigmatic dreams
two dollar Super Chat Microsoft buy
square and bring and please bring back
Parasite Eve oh that would be great
remember I love parasite I
we got decado five dollar Super Chat
question is the real issue for Sony that
Microsoft is owning Activision Blizzard
actually the games or the data and
analytics of owning games like Call of
Duty and and Diablo 4. oh it's all of it
I mean it's just about the exclusivity I
actually if if I I can talk about that
for a second because a lot of people
don't really understand the the
implications of this deal and why
Microsoft wants it it's actually about a
lot more than games if you pay attention
to what happened in 2022 there's another
company that Microsoft also bought
called Xander Xander is an Ott uh ad
platform Microsoft is trying to get into
the ad business and where uh where
Facebook plays and they're dominant it
is in the socials where uh Google plays
it is in Search and YouTube for ads but
you don't have like a real major player
like that in Ott and that is the the
Last Frontier now when we talk about Ott
that is sort of over the top ads that
you would get from your Apple TV or your
or your or your video game console or
your fire stick and now a lot of people
don't also know this active Vision has
an ad business and they have 400 million
monthly active users so when we're
talking about the ad business we have to
understand that there are new rules you
know whenever you go to a website they
now have to tell you do you want cookies
on that basically killed the third party
data market so if you have an ad
platform you need to be able to Target
people and you're either going to go to
Facebook or you're going to go to Google
because they have all that first party
data from their platforms so first party
data is the name of the game Activision
has a lot of that Microsoft has an ad
deal with Netflix but you need ads to
you need people to serve Those ads too
which means you need profiles Activision
has a ton of that data and they can feed
that data through their ad platform
Xander and sell ads on that through the
Ott thing and that could potentially be
more profitable than the games for them
and this is another reason why they're
fighting so hard and willing to spend
all of that money for a lot of passive
passive ways to make income with that
sort of stuff so yeah that that's that's
crazy we got Dragonheart Yogi remember
for one year two dollar Super Chat shout
out PK I love you brother
that's some Dragonheart Yogi
then we have Nintendo on the otaku
remember for one one five dollar Super
Chat I don't know who needs to hear this
yeah I do but Super Mario Wonder on one
platform will stomp out Sonic superstars
on four sales meta every metric
through that
yeah
then we got chuckle chuckle with the 10
pounds with the chat
many happy returns of the day King well
deserved [__] is down and the seller
when attic says it puts the lotion on
its skin or else it's not going on the
live again hit the like and say book
shout out to Silence of the Lambs love
that and we have JD gamer remember for
two years two dollar super check uh cook
Evermore cook I came here for all of
this it was very bad
then we have Deus Ex machiado five
dollar Super Chat it's wild that instead
of uh competing with exclusives they try
to compete with money this sequel to
King of New York is five
there we have Michael Patton five dollar
Super Chat Sega handheld presented by
Xbox in Japan backdoor Japan through
Sega put all of Xbox's games on Sega
handheld Voltron
call it the Game Gear X oh man then we
have the tsws gaming remember for two
months ten dollars Super Chat happy
birthday King David from me I'm solo
shout out to ham and that's the tsws
gaming thank you for being who you are
P.S hold the line
and we got chuckle Chuckles
Phil Watson Oppenheimer I am become
Darth Phil destroyer of Sony
we have ladies saying five dollars so we
tell you to not have to be fair to the
other side Xbox is playing the rules of
the game that have been set big bank
takes little Bank tell the truth
then we have zakari 10 super chat Phil
said in his finesse voice it's cool when
they do it it's a problem when I do it
it's not Xbox is full others can't do
the same that is true that's what I'm
gonna do it anyway
so we have tsws gaming once again member
for three months Lord gold what up PK
ever born check out his books and K
Asante good to see y'all no doubt yes
then we got Alex excortazar member for
22 months Lord bronze but what about
those who are only impressed by Sony and
Nintendo's success how can Xbox impress
them what about them by buying
everything
you got a choice for my next trick
[Applause]
I'm gonna make him disappear yo you love
me
Super Chat happy birthday uh King
business is business and PS can't afford
to play the same game as Microsoft Sony
is a billion dollar company and these
dudes out here talking like their
startup company buying Debs from
AliExpress
then we got ladies saying two dollar
super chat hit that like button people
yes
we got JD gamer remember for two years
ten dollar Super Chat remember playing
snatches
[Music]
yeah
play snatches over here
you're doing something different
but you snatched my chips all right I'm
getting all of that I don't know what
this game is
we have gamer by choice member for two
years five dollar super chat if you
remember Star Blazers once ABK becomes
Microsoft Studio Microsoft should get
messy and hit doubters with wave motion
gun and destroy their world great show
starblazers I remember showcases yeah
Star Blazers though then we have a lady
saying once again twenty dollar Super
Chat this whole FTC business has proven
how broken the system is even right even
right the rich but this had to happen to
get the dirty laundry out fill in the
whole Xbox leadership I've indicated as
we all can empathize with them um
business in the background yeah but it's
in the background what it is you're
gonna still be what it is
bro they're just 70 billion lighter
yeah then we got Italian clowns for two
years five dollars for the chat Jim is a
puppet for his overlords yeah I don't
know considering Jim's testimony I don't
know who he's a puppet for but that was
good no yeah then we got Mr two
opinionated two dollars Super Chat
Spider-Man where's that organic Infamous
sequel yeah Spider-Man is the organic
Infamous sequel that's what you got
it makes more money than Infamous than
Infamous would
remember for two years five dollar super
chat if you wipe up the girl but she had
a guy in her life before y'all got
together that uh that you still have to
allow that guy to come and get it nah
bro whoa whoa
Arrangement you got going on
some people live that life yo don't be
out here discriminating wow
there'll be no cucking here
man
[Music]
okay we have Spartan six six one five
dollar Super Chat when Sega is bought by
Microsoft do you like the name of the
new console as the x-cash or the
DreamBox
DreamBox sounds dope oh man
there we have you know you know I got
sold two dollars Super Chat Microsoft is
just like us we don't like to pull out
whoa
I think they trying to see it to the end
son we got to come up with an
out-of-pocket Emoji or something yeah
these days everything then we got filter
let's put the crust in a chaper filter
newest member to the realm Lord bronze
why she don't have no filter
no I didn't say anything just just join
the right yeah
then we got a hearty remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat for the
knees I would recommend stipulating that
Sonic can't go into Game Pass or the bet
is off
Game Pass don't mean it's gonna sell the
game pass that man is on to something
yeah
I wish it would go to game pass and it
will be seen by everybody else but that
doesn't mean that you know it's gonna
out somewhere Mario gonna beat the hell
out of it Jesus I'm just listening and
I'm a fan of both but I just know that
the King has spoken
Sonic know about that wrench
I'm Lloyd Metroid member for one year
two dollars Super Chat King is getting
his lap on All Seasons later happy
birthday
[Music]
get back to your right back to you song
back to you
wow wow
rambling entertained entertained not
entertainment rambling entertain ten
dollars stop holding the line for the
company that needs to pay for
exclusivity in order to compete against
the company that became as big as it is
by buying exclusivity ever born ever
born FYI Nintendo does what Sony can
you coming from
that's right I bet this game is rolling
deep dude
then we have Tony Bryant remember for
two years five dollar Super Chat get
those likes also so we can save the
Green Hill Hedgehog
he may be an endangered species
[Applause]
like that they said quiet we out here
hunting hedgehogs
that's wow
that does work out too well for Elmer
fudders
oh wait a minute one second one second
one second yeah yeah I just want to say
for the Abacus gang oh boy like King say
we got you a game
over here oh we got hostage
everybody got the alley well
[Music]
same everything twice the ram twice the
battery life eight inch screen okay
worst UI oh damn sure yeah yeah terrible
UI Point Blank but I'll take the
hardware any day for software I can I
can install my own stuff okay okay
but you know what we like little white
men over here
he said that's your choice sir we're not
doing that time on King David time on
King David let's go
Mr mdj five dollars
that was not a goal
we just got
yeah that's it we lost all the revenue
now it's over
here Mr mdj five dollars is the biggest
straw man argument because Regulators
decided off the rip that Microsoft is
spending 70 billion must be bad the PC
did not prove immediate harm no they did
not nope they shout out to the homie
family Lord valicon
there you go brother appreciate you
appreciate you yeah oh he actually said
that um his FIFA got his Super Chat
didn't go through and he said because
this is the homie from channel five
um it was supposed to say happy born day
King hope that you have a wonderful uh
fam and he said please pass that on to
him no okay
appreciate you brother
and we got Spartan goes 17 the five
pound Super Chat Phil gotta hit him with
that 80 20 publishing fee PlayStation on
ABK
come on gonna tell Jim yo um
being that we had changed hands the
prices oh no you can have it on your
side but if you don't want it we
understand you understand listen listen
listen hold on you know you know we're
talking about Darth Phil here yeah and
you know after uh the if the if the
injunction doesn't get granted uh Jim
Ryan's going to come to Phil and say
what about that 10-year deal was all oh
no that was awful and and Darth Phil is
going to say I've altered the deal and
pray I do not alter it further oh man
we're gonna give it to you but it's a 90
10 split
yeah
just about those Dev kits could we have
those Dev kids tomorrow we gotta get
into that we're gonna get into them to
be clear if this preliminary injunction
is not granted that means the the
console theory of harm has been
destroyed everywhere around the world
even in the UK where they don't want the
deal to happen this means there are zero
Protections in place
for the FTC Whisperer hopefully next
week we get some clarity continue some
uh it's still this is still Spartan
ghost uh yesterday's prices not today's
price make him dance dominance
then we have a net watch two dollar
Super Chat happy birthday King mine was
the 24th thank you Happy Birthday
to go 17 two pounds Super Chat nah bro
Pete hounds is out of pocket fall in
love with you right there
that we have gamer by choice member for
two years five dollar Super Chat SOB you
my dude but I disagree there is a world
where Xbox is more popular than
PlayStation we should not say never
mathematics say different not in this
timeline sir oh man
it's not it's not that it's not more
power we're gonna stop that
we listen listen let's be grounded here
[Laughter]
thank you I appreciate that and we have
Fargo 172 proud super chat if Pete ain't
happy at Microsoft he needs the GTFO for
real
it's not that you know it's business
these guys gonna argue one another you
know what it is hold on a second let me
go back
so let me see I gotta roll back a little
bit oh wow I just crossed 13 000
followers on Twitter thank you beautiful
beautiful we have Mr two opinionated
five dollars if we chat Pete could have
emailed Phil about redfall too worry
about that man worry about fat Pete
shaking my head
yeah yeah I mean red four whatever just
nobody's talking about redfall anymore
we have Spartan 661 2000 which had ever
born Saga please turn your mic up
and we have Corey Tidwell ten dollar
Super Chat shout out to my mans that
look like sugar-free spitting facts on
the shows
he's staying ready so he ain't got to
get ready
that is a compliment
it should be for sure he said I've never
seen a turtle with speed or a chick
[Laughter]
I can tell you 30 times how to pimp you
a pro and I can tell you 30 more you
still won't know he got balls yeah
then we got booty hunting clicks
hit that like button while I'm hunting
oh man we had to get on that we had to
get all that sniper out
he had to get all that we got a TSW has
gave me two dollars for that yellow card
yeah there's a lot of violations
violations on the field bro
we beat out of pocket emoji and we got
Jay Boy On The Run
oh man the order
uh it says white is old news we black
from front to back Xbox series that's
one terabyte oh my gosh
wow today
okay we are caught up so we're gonna pay
these others pay the bills mics
all right
this episode is brought to you by bird
dogs bird dogs is a company that
specializes in bringing you the most
comfortable shorts bathing suits pants
and polos on the market the specially
engineered built-in Comfort liners for
their shorts and pants offer any
cross-disciplined workout or Leisure
activity which enables customers to run
swim and relax all in the same pair of
shorts or pants so even if the prospect
of technically going commando doesn't
get you super excited the fact of the
matter is that bird dogs just make you
look good bird dog stretch khakis and
shorts are designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and leg give you a
truly sculpted look
bird dog shorts do the exact same thing
as Lululemon but fit way way better they
also fit way better than regular shorts
and pants that are made with stiff
restricting cotton bird dogs has fixed
this issue by inventing Cloud knit
fabric that looks just like khaki but
stretches so you get a way Slimmer fit
without having the sacrifice movement
bird dogs also uses anti-stink sweat
wicking fabric that keeps you cool and
dry all day long for me my dress style
has changed considerably since my
younger days and as someone who probably
took the uh the whole baggy Trend a
little too far throughout the 90s as a
47 year old man I now prefer a more
flattering form-fitting look to my
wardrobe so you know I can accentuate
this uh adonis-like uh body that I've
chiseled to Perfection over my nearly 50
years of existence
but no the fact is as someone who is
constantly on a move and sweats
profusely unfortunately
bird dogs allows me to stay cool dry and
flexible throughout my ever hectic days
and additionally and this is just a cool
side note I love the naming conventions
that they have for their products with
polos called Jacques straps
uh shorts such as Teddy rub skins and
tight wads and pants called John D Cox
Brothers and Lee I did a lot of Coca so
if you're ready to join me and finally
dress like an adult and show off those
massive quads and calves it's time to
get bird dogs go to birddogs.com pool
and enter promo code pool p-o-o-l for a
free Yeti style tumbler with your order
that's birddogs.com pool p-o-o-l for a
free Yeti style tumbler you won't want
to take your bird dogs off we promise
you
oh man it's a guy right
yeah shout out to Veritas I will say now
that I got mine oh they are comfortable
so how are your John D Cox those are the
pigs no I ain't got those I got the the
camouflage joints
a lot of cocoa yeah I gotta look at this
site whatever's name for the camera
I'm saying I'm gonna do it since you had
these shorts
how has the recognition in the street
people checking out your calves yeah I
wear these zero dark thirties that's
what I wear the Zero Dark thirties as
they cool and then um there's another
drink that's kind of fire on the forest
pumps before okay
all right
what's this reception that you've seen
in the street I mean this is how people
responded
we all know we got a certain short stuff
that we put on we look for certain
receptions yeah I'm not looking for that
reception
I'm good I was I wore my dogs you know
what I'm saying like I did like day and
I I was comfortable okay you know what
I'm saying it wasn't no extras you ain't
seen no a man I don't need to see amen
I had my headphones on I was not
interacting
did you catch anybody
and you can be as free as beefy over
there
[Laughter]
we missed it
face face face face face face face face
copy paste it and put it back in the in
the chat please yeah regular chat face
and then yeah at us because we'll take
care of that we got you bruh we got you
yeah because it's really hard for me to
miss them now yeah it's a 20 one I don't
know if it doesn't have the number the
money next to it or no yeah it would be
an orange one so I'm like okay
no that was Lady we'll go Xbox oh yeah
okay I got it got it okay Phase 23
weekend why twenty dollar Super Chat
Xbox fans FTC getting cooked Xbox fan
CMA gonna approve the deal oops
you say y'all popping bottles yeah yeah
I know I know the last time it didn't
look like that but listen go ahead man
go get your champagne together ready
celebration are you ready celebration
Corey Tidwell five dollars Super Chat
breaking internal Microsoft email
reveals the original Little band was
canceled for blackface
are we good so yeah
all right I got reading yo I got family
listening today what is going on so look
Jim Ryan hit the standing all this
addicts topic sorry Alex have having a
power issue so um oh I'll take over his
topic so look Jim Bryant hit the stand
you know he has a lot of choice to say
so I'm gonna get a bunch of his bars off
some of the keywords not everything so
yeah Jim Wright admits starfield's
exclusivity is not anti-competitive
lawyers ask Ryan Point Blank if he
believes exclusivity for games like red
four and Starfield are anti-competitive
I don't like it but I don't view it as
anti-competitive however speaking of the
ABK deal as a whole Ryan said he told
Activision and CEO Bobby kotec he
thought the deal was anti-competitive
and wanted to get it blocked Ryan said
kotik wanted to cover himself with an
extended Call of Duty deal with Sony
just in case things fell through what
Bobby wanted to do was cover himself by
extending the extending the marketing
collaboration between Sony and
Activision in the event of the
transaction not proceeding so a little
slander right there for how Bobby was
moving Ryan and calls Xbox game pass
value destructive he called the
subscription service destructive say
Publishers he spoke it to are not fans
of the model The Game Pass business
model appears to have some challenges
and Microsoft appears to be losing a lot
of money on it I talk to all the
Publishers and they unanimously do not
like game pass because it is value
destructive so that was a big eye
detector said why do cops why did cops
came through right at this point that's
gonna learn
yeah oh man so look um on August 2020
this was big August 22 to email from
Phil Spencer's set Jim Ryan's alarm
spells ring after Xbox announced it's
intention to acquire Activision at 22.
Ryan said Phil Spencer reached out to
him in May 2022 with a potential letter
agreement and list of games Xbox would
commit to keeping on Playstation Ryan
said this interaction with Spencer did
not adequately address his concerns
about activism games on PlayStation
moving forward Ryan also said that he
was concerned about the transaction in
May 2022 but Spencer's response to
Sony's counter proposal in August 2022
set the alarm bells ringing this email
from Spencer caused major concerns
within Sony's camp but the contents of
the email were not shared in court I
actually know the contents of the
evening what's the contest of the email
he sent the email and this is the whole
email and I quote
specifically said that in the list of
games that that Phil Spencer sent to Jim
Ryan yeah if the acquisition comes
through this this is all the stuff
that's gonna stay with you right so Jim
Ryan's alarm Bells went off because he
didn't see OverWatch too he's so
OverWatch won Jim Ryan gamer Jim Ryan
realized that OverWatch 2 wasn't on the
list and the alarm Bells went off so
this is no OverWatch one wasn't on the
list no one was it that's what he said
so we believe that Microsoft intends to
use Call of Duty to disadvantage
PlayStation in terms of the availability
well the manner in which the game is
made available on PlayStation consoles
and to drive PlayStation Gamers to the
Xbox platform specifically Game Pass
another key point
icon that about Dev kits and if the
active position goes through so last
week obviously Phil testified that the
set on PlayStation 5 to Sony uh the dev
kits um that Sony sent PlayStation 5
developer kits to Microsoft well after
other developers got them Phil also
claimed that the late access to the dev
kits is why there's no native version of
Minecraft on PlayStation 5. Now Jim has
said in his piece for the dev kits that
um that Sony would continue to hold back
Dev kits of future consoles from
Activision if Xbox's acquisition is
completed Jim goes on to say we simply
cannot run the risk of a company that
was owned by our direct competitor
having access to that information that
information could leak into other parts
of Microsoft and potentially allow them
to be able to develop similar features
to the ones that we would argue that we
invented and he claimed that he Sony
could not rely on a contract to make
Activision keep PlayStation features
secret from Microsoft so that was a big
point of contention from him and the
last one which is very interesting was
uh Jim Ryan about Bungie and how he
looked at Bungie versus the ABK deal and
he said Jim said that Sony will get more
out of the Bungie purchase than it would
out of buying Activision Blizzard Ryan
said this logic comes down to Bungie's
expertise in the live service space he
continues to go on when you look at 69
billion for Activision compared to 3.6
billion for Bungie we believe that
Bungie can give us way more than a 69
billion dollar Activision acquisition of
Activision and that's before considering
the relative value of that particular
transaction so I seen you broke without
saying you broke
yo ask you a question Kyle yes
was Jim Lyon oh sorry Jim Ryan
was Jim Ryan lying to The Regulators or
was he lying to his investors he's one
of themselves
[Laughter]
he just no because these two things do
they don't they don't go together it's
like The Duality of Man correct right
yeah one side you're saying we're fine
you're saying you're insulated you're
saying it doesn't matter you're saying
if Microsoft wanted to make an
exclusivity play they could have just
spent five billion dollars for three
years of Call of Duty exclusivity you're
saying you don't even know if they're
going to be able to manage it you're
saying they need to do that to compete
that's what you said to your former boss
correct and then you said it again to
your investors at Fidelity correct but
then you went to regulators and said no
this is anti-competitive right and you
wouldn't even answer the question
if you were Phil Spencer would you do
the same thing correct so he was lying
somewhere I'm I'm just asking the
questions of who he was lying to he
doesn't understand the question he
doesn't he doesn't have enough knowledge
to answer such and please form a lawyer
it's look it's fraudulent baby we just
let's just call it whatever we English
called this this is fraudulent behavior
and this is protecting shareholders and
I get it we know you're gonna do what
you got to do bro so everyone I'm with
you on that I want to start with ksanti
just in general Jim Ryan statements
where you at with that you know there's
a lot to unpack here what did you get
for most of his testimony
oh I I got from from Jim's testimony the
stuff I always get from Jim's testimony
you know he he knows and and I think it
was I was it was on ILP I said I said
this he knows he knows that he has
earned his spot on the Mount Rushmore
snitches
he has earned it I mean am I wrong like
people can now take he can now go and
then have webinars talking to people how
how David can poke poke the eye out of
Goliath
he said he's up there with Frank Lucas
oh man
but let's be clear let's be absolutely
clear he is doing his job like you know
I I've said this too uh for my for my
soccer fans out there when you see
Ronaldo running on the field and he
grabs his leg you know you don't get you
don't get mad at him when when the when
the referee doesn't give him the call
you get mad at the ref don't hate the
player hate the game and he's just
playing the game that's what it is and
and in that realm he is doing exactly
what he's supposed to be doing and the
fact that he's been able to take a bite
even if it's the smallest piece out of a
two trillion dollar company a company
whose budget he may never see in his
entire lifetime but somehow has made
them move to him as he will
[Applause]
see see you obviously obviously he they
have he hasn't moved he hasn't moved
them to the place where he wants to move
them but he's moved them enough to where
they've had to go through a lot of
Superfluous processes and like as we as
we've discussed they're they're putting
out they're putting out the uh what they
call the contracts and doing things that
are unusual because he's gotten enough
of The Regulators on his side to the
point where they you got you got place
you got
um Microsoft now doing uh doing
marketing research to discover whether
or not there's there's a outsized
influence on whether it's a positive or
negative for the environment that
they're they're buying things they never
do when they purchase buy their own
admission right and I would I would
argue that's all because of Mr Ryan
right he's the one who's who went out
there did all that and got all of these
ducks got all his Pawns in a row ready
to make them get you to do all this
stuff
yeah he did great work for Nintendo and
Nvidia what did he do for PlayStation I
mean you're a presence though we can't
we can't deny his dominance in that
region and how he really elevated them I
gotta give him that in Europe
that's not what I'm talking about that's
not what I'm talking about your question
which is great for for Sony what Kay's
talking about is what he was able to
accomplish to sort of uh uh uh bother me
the process the deal itself what did he
accomplish in the deal bro give give me
a week we will talk again because you I
guarantee please maybe you can you can
prove me wrong you right now can't tell
me definitively that this is going to go
through
even though you and I are even though
you and I are on the exact same page
because because of what hope law says
you can't account for crazy and not
crazy was stoked by Jim Ryan and all of
that all right so all of that see you're
telling me that Jim has nothing to do
with the father that has caused this
process I think Jim Ryan was a useful
idiot for people who already wanted to
block the deal but you don't you don't
see you don't think they both used each
other yeah you don't think that he's one
of the persons to ignite the the the
only person because the judge says if
Sony would have took the deal would we
be here that's right and FTC tried to
the skirt around the question and she
changed it again and said again I'm
going to ask you if Jim Ryan did not go
to regulators and bring up this issue
and sign the contract what would we be
here yeah be here yeah she said oh and
by the way this is an inevitable point
that we would have gotten to but you
would have never gotten here without Jim
Smith
she said that to the lawyer who was uh
five minutes ago asking about Diablo 4
yeah the guy who used to work for him
yeah
like come on he has put something in to
this process whether he was completely
successful or not you know we we will
we'll see about that we'll see but you
can't take away you can't take from him
the fact that but he has earned his
paycheck he has earned his PlayStation
paycheck for real for real whether he
successfully does it or not he has
earned his paycheck and you got to give
him credit for that right because if you
were in his position this is what you'd
want to have done maybe not oh yeah
everybody feeling it see I I told
everyone once what if Sony buys Sega and
then does a Ratchet and Clank Style
Sonic yeah will you forgive them
he's like
it was crazy that'll be a crazy timeline
that'll be a crazy time I would prefer
not to answer that question oh no you
sound like different information you
sound like Jim though
in fact this is a fun fact for everybody
if you know your uh Sonic and Sega
history
uh uh what's the the the engineer over
at Sony what's his name again
yeah used to work for Sega
absolutely and when and when Sonic 2 was
gonna get made he brought yujinaka over
yes to to uh work as he didn't really
want to work in Japan and they kind of
work together to make that happen so
there is some DNA there but not it's so
to to answer your question directly I
think he did exactly what he was
supposed to do I think a lot of his
conversation were full of
straight lies right which which I find
quite interesting because you know we've
we've heard a lot of T spilled about it
C-Class Executives cannot lie they can
skirt the truth they can they can
embellish they can you know they can do
a little bit of that bobbin and weaving
that we saw kotek and the rest of them
do this dude you can you can find Point
positive lies in his statement for some
reason that just
true well no yes he was yes he was he
was deposed it was a deposition this
deposition
sure sure since he's not the defendant
and they're not yeah so so they deposed
them but then they didn't and then
that's the reason why he didn't come on
he didn't come right then he would have
to be under oath yes absolutely
absolutely
then that means that means that that's
probably why he's able to skirt this one
on the side good point good point but
yes at the end of the day it is what it
is you know you can hate on him as much
as you want you know you can you know
and you can you can you can have issues
with how he made his moves and what he's
doing and all that he's like I played
Call of Duty games and I'm like I don't
believe you sir
what's your PSN tag oh exactly
that's the art of the snitch man we
gotta respect to snitch game like he's
he's like the Omega snitch right like
and he got a little mini bosses like
Sammy the bull and Takashi oh but he's
like the king snitch like so he knows
how to move like you thought you was
gonna get him on the stand he's like
haha videotape like that's right and he
said it on a VHS tape oh man because you
know they won the war against betamax it
was just little things and he he makes
sure that y'all understand exactly where
he at with it his snitch game has no
parallel
[Music]
I will not deny his snitch game at all
because when did you ever think that a
billion dollar company could could
literally poke the Ayah out of a two two
trillion dollar company and really cause
as much static as he has right now
remember when your mother told you be
careful with your words because words
are power are you like nah man people
hitting people in the face hurt right
and he was like I ain't gonna believe
her and Jim said he understood that oh
yeah his mom's told him that words is
powerful Jim said yes and he went to
Brazil and said Mira Aki
a moment of your time before Oh bad boy
I can't I can't with you the bad Spanish
I can't moving on we gotta get these
guys pretty soon I need to get PK real
quick so obviously Jim Ryan's testimony
a lot of things to unpack anything
that's particularly stand out for you in
reference to his testimony
um for me you know
because he was
on a recorded deposition and even though
Sony's headquarters is like uh
you saw the G Africa yeah
from you know I mean if you're a snitch
it behooves you to be right next to the
courthouse
I'm just saying this is how slick he is
he makes sure that his
working
where he works at is out of UK so
technically even though he's here he
actually
works out of the UK office so they can't
necessarily ask him to come in I mean PK
though seriously you you had Satya take
a meeting and go sorry president of the
Free World I'll be right back because
these people got to ask me about video
games it's better honestly but again
they're not on trial here true true yeah
very true they're not the defendant if
it goes to trial in August that would be
different oh yeah yeah this is just for
a restraining order
so they don't have to show up right now
um however that isn't change anything in
August whenever they go to court but uh
just to be clear and I just want to make
sure everyone in the chat knows that
everyone listening
um FCC
had the burden of proof not Microsoft
right and they had to burn into proof
not to by certain not even by certain
just probable cause yes that's all they
had improved yep not Theory and what
they did was they had a lot of theories
but no evidence to bring probability
I mean even their uh you know so-called
expert had a quantitative data model
that my students can put up right and
you know kids that can put together
and he based it off of Xbox One and PS4
which is crazy to me that you're gonna
use that and apply it here then you put
your own input in that input that it
created you put it to come up with is it
so listen to that Jim Ryan sat there and
it's crazy that these emails came out
and you know someone goofed on
what they not supposed to show I don't
know if that was intentional or not but
no they just use the wrong marker oh
that's Sharpie oh that shot Sharpie gate
discouraging yeah
it put doubts in by positioning the
language on if
we
um if we do not allow Microsoft the
access
to our console should they buy this it's
going to hurt our consumers which in
turn hurts consumers that's the language
State or the the method he was trying to
use to position it and
also you know basically he was he was
the way he was speaking was was
obviously he was comfortable he was
being recorded and which means they can
have mass retakes you know just you know
well I don't like that let's do this
again
um
[Applause]
[Music]
he does I agree with God he is a
businessman he's doing what he's doing
for his brand and he's he's trying to
put enough doubt out there for this any
any way they can to delay this deal so
they can fall through he's gonna do it
he wouldn't be lobbying if it wasn't
important factor if it wasn't important
we wouldn't even be talking about this
he wouldn't have been there he wouldn't
be in UK he wouldn't be all over the
place trying to
persuade people to go that direction if
it wasn't important and I think the
judge was not only smart enough to but
Savvy enough to understand game yeah she
said that that's why she asked the
question we wouldn't even be here facts
she just said if they signed the
agreement like everybody else would we
they couldn't answer it because that's
not the truth good point that's not why
it didn't matter if they signed the
agreement or not you were pushing this
this Initiative for your own reasons
because someone else came to you and
started pulling coattails and we already
know why they refused to sign contracts
because it's not just because of Call of
Duty they want to guarantee
they get everything and they want
everything they lost he wants everything
and everything he lost and that is
what came out and and what also came out
is hey no one talked about this because
marketing is a huge deal yes the fact
that Xbox couldn't even mention the word
Call of Duty on their show last year
the marketing home wait that mate that
position Sony to or or the appearance to
because we're we we are the small few
who are into this right but the Casual
Market they have no idea they think
that's a PlayStation exclusive yes it
looks like a PlayStation think about
this talk to them how many people know
that Seafood is on Xbox factual talk to
a marketing holds power marketing where
it's whole it is on there but no one
knows because they're not allowed to
Market it that is huge so if they own
the marketing rights to Call of Duty no
longer do they have this narrative like
his next topic about that this is gonna
be fun
and and and he knows that this is what
Jim Ryan knows think about this this is
what no one says that he also asked for
them to
cancel all the contracts with Activision
where they have to pay them back
towards some of this marketing stuff
that they front loaded he don't want to
pay the bills either
nobody's seen that I mean it's there but
the way since I I find that
um this is a typical thing and this is
why I don't understand why people get so
in their feelings about
you know because
business Biz they're going to do what's
best for their tax situation and I do
respect that he is he is he is Savage
bro listen people's like yo don't defend
football behavior and I'm like bro
that's business but me personally I
would just say we still believe in
Generations oh and greatness is still
waiting I don't know all right PK we
gotta stop
for the block
we're gonna stop me downstairs I mean I
mean Cog it is almost 4C oh man y'all
let the fireworks go early
when the next psvr come out you're gonna
have to buy everything all over again oh
here we go so the next PlayStation
a super turbo Edition
time won't be gay but you expect yeah
yeah
bro oh babe ever boy do you want to
Commodore okay yes yes real quick real
quick
all right so uh the one thing is that
you brought up about how they could not
even mention Call of Duty on their stage
you know what's Wild
Sony was giving them a 10 discount on
for the for the pleasure or the ability
to be able to do that Xbox had to pay
the the same
non-standard rate and they got nothing
for it yeah as a matter of fact they got
worse and they still had to pay Sony's
price so none of the benefits actually
being hurt by it and they they still
have to pay 20 but like the North
Phil never forget
and that is why he was like okay cool
I'm gonna pay you the 20 but uh
you when he came back to him he got him
but anyway we got to paint the picture
everyone Bobby kotec rolled into
Winterfell and made the queen bend the
need of these turns Queen Sarah ball had
they had to bend the knee and like you
said the north remembers
continue the story this is great and and
so okay you wanted to strong arm us
about this 20 or you're gonna pull all
your content off the platform
uh your employees just happened to start
coming forward
right oh you just happened I mean we're
a a multinational conglomerate and now
you just happen to be getting sued all
over the world
oh oh your stock price is dropping
Bobby calls Phil Phil don't pick up the
phone oh man
and then Phil then then he picks up and
says this is what we gonna offer you
cash
I'm not even talking to you no more take
it to your board oh babe but anyway
that's not about this we want to talk
about we want to talk yes please uh the
gym right so the thing is this right I
hear a lot of people running with this
idea that uh Jim Ryan said oh Bobby K
was trying to work out a side deal yes
if you believe that Bobby kotik would
put forget it forget about the the 67
billion dollars or whatever right 68.7
billion dollars you understand if he had
any conversation like that that would
put his three billion dollar breakup fee
at risk do you think Bobby K is gonna
have any conversation like that to put
that at risk um ever born they're
forgetting the part when Bobby told you
I was trying to reach out to these dudes
and he wasn't calling me back so that
conversation never happened because
exactly get in on the phone to get to
the other side to make the proposal
because Jim was already butt hurt
because from the stuff that he did he
said how dare y'all do this and bring
this to me how dare y'all not allow me
to little man this dude no I don't want
to talk to nobody that's a person that
sees what they did and they're ghosting
you looking at the phone he knows what's
up nah and and that's why he said I
believe uh Bobby was trying to work out
a deal he didn't say that that's what
Bobby was trying to do because that
makes no sense at all but he was up
there lying the whole time anyway uh the
other piece of it is when we talk about
these contract negotiations
I I don't know like we I understand it
because
if I don't want this deal to happen why
and I know that if you get my go-ahead
right that kills The Regulators there we
go so why should I sign anything unless
I'm gonna get everything true right
there's no reason for me to sign it but
if you want me to sign it cool I'm I'm
going to take your knees facts yeah
right so he he he was doing what he had
to do but to to to Mr K asante's point
right all of this
and at the end of the day from the
beginning of this deal Microsoft said
it's going to take 18 months to close
right we're right at the 18 month Mark
and after this hurdle they can just
close because I think they'll close over
to CMA that would be closing in 18
months they said they were going to keep
the game on PlayStation they're probably
going to keep the game on PlayStation
unless Jim wants to get cute
the the the the the point is all of this
hooting and hollering and and turning
States evidence and doing all of that
and we still end up where Microsoft said
uh we were going to end up and when they
said it was going to happen so Jim Ryan
has only been successful if the deal
gets delayed and doesn't close past 18
months other than that Microsoft said
the terms in the beginning that is the
terms they will continue to get and and
and and and they don't have to sign
anything there's no there's no remedy in
place anywhere in the world that says
that they they have to give Sony any
special terms there's nothing in writing
saying that they have to give Sony
access on the subscription service
there's nothing in writing saying
anything exclusivity yeah they have to
ask for it that's right yeah and they
have to pay for it when they ask for it
right so so so again all of this that
we're looking at uh uh Jim Ryan like
he's some kind of Svengali what did he
really get done they're closer like they
said he got he dirtied up he dirtied up
Pete he got people to look at yeah he
dirted the waters beautiful Nintendo and
Nvidia that's what he did
stole out baby stole out great right and
and then the the other thing is when he
what he pointed out the reason he did he
said that Starfield he doesn't like it
but it's but it's not anti-competitive
he knew what what that would mean
they're trying to set him up
FTC is not his friend this is why I say
it is a he's a useful idiot he's a they
have no case and Sony gave them the Oppo
research and so that's what their that's
what their whole case is defined around
but if you say on under oath I mean some
people I mean we think that he wasn't
under also or not but you on record yeah
right they will play that tape back and
if you say that Starfield being
exclusive is anti-competitive you don't
think that that's going to come back on
you that would definitely come back on
him
so so that that that is the thing so Jim
Ryan may have because we don't know the
FTC might want to get a win you got a
lot of information on Sony deals that uh
according to the FTC if you do these
things it's anti-competitive
right unless the FTC saying only Sony's
allowed to do these things maybe they
are but if that's not what they're doing
and you believe the FTC is just trying
to protect I don't know who then
after this is over if the STC gets
embarrassed it's an easy way to get a
win if you go after what you called
anti-competitive practices like partial
foreclosure or full foreclosure no and
who's the who's the number one at that
so again
you didn't delay the deal we don't think
right you didn't secure any of those
things you asked for in your email
and now
the FTC got all your paperwork
so hold on hold on while I hear you and
I agree with all your points I do are
you saying that Jim should have just
stayed home that none of this was
fruitful for him
that's exactly what I'm saying
look
at all we can all agree that that's the
case yeah
I'm with you on this okay but I feel
everybody where he going again it's all
contingent or what the end result is
right whatever the end result is that
everyone can feel the kids
I know I know what's going on here but
we gotta move I'm sorry okay Jim did get
one thing he might end up with Pete
hunts as an employee
argue P Hans is ready y'all stop it stop
it I'm not doing that to the legend
we're not doing that to the legend stop
song I gotta ask you what's going on Sir
about Jim Ryan's testimony your thoughts
as quick as possible because we got more
topics yeah this is exhausting yes um uh
yeah Jim it's just it's funny to me that
you know again the nature of of his
testimony allowed him to honestly be
more honest than I've seen him be in
quite some time and the fact that you
know exactly and but it it really is
this thing where he He just flat out
said that MO most of the issues that
were initially presented in his
arguments as to why they should not go
through don't really affect and then I
and to back all that up is just the fact
that the documentation indicating these
you know showing these emails back and
forth between him and Phil Spencer and
and him Bobby kodek say as much so it it
was really him trying to protect at the
end of the day when we talk about like
how important call of duty is to this
entire thing
as a whole it isn't very important to
PlayStation into him it was very
important right and and it wasn't about
exclusivity it was never about
exclusivity it was never about even in
their emails when they pivoted to like
yeah it's not about It's Not Call of
Duty it's not exclusivity it's it looks
like a king play right it's a king thing
and it's them trying to get bigger
and the cake thing King thing but
so even then like it was it was just him
trying to throw a monkey wrench into it
because he did not want to allow that he
it opens the door to so much more and
the Paradigm changing shifts that this
would sort of initiate that I was
talking about earlier so that's just
what it is and the fact that he didn't
necessarily tow the line in his
testimony and and kind of was honest
about how he really felt about stuff was
kind of it was refreshing
[Applause]
um and it it kind of does indicate to me
that the point from the beginning was to
try to throw a monkey right if he gets
like if it stopped bro and it works he's
gonna claim that like he that was his
goal all along right and what and if it
doesn't happen then he's gonna be like
yeah I knew it was gonna happen I tried
to I tried to do the best to sort of put
myself in the best position to do what I
needed to do now this conversation about
Bobby kotech and him extending it uh
behind the scenes
I kind of I agree with everborn right
because when you think about are you
going to sacrifice the three billion
dollar one shot deal that you get if the
deal doesn't go through
long term it makes sense
year to year maybe not because if you
talk about 13 about 13 of of
Activision's Revenue coming from Sony
money right call Cod money maybe a
little bit of OverWatch but mostly Cod
money that's that it kind of rounds out
to maybe close to a billion dollars
right out of whatever there's seven
about to get fired for all that contract
that is true too right well well
we never got to see if the pressure was
going to get to it to the to the to the
stock to the shareholders right because
it at first they were like no he's a guy
whatever and they try to do all these
other things
and that's when Phil's swipe you know
swooped in right my man
I knew you I knew you'd be back
are you oh hey Bobby what's up man sit
down have a seat you want something to
drink
cause he like sex on the beach oh man
continue
[Laughter]
oh you can't pay your mortgage this
month
[Music]
the reality is just XYZ and it just felt
from the beginning right we don't we're
not privy to all the conversations he
had with Kodak and we had he had with
Phil Spencer but it feels to me that he
knew from the jump that regardless of of
the sort of the roadblocks that were
going to be placed at Microsoft's way
that they told him we're going to
continue to push forward and if Jim sort
of understands this process he's like
you know what hella high water this
something's happening with this deal
whether it happens in this form or they
re-jigger it after it gets shot down
some way shape or form this is happening
right because I firmly believe that if
this deal in this form is shot down
something else happens either they piece
off Call of Duty by itself they piece
off other sort of uh Activision IP by
itself some way shape or form Activision
isn't is changing in some way and I
believe Xbox is integral to that change
it would be part of that change whether
it happens this way or another way I
don't know but I think we want you yeah
and it's hey so to me it was just like
listening to him I was like Wow Jim like
what happened to the fire what happened
to the rage what happened to them like
to K Ashanti's Point blatant lies right
and I think it finds he got to the point
also when you look at judge Corley shout
out to judge Corley when judge Coley did
a very good job of shutting down the BS
on both sides and saying the things that
we've been yelling from the Raptors in
the beginning like it's not about this
it's not about these stupid ass
arguments all these things and just
being like Hey we're not protecting Sony
here we're not protecting Sony here and
the moment you Jim Ryan hears that and
he doesn't hear an argument that's party
that's sort of partial to what he's been
arguing up until now what are you going
to do well the problem with that though
SOB is one you're not in a good place if
you have to remind the judge that you're
not protecting
that being said right after he said that
he went back to protecting Sony
right like he he they act they're
actually saying that uh if if a gamer
wakes up on Christmas and he can't get
the skin yeah uh the Christmas skin for
calling
the judge said you mean like what
happens on Playstation right now yeah
and exactly a lot of people are saying
well why didn't Microsoft's lawyers get
to speak more this was all about the FTC
and I'm like why they didn't need to
they needed was doing their jobs man
that's the burden of proof is on the FTC
not Microsoft that's what I'm saying
that Jim's Jim's testimony
this is clearly a joke but it's like uh
you know Microsoft Microsoft they're
like we're gonna sit back PlayStation
one out there they picked up the FTC
they like this is ours we we buy these
Microsoft did the next best thing
they're like okay you take the FCC we
taking the judge
yeah
the FTC is Sony's new times exclusive
so that was it for me like to me it was
just it was it was weird to see but then
seeing the situation and seeing how uh
obviously as she as should be impartial
the judge wasn't and and very quick to
sort of shoot down BS arguments on both
sides it kind of felt like you know what
I'm done here if if I'm gonna claim this
W if it happens to go down if not I'm
gonna act like it I knew it was gonna go
down anyway and and sort of save face
and that's gonna be it so Jim Ryan is is
a very I kind of see the full point that
everyone is talking about but I think
he's purposefully a fool too like he
knows what he's doing and he knows that
he's not a gamer and he knows that
people see him as a non-gamer and a
business guy so he plays that role very
very well and I do to cast his point I
think he earned his check I mean who
would have thought that Sony could have
put this big of a wrench into into this
proceeding I thought it was going to be
go quietly and whatever and just that
just one little complaint and a little
bit of snitching yeah look what you get
look what you get so you get you know at
the very least they're making them spend
a lot more money than
here we are Lord King Jim Ryan on the
stand
video tape not understand
but uh what do you feel sir about his
stuff that's what I told people before
this stuff even before he even got there
before the videotape and all that other
stuff like your boy was going to plead
the Fifth
and they was like yo so if you give an
opportunity if you was buying ABK and
you was doing X Y and Z uh would you
make that stuff exclusive to your joint
well answered it I guess he looked at
the FTC like yo B I paid you what's up
why are you trying to trap me what are
you acting like Bobby here what's what's
going on here wait a second wait a
second I thought you was here to protect
me that that that that question seems a
little bit loaded guy
I refuse to answer the questions off of
the Merit it might incriminate me yeah
I sit back here with the rest of the
rats I thought first of all I thought we
would have a screen that you guys can't
see ah not the filter all right so what
the filter when I when I turned States I
thought I was turning states with
where's my voice modulator
because come on now be nice he did what
he's supposed to do for the PlayStation
dude
oh man let's not talk about the physical
features of people let's continue we
will not be physically oh you know
shaming people but you know listen the
PlayStation dudes
you got the proper Defender these are
you guys these are y'all guys in a
nutshell and he and he is the epitome of
you guys you guys like lie to yourselves
and I like that I like that y'all guys
feel safe in the in in in the fact that
y'all number one in the market but look
how you got here
all money and good money bruh like you
you see it this is the hated dude in the
club he's sitting there with his one bad
shorty he go to the club to the wife up
the strippers
you gotta feel over there buying out the
ball buying out the club and he's
sitting there eating a banana talking
about him like this
we're gonna have to do something about
this and he went he went snitching and
you see the snitching in effect now he
thought he wouldn't have to be called
the court so he sent a video today oh no
going in there yo so y'all gonna do the
voice you're gonna do the shade thing
and the modulation thing on my voice
right there's like yeah so when the tape
came out he's like these dudes don't lie
and told me
congratulations and the voice thing on
I love it it's business always
what happened it would be funny if
there's like a a whole incident going on
where we're hearing someone in the
background talking and they have like
that little modulator on and they you
know how like they they'll put like the
witnesses with like the screen up so you
could see a silicon but you can't see
them yeah and you just sit there and
they're talking all this all this stack
for like 10-15 minutes and then someone
actually bumps that that protector out
and it's you
I thought I was protected
this is how I feel
we're eight eight likes away from 1K
let's get those likes up
can you imagine if he did show up on the
stand what judge Corley would have done
to him up there he would never have done
it
it gives you the ability to be
cross-examined yes and it opens up the
The Host this is the reason why uh a lot
of defense attorneys don't put their uh
clients on the stand because you know
the clients aren't well versed to move
around the questions in the manner that
they can't so at all times you try to
avoid the stamp yeah and what's funny is
like the the rare occasions where
someone's like 88 of the time they go
into jail to get them yeah yeah as soon
as they get this a lot of the times if
you look at like Court proceedings the
ones that Got Away knew exactly what to
say on that stand and I don't think Jim
is in that position but even though he's
he's doing what he's supposed to do so
yeah the money that he spent for his
companies to get this to happen remember
he just went to Country to Country to
plead his case if I can turn one
I'm good and he did his thing with the
CMA and as you can see uh as far as them
colluding together on this case
this is nothing surprising what we saw
from Jim
this is everything that we thought we
would see and thought we would hear if
the Brazen part for some people is a
little bit eye-opening as far as his
willingness not to accept things and
what he wanted in return
you got to think of it as entitlement
and you're number one if you've always
been getting that steak dinner that
stuff and somebody brings you something
subpar that is inadequate that is not
what I'm used to and I won't I won't
settle for less country So Country Club
yeah you gotta respect he's been eating
good he's been expecting things so if
you're not bringing exclusive stuff to
him and he's the market leader why
should I entertain this to help you help
you I'm not gonna help you get rid of me
and you got more money you go figure it
out go outside and go figure it out but
because I figured it out with my money
and I'm where I'm at and I'm not giving
you the leg up to bury me so if you want
to win you better go outside and win and
if you think you're climbing up that
mountain I'ma step on your fingers every
chance I get so you better have some
hooks in your hands to go around me my
man and Phil said that
[Laughter]
you not getting no star Phil you not
getting the other stuff oh by the way
Indiana Jones exclusive and I'm gonna
tell you you want to fight we gonna
fight and this is why Phil is who he is
Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive he the first to his name and
you better respect it he got into court
and he said it's about that I'm about
that life and oh well you're not getting
Indiana Jones it's about exclusive and
Starfield You Gonna Hurt in September
you said uh Phil told Jim that he stole
fizzy lifting drinks so he gets yelling
yeah good day sir
that's just my thing on this listen Jim
did what he was supposed to do I respect
Jim's moves but remember at the end of
the day
like Bobby learned
you go against the grain there's gonna
be a point in time when you have you're
ridiculous
that deal ain't gonna be the same you
ain't gonna get the 10 years like
everybody else
you gonna get the every year the Year
baby
deal yo
Santa Claus are you
all you want because if you didn't play
nice this year and being that nothing's
in place saying I gotta do what you want
me to do I think we might skip you this
year
so please Jim by all means sign the
contractor
get the horns oh sign the contract gym
and send me that dev kit too while you
at but that's what I was doing you know
we gotta miss you this year
if you don't send me a dev kit I don't
think I can ship this [__] on time
we'll see you next year since you since
you feel that you want to give me what I
need I don't think I need the [__] oh
man see you next year Jim yeah
this is what I personally feel is going
on with you know Jim Ryan I think
what what's the problem I'll take you
seriously continue
but this is what I personally feel is
going on with the Jim Ryan thing is I
actually feel like at the beginning he
had every intention on letting this go
through I don't think he's really gonna
fight too much on it but I think he was
going to try to get consolidations you
know I think he was like all right let's
let's fight this a little bit you know
just put enough enough friction just to
get just to get us a nice little deal
you know make sure car don't leave for
10 years or something like that but I
feel like he started seeing
the amount of
friction he was causing
and at that point he's okay we're no
longer trying to get a deal we're trying
to block this thing actually and I think
that's that's the reason he looks so
lost like literally when you listen to
that that hearing when he when he was
testifying
you would think this dude was kids
smooth with all the ums like every every
time he said anything he he he it would
neither be like a long thing of Silence
or he would just be omin at all yeah um
you know I just I love his famous
sentence man what what what makes you
feel like that why at the time yeah
at the time I felt like Call of Duty was
gonna be on on Playstation because it's
like there was two different mindsets
going into this that's why I feel like
at the beginning PlayStation didn't
think they could realistically do
anything to stop this but slowly they
started seeing that so they started
causing more and more friction with
hopefully being able to get it blocked
you know
I think it's just hilarious that like if
this doesn't if this gets the injunction
gets approved and Microsoft has to pull
up
of the deal
there's some corrupt stuff going on
because you know I'm not a lawyer but
I'm sitting here listening to this like
this dude sounds like he don't even know
what he's talking about like there's a
lot of the times where
she would be asking him a question
and he would take so long to answer it
she has to re-ask him
it obviously most likely he had like a
lawyer in the room and like they kept
muting the button just like the best way
to that's probably what happened he
wasn't in the room that's the reason he
didn't show up in that Court like he was
going to get obliterated and showed up
in that Court like they there wouldn't
have been a Jim Ryan that would it would
have just been his tie sitting there
it's just like you know when you see
this stuff like this going on it's like
if this does not get past
there's still chest I don't want people
don't be a king don't pop bottles
already yeah because you don't know how
far the politics goes in this somebody
gotta be
um
you don't know what I said the deal's
going through don't listen to nobody
else with these Kool-Aid Hearts
they told King not to say hold on hold
the line
that's this is exactly the line we've
been holding anybody else been talking
about some other lines you hold I don't
know what your lines y'all holding but
the Hawaiian we talking about we talking
about this FTC this court case one I see
dudes it's just the weakness is to what
bothers me the most okay it's just like
when it gets the crunch time these dudes
needs start knocking you start to hear
they harder
yeah they not cool Under Pressure
that you're saying everything it's just
Friday came we got down to the closing
arguments and that's when I started
seeing dudes knees not
cheap chattering yeah they start
questioning stuff did we
did we was it this
is
bring the points I don't know if the
judge gonna go this way because you know
it's 50 50 and we can't we can't even
say with you but if it is
but the thing is yes so what last time
he was popping bottles and and you got
smacked in your mouth so what you still
alive did you die here's the thing the
only reason I say don't pop bottles is
because we've seen over and over again
when it comes to American politics you
don't know how how DC has a losing
record what you mean like what the hell
yes
if they told me my next appointment
opponent has lost his last 10 fights
sign me
sign me up don't tell me this dude is a
killer he ain't Mike Tyson he's this
dude ain't he ain't on a 10 fight
knockout street you know loses
not this if this deal doesn't go through
it's going to be the greatest comeback
I've ever seen King speak because I I
just I can't imagine how he gonna you
know what it is
my name they remember me for the only
dude standing here while I knew why
dude's knees is knocking me sitting in
the corner playing on this joke
yeah yeah he knocking and they standing
in the corner peeing itself with a stop
bubbling their nose talk about how no
King man if you don't buck up and stand
strong listen Stands Tall holding it
stand next to me if you don't got
strength hold on to my shoulders because
I'm looking at you dudes different do
not come to me after the deal goes
I'm with you Kingsman mental health I
hope this thing
you said that right before the Xbox show
too they said King you doing too much
before the show what an actual show who
was standing tall walking around yeah
but if you don't back and you put a
tally for every time they hyped up
something and they didn't live up we
would have a completely different
conversation give you one step okay
there has never been an injunction
granted in the last 50 years for a
vertical merger
I'll give you another stat see that's
right
that's that's Nationwide
hold on hold on hold on in the Northern
District
in the Northern District of California
in the ninth Circuit of appeals there
has never been a preliminary injunction
granted at all ever
um
you know
you know we need to do king we need to
meet up with a cartoonist and an
animator and we need to have two things
made one General King hold the line and
take in the car the capital and one you
get pushed through losing the cats don't
listen to him man I don't I don't
entertain loss like I've never done that
in my life I've never looked at
something and said oh Let Me Entertain
him
you lost to me and drive you lost to me
in Dragon Ball you know what's funny you
lost to me and listen listen listen and
Naruto you also lost to me on two bets
that was your Battleground and I came
into your house and I stomped on your
chest the thing is you think I care
um
and everything there's going to be a
chance of winning and losing but the
mentality of a loser goes and thinking
about loss first I'm a mentality of a
winner I'm going into win at no point in
time if I'm going to give you a break
you won't have to break me and you won't
break me so even in a loss I'm gonna
look at you like that wasn't that good
like what like you could have did this
so listen this is this is why I am I am
me and you are you and not talk about
you at it I'm talking about the song you
mean the person that has like multiple
of your needs is that who I am okay
because you only go up you like Jim you
only go into a situation when you think
you have a benefit yeah foreign
[Applause]
let's go quickly
when that when the case is settled and
they say in Microsoft favor
who the hell everybody coming to oh King
David
I'm gonna put it this
heavy is the head that wins well it's on
my
mind hey talk to him my neck is built
out of still because it's still like
that
cake and these must have had dudes out
here talking all this money no king I
don't know oh my God this shot is
ridiculous back-to-back defense
knife to knife that's the knife I will
say let's go we'll say I wish you had
this kind of spine when we was talking
about Sonic
you know what I'm saying but you didn't
hold the line
are you saying ever born King walks in a
situation
he mad I ain't standing up for that
furry blue right
okay
yo for 50 years people getting knocked
out I don't think this
[Applause]
he went from the 16 big Graphics to
whatever the hell this is now and that's
the only gimmick and they got four
people we calling my man though furry
rat bro Mario showed you on the next
page that he's on mushrooms and Molly
you know what I'm gonna go with what
this dude is doing because this is new
sorry he gonna get knocked out in
October
look we gotta move on it's going too
long look y'all best y'all messy y'all
messy look and I just want to say for
the record he told us about about listen
at least
Amy no sticks by Sonic because we all
know what's going on with Bowser and
Pete
we all played
Odyssey where where Mario ran all around
the world built the spaceship went to go
save her and then she took his spaceship
and left him on the moon
yeah we know there's something going on
there time on y'all okay all right y'all
derailing this is great though this is
great I love you I love you I mean we're
gonna be over 10 hours
look all I'm gonna say is
look you know Jim is outside you know we
know what he was going to do I did think
what was interesting he caught the way
he said Game Pass was value destructive
and that he spoke to all Publishers and
all Publishers said that they hate it
I'm sorry Jim I'm not I'm not buying it
but not a PS plus right there you go you
know EA EA would like to all the repeat
customers come yeah
you got the plan what fact Tom who's
launching new games there facts EA would
like to enter the chat Capcom would like
to enter the chat Square would like to
enter the chat Ubisoft just put even
though I know it's not directly into
game pass but at the same time
wait a minute after this was announced
didn't the publisher Hits come out like
on Twitter and be like slowly roll Jim
many of them on Twitter
everybody everybody's following a second
MLB the show is on Gamepad yes sir
indeed
Paul just got caught leaving out the
back door of his house
and you said that she don't like him
yeah
look MLB the show was definitely that is
MLB's call though
you have shoes on when she left
as part of the king there's Satya size
10 and film size 12s no those are size
13. okay about four so look MLB
definitely forced the deal but look at
the end of the day we know that to not
be true right we don't there's tons of
developers as Publishers that do find it
now granted In fairness if you are like
take two and straws in them it's not
going to be a value benefit based on
where Game Pass subscriber count is
right now it's not that's what it is but
we are seeing people add stuff on the
tail end after that front money front
end money goes down sales are slowing
Now The Game Pass deal looks effective
so I'm not buying that stuff with the
publisher
um what I I don't even know about this
email that quote-unquote set Jim's alarm
bells ring itself I think that's the
funniest thing like it was all good but
then this email happened and then
because of this email this behooved him
to now has to stand staunch defender of
the deal they ever born is right he just
said no whatever whatever
that did I would love to see that
because I think that is the funniest
funniest thing going on and and to um
what's for everyone's point in the case
Audi's point about the dev kits I think
that it is interesting you know what I'm
saying it goes on one on one hand you're
talking about parody and wanting to make
you're scared that things would be
degraded on Call of Duty if they get the
deal but on the other hand you don't
want to give the dev cat deaf kids
because you claim that they will learn
internal Secrets I feel I feel like both
is valid though no I do his ability to
what because this is like because we're
talking about sending Dev kids like when
they're first off the line like they're
able to be seen by people you said
something like that to Microsoft
Microsoft could say whatever they want
all Minecraft gets the dev kits we won't
share it to Xbox you're an Xbox Studio
I mean it is interesting that that that
Hillary Diamond but I do understand some
aspect of it and obviously we have you
know proof with Minecraft right there's
the the PS5 there's no native PS5
version of Minecraft because of this
situation so if the deal goes through
I'm very curious how that plays out Cog
let me ask you a question though why are
we pretending like AMD is not the one
making all these things actually factual
right like you know they don't have to
go to like you you're they're
you can already get that info and if you
think they don't have that nobody wants
you nobody's got ten your homework for
the record for the record Phil Spencer
has said in interviews that even during
the PS4 PS4 three uh Xbox One genuine
they were transitioning to the next gen
they had seen the PS5 devicade on many
occasions because they go to the same
Studios they Dev test the same game
absolutely absolutely we know everybody
this is this is all snake oil they're
trying to get over here
absolutely right but we gotta give Jim
this this could create doubt to the
uninter of course right yes wow they're
gonna learn our secrets it's you gotta
it's good theater everyone I know you
hate it he knows what he's doing to prey
on the uneducated in this space
just guess what judge Corley is not on
the edge
they got away with the fact that
Nintendo's ninth gen system is not
intent that's what I was just about to
say where was that my next Point come on
and that's Jim's greatest strength these
Regulators do not understand you said
Jim's greatest strength is playing
praying on idiots yes an idiots yes on
stupidity it's it's great it's
corporations corporate and stuff so okay
so so
the fact that his uh
fan base is being preyed on oh man I
just said oh I see what you doing
we gonna move on I know yes hey I did
not thread that needle ladies and
gentlemen I Didn't Do It Blockbuster yes
customers
there we go because they like but they
would say it's going to be the death of
the movie industry why I want my
physical VHS tape why are you making me
pay for a digital service remember that
remember all the games I gotta go to
Walmart to buy a movie I'm not watching
bro yeah he'll say like dude the boxer
you put the money in and you get the
tape and all that bro like when Netflix
came thank you when Netflix came
Blockbuster was holding the line holding
on we heard about all this stuff they
had the ability to go digital and they
didn't and they chose not to that's
right it was their choice yeah listen
Redbox came to them with the ability to
uh merge with Redbox right yep they did
not merge with Redbox if they were to
merge with Redbox they would have red
box kiosk inside there inside the Giant
and then they would have been able to
make the transfer over to digital by
consuming Redbox and putting red boxes
on every corner while you consolidate
the opportunity to buy netflix.netflix
yes see again and like PK was saying
this is the nature of just the industry
in general not just isolated the games
the industry so that was pretty much it
I just thought it was interesting let's
see them turn to an app I know yes we
know where you want your demise to be so
let's come by this time no I'm done yeah
cause I was like there's no need
already so we ain't no need for that and
then you talk about young older no oh
I just I just want to talk about young
Odin being the the G he is
like
it's an ad read yeah
YouTube
they already spreading rumors about us
at it and here you go talk about Mutual
might like he got to do an ad read
Versace
that was boss addict that was your first
Fireballs ever this portion of ice
the thoughts of King David reflect the
thoughts of King David on his birthday
and also on this Edge reads
ain't nobody get no bags over here
I knew it was real when the day before
Satya came there they was like we got
permission from the White House for for
Mr Nadella to come here at 1 30. so is
it okay if we do it at that time Nadella
was there doing photo ops he's talking
to Byron
Byron
Joe Byron
this is the difference Jim this is the
difference Jim they call them they
subpoenaed him to the court he said hold
on let me ask Byron if it's okay
you know you know what else was wild
talk to these dudes his Byron say hold
on that's conning them let me get on the
phone yo man treat my guy nice he's
showing up over there
thank you
yo so at this point in time Satya gets
up there and I love the fact that Satya
gets up there and says you know what
they ask them questions and said yeah
those questions that you asking me it's
nice and stuff but I like to defer to my
shoot over there
you know Phil said it's a good idea and
I said it does it make sound business
sense Phil he said yeah it does all
right so Phil go get that
what's the limit on the budget Phil
don't talk to me about money go get it
done
that 68 building so they came back Santa
is 68 billion
yeah that's cool make sure that we get
all this done I think the FTC is gonna
have a little bit of problems with him a
little bit of wind Byron got to me let
me go talk to these dudes and handle
this so
being that he had to go from the White
House to the situation we know where
this is going and right back to the
White House because we're talking about
political ties and last time I checked
Byron like Xbox
I don't know about all that a lot of big
Tech a lot of big Tech stuff is reason
why this is happening yeah you know
because
yeah Microsoft supplies a lot of tech
and a lot of AI stuff over to uh wait
are you threatening sir I'm just saying
if things don't go your way you have
leverage to do stuff again hold on oh
hey hey all I'm saying is
somebody kid works for the company oh
we're gonna keep it let's keep it we're
gonna give it a step yo kick I'm gonna
send you some I can't share this out on
this podcast but I'll send it internally
someone sent me a chat message on this
little card Y'all Gonna peel yourself
somebody say a message in the zoom chat
and I'll reply to it continue I got a
name for him though we we call them
Xerxes
you see he just comes by to expand the
Empire and all he asks for is bread and
water
show yourself
oh okay no no that was it I don't want I
don't want to drag it out any further
but we all knew that um all the team
members that went up there were going to
uh hold their self accountable and give
the proper answers that we that we knew
was truthful
yeah this is the part of the podcast
where we just talk about the sponsored
post that we just read
it
yeah
I just feel that he's he's the whole
team being there shows you the
importance of this right so when Satya
can make a way from the White House in
order to take this meeting it really
means the most to Microsoft and if a
judge sees this and if it meant so much
to Jim
to bring up these concerns and then he
had contradictory emails that stated the
opposite and for him not to show up here
means that it really didn't mean that
much
so that's a perception in a court
right so when you go to a courtroom and
that's why they tell you sometimes when
you go to court or bring as much family
members friends and everything that you
can bring in so the judge can see that
you have support
saw that if the only support is from the
FTC for Sony that's why the judge has to
say we are not in the business of
protecting Sony so that's all I want to
say is just the fact that it was good to
see all those people there and the fact
that he's the head and he was there that
shows how important it was yeah fair
enough Fair now yeah they got too much
to add with young Odin I just felt that
the um what you call it the statement
that uh he made in reference to
exclusives was interesting but at the
same time he deferred to Phil and say
Hey you know if it was up to me I'd do
this but clearly it's not up to me and
we we're it's just I don't say fading
strikes are like we're forced to just
play this game yeah but that's the thing
he deferred Lester Phil as much as
blaming it on something yeah he blamed
the market conditions also he's like
we're doing this because we have yeah we
didn't really want to do this and first
of us I would not do it but you know be
that that's the way the that life is
right there
I just thought that was interesting you
know saying that the logic there but
yeah that's that's pretty much what I
had on that and um let's just follow
through this last one because this is
quick this is really quick which is um
King stop it which is um the actual deal
itself Call of Duty um it looks like it
only includes one more game shout out to
um Tom Edison and those guys so yeah
when it all Launches on Playstation uh
consoles later this year it's going to
be the last one under the current track
contract so under leaf that bad
um uh Sharpie in the courtroom you know
said um Sony's current contract with
Activision Call of Duty ends in 2024
however that contract doesn't include
the 2024 Call of Duty game The Last Game
covered by the contract is a Call of
Duty title to be released in late 2023
Microsoft has offered the 10-year
contract for the franchise to remain on
the platform should the acquisition go
through however Sony has rejected it and
then we also learned in the documents
that uh Call of Duty has made over 27
billion in its lifetime in addition to
that it was claimed that Call of Duty
has somewhere between 7 to 10 million
active users and it's also claimed that
one million users spent 100 of their
gaming time on Call of Duty Duty in 2021
and yeah that's pretty much
um you know for Bobby reiterating that
you know you know what Call of Duty
exclusive because he doesn't want to
alienate 100 million active players that
would be funny
if the day after Call of Duty comes out
this year
it's just they Microsoft and ironically
announces an EXO and the first thing
that comes out that stage is next year's
college but they would have to marketing
if it goes through so King this is I
think even if the dough doesn't go
through Microsoft's getting the
marketing yeah oh he thinks all at the
end okay I see what you said okay
that'll be interesting so uh King this
is your topic Call of Duty's uh deal
with PlayStation
dudes is like nah they got it up to
2026.
they got the [__] rights for this
whole generation
sorry sucker
yeah
it's out this it's over it is over it is
over you are watching the mortality of
your box go down and Jim sat up in his
bed because he thought like you the
contract was up until like
2023.26. he's like yeah man we got years
to come and he woke up and say oh stop
wait a second hold up is up this year
it's 23. now we gotta stop this deal
y'all don't get marketing rights after
this it's over y'all don't get a chance
to dictate Pace no more 20 something
billion what is that 24 billion over
it's lifetime that it's made 27 yep yeah
man we need we I don't know how long
it's been in existence but we need to
get that over here we need that 27
billion here that'll pay for half of
what we paid for y'all and then I did
that Diablo and all that other stuff
cool you know spread out spread the news
and get more money back to us I love
this I love that the contract is up this
year and um I I predict this year is
going to be in Game Pass we won't be
able to talk about it
but I predicted this year Call of Duty
will be inside games yeah you're going
to go for it yeah straightforward so as
soon as the deer goes through all the
Call of Duties and Game Pass I predict
I'm gonna stand on that one all right no
doubt no doubt anybody else on this uh
the deal and what you think might happen
as far as uh this whole situation let's
go whatever boyfriend yeah I think I
just just because I know we all got to
get out of here uh I think that so this
is the last one you get but it lasts
until 2024 because I think it's going to
be like okay whatever this year's Cod is
they gonna have that one year where you
can't put it in Game Pass and then when
that year is up it can go but the 2024
Cod uh that there's nothing that's gonna
hold that to say you can't put that in
Game Pass so I think I think this year's
doesn't go in Game Pass but next year's
does and then after January 2025 you
will see
um you'll see this year's Game Pass
sorry this year's cod in in Game Pass I
think that's what what the country you
know be funny ever born if the
contract's only how long they have the
marketing rights so the moment the
marketing rights expires they just throw
game passes
it's like the game it's like okay the
gate comes out the fifth the 16th and
Game Pass just switch it over okay your
thoughts on the uh the actual deal
itself
um I agree with everyone by and large I
I think that they're going to be
strategic and they're going to place it
they're gonna it's gonna come out right
after they they adhere to all the the
various the various contractual
obligations I also think that come
hooker crook this is the last time
you're going to see a marketing deal by
PlayStation
regardless even if regardless of it yeah
in Junction or not this is the last time
why because business is business but
there's been some dirty dealings done
and Microsoft will be really quick to
give the money if that's what they want
in order to keep the marketing rights
they would do that and I I don't think
Bobby would go well water under the
bridge let's go back to normal if
Microsoft didn't give them any extra if
if they didn't want to do the marketing
then you'd see PlayStation but it is in
my estimation that Xbox will get first
dibs
I think Nintendo will get those Mercury
rights before PlayStation I suspect as
much this is this I mean yeah but here's
the thing when you go in those other
circumstances and and stuff was done for
business reasons it was always done to
devs or or you know Parkers you
literally have took away billions of
dollars to the people that matter at
this company exactly like this is just a
small thing you literally walked up to
Bobby like I know you want that three
billion so if we don't want it but okay
what about Bobby gonna have to come back
to his table that's exactly the thing
that's exactly the thing but if we're
talking about a universe where the deal
is blocked that means Bobby lost 400
million dollars do you think he's gonna
go back to the dude that just lost him
400 million dollars
you gotta try to recoup
PlayStations in the room
okay what what what what what what what
do you want for the marketing rights
he's like I want 68 billion dollars for
the marketing oh you can't give me that
you see what I'm saying like like I I
understand the idea that he has to they
have to recoup their losses and of
course that's business but I do think
that in that world where they need to
recoup their losses and they've lost the
they've lost this deal they go to
Microsoft Microsoft goes okay we'll give
you that deal why because both of them
at that point have lost a lot from this
competitor so tell me how how Petty
would be to give it like steam their
first marketing right Steam Market
hilarious Hey listen listen all I'm
saying is whenever this deal is up you
are gonna if I'm if I'm Phil I'm putting
an exclusive Christmas skin
and you should literally call it with
with uh with parentheses on it when you
highlight it exclusive Christmas skin
yeah
and it's green it is the whole Xbox you
can PK your thoughts quickly on the um
the deal itself the structure of the
deal and what we learned that is ending
soon
BK's on mute oh he's on me was on mute
oh there you go
there's a pip cap there yeah
for me I think it's gonna go like the
Bethesda things you know uh existing
will stay multi-plat all new going
forward be exclusive me personally
I'll just be happy because no one feel
he will stop making high move Studios
toys for backup and Etc being just
support take him out the salt mines baby
take him out the salt lines and maybe we
can get the final no I'm sorry this is
me being selfish talk to it let's go I
know final game
for Transformers
it is amazing part of me feels like
they're keeping that that line calling
David team right now
it's crazy that you guys are talking
about wolf of Cybertron because somebody
literally had me like I was playing it
on here like a day ago speaking into
existence
greatest Transformers games
yeah third one so hopefully yeah we'll
get to that point and then you know all
is good but that's me personally no I'm
sorry it's gonna be business it's gonna
we're gonna definitely
they're going to definitely put
everything in Game Pass and make things
exclusive I won't say everything but
things that make sense for sure
absolutely no doubt they say PK spit
right now he got a channel I don't mind
hearing this yeah we're gonna put his
Link in the description and all that and
of course you know I'm saying our
brothers over here with uh ksrt and ever
born um solve and addict any thoughts on
the deal what we learned about what we
know about what Call of Duty yeah it's
like I said make it quick uh even if the
dough doesn't go through I don't feel
like PlayStation will get that marketing
right I do feel like when they start
having a good relationship with
Activision or blizzard it's going to be
when the leadership changes like
drastically because even especially if
they promote with the from within you
know what what's that uh the people
below Bobby and them you say they're all
Executives too you stole they money too
so it's just like I and people can say
it's all about business but one thing I
know is when you have that much money
people aren't just gonna let that go
like that we're talking like they go
they all go into the sunset if there's a
reason so many Executives that came out
so openly and for this this agreement
what's that chick Lulu is that what's up
they better hope to God that woman don't
take over right she's gonna be Spanish
because
this chair she might try to confess a
whole room to take it away from places
yeah
see they would have uh revealed the
whole Joe Brian about blocking the deal
stuff solve thoughts on the deal the
length and all this good stuff
yeah I'm surprised that it's ending this
year right yeah everything that we heard
prior was just about a couple of years
right it was it was the modern warfare
too I bet you they counted that as a
game right that and then in the new war
zone coming in right so it was like it
was it was more a game thing number of
games as opposed to number of years yes
um and so yeah yeah here we are I see
the if there's any truth to the the
whole
um Bobby Cole dick sitting down with Jim
Ryan Soca trying to extend the deal if
if this deal falls through if there's
any truth to that then you know again
sometimes we get in our feelings and
then business is very cold-blooded yes
and I just kind of feel like at the end
of the day if the money's right if the
bag is right and the splits are right
and they they know I mean you can't sit
here and argue that Call of Duty isn't
most popular on Playstation business
would dictate that they try to figure
that one out what happens a place like
weapons of Activision try to negotiate
like a better split with them
like they did at Mike or so you see it
would be is that type of minutia where
you know you have to start looking at
each other with the side eye like listen
man you don't have as much leverage as
you once had let's let's renegotiate
this you're still the best place to be
whatever but you know let's renegotiate
this and I think that the opportunities
will be taken to do that sort of stuff
okay end of the day of Microsoft wins
and this goes through
um yeah I think they're gonna adhere to
this last one I do think that
immediately wants that that once that
exclusivity period sort of Runs Out boom
you're gonna see this year's going into
Game Pass next year and then next year
depending on what is finally you know
ultimately agreed upon at the end of
these proceedings right if because I I
just find it hard to believe that
there's no stipulation about it going
into Game Pass and whatever and there
has to be some sort of stipulations
around that well Bobby don't want to go
again exactly he doesn't you know
about money
yeah
what I mean is that probably don't like
it if at the end of the day it has to go
through with some sort of concessions
and the concessions that are that are
sort of put forth are hey can't go into
Game Pass after that right that won't
happen though right because it I mean
that would have happened everywhere else
and no one had an issue with
subscription Services right like not
even the UK or anybody if there is a a
thing the closest thing they have I
think is cloud and that's where it would
be but even then I don't think
um the subscription will be a remedy
only because it wasn't for the UK it
wasn't for the EU and the and the judge
even said uh having it in a subscription
is good and it would cause Sony okay so
there was no there was no question so
far as to the specific terms nothing has
changed everything that was agreed upon
in other regions is exactly what what
what stands here that's what I'm saying
that nothing related to PlayStation will
stand okay
um just because the judge doesn't seem
like she bought it and I'm not saying it
will go one way or the other cloud is I
don't even think they made the case for
cloud but I feel like that's where it
would be and I'm only basing that around
the rest of the world wherever yes and
and this judge didn't seem convinced
about any of the PlayStation stuff and
thought that uh it going into a
subscription would be pro-competitive so
if that is the case if that is the case
then it's going to the game pass as
quickly as humanly possible and you know
whether who whether internally people
like that or don't I think then they
don't work there
we don't care what Bobby says after the
deal go through Bobby get your money get
them about the building yeah yeah
you're gonna go on the parachute he's
out of there
um but yeah I think you know it's going
to be interesting what happens because
again all this talk about Cod or let's
talk about cod we're gonna finally see
what happens to Cod yeah um
I agree I agree let um just reiterate
everything what everybody said I do
think that you know if they stop you
know the injunction and they're going to
close immediately they're going to close
immediately I don't think they care
about maybe what the CMA do and it'll be
like to be it's the equivalent of back
in the day King when like remember when
EA was back in the day like being very
resistant to put stuff on Xbox Live and
they had to go through and then you know
Peter Moore and them had to fight you
know your game for this reason you just
won't have it and then you know there'll
be enough political uproar for the you
know that battle to continue yeah and
it'll get there when they get there but
they will close I agree I think it's in
Microsoft's best interests and I think
they will do effective you know
immediately kind of deal and they'll
offer that value I've always said one of
the most attractive entry points to a
generation from a casual perspective
would be the series s Call of Duty
packing I think you put that on the
Shelf to the Casual you will I'm not
going to say to the same it Bobby
because Bobby's like they gonna flood it
droves but I will be honest that it will
have impact but if what you put on the
boxes put Call of Duty put fortnite for
fortnite free to play people ignorant to
this they don't know that yeah you put
Wars on on the box absolutely watch on
the bottom absolutely and you can say
that this is the the shooting of battle
the shooting battle battle box yeah yeah
you you you have a a a holiday season
with little little black man
who interestingly storage was increased
based on Star Fields size and that that
you now
you're talking oh yeah you're talking
holiday YouTube new series that's Kevin
Hart
one second I I just learned something
new here so [__] does that mean that
your OG does that mean that your OG
little man will not be able to run
Starfield easily out the box I mean hard
drive you know he he'll he'll be hitting
the limits
that means if I have a series of time
Garfield comes out I won't be replaced
no you'll be able to play it you'll be
able to play it but you will be
constricted on how like any other games
you'll be able to add
something can you just even stream it
you can stream it yeah
man it's a very versatile individual
nobody's trying to limit a little man I
wanted to know because I'll be like that
that would have been a little bit of a
little bit of an issue light bro oh man
anyway we versatile
we gotta get out of here look that was
it that's what I got on there fire
topics gentlemen again absolute pleasure
to have y'all all in the realm monster
discussion didn't think it would happen
but this was so much fun this was so
much fun so let's start with that's not
what to do new person to the round p
where can I find people find you what
you got going on sir
yeah first I want to thank everyone for
letting me come through shout out to all
the panel and definitely uh que Asante
and everyone
um
you guys always can find me in 4gq TV
where I co-host with my brother clowns
and definitely we always do things big
and brown over there you definitely uh
hang out with the dragon when he's not
asleep
um but sure and definitely follow me at
pkx live on Twitter I'm down to get any
gaming in be let me just be real I am
not one of those who like to talk I'd be
about that life so you definitely we
have to shoot my cards or your seats It
On Deck okay like yo bro check my
paperwork
check the paperwork just look at the
little PK salute bro glad to finally
make this happen it's been long overdue
I appreciate you reaching out loved your
input on the discussion salute the four
guys record a salute to your channel put
that in the description through the 108
you can find a multiple places but go
check them out on Twitter salute to the
legendary PK and then graph shout out to
you pulling up when I was in L.A pulled
up you know what I'm saying we got a
chance to chop it a little bit that's
love always I always appreciate when
people are outside that always means a
lot to me no doubt and of course we got
the circle we got about brothers in the
game it's Circle podcast up in the
building one of the hottest new Duos out
here it gave me the stuff of my bro Kate
Asante always love brother good to see
you where can I find people find you
what you got going on
I will first and foremost once again
thank you guys for having me always as
as has been known as I say publicly
everywhere my favorite podcast you guys
allow me come on here I feel like I'm
standing on the shoulder of giants I am
so so humble thank you guys for having
me happy birthday Lord King what do you
think talk your stuff it's all good we
appreciate you sir and of course of
course my man never born soccer we do
this you know the dynamic duo we always
enjoy doing it live but people would
appreciate it PK great stuff stop it
stop it King continue
don't let him get you off your squabble
who said that somebody said that
I thought that was King I'm used to that
for behavior for kids one doesn't like
doing it live for the people
everybody can get together I forget it's
the same person so now I got it
my bad I blame my cousin okay absolutely
I was going
I was gonna say PK has the most amazing
content super knowledgeable podcast with
the gentleman a few times great stuff
always always love hearing your your
takes so people go check out his stuff
appreciate you being here love
podcasting which was really good uh as
for me you know a podcast with the man
ever born stagger I'm also now I'm also
now podcasting with the man John Wolfe
the father Sega Stan in the chat now we
are talking we are talking you know
we're talking PC stuff we're talking you
know for the wrong Ally gang for the
handheld PC gang out there you need some
pointers you need some tips you know you
want to talk you want to talk about how
you do a little this a little bit of
that the waters are shallow or deep
depending on how you want to go so
Monday nights Easter 7 PM Eastern
Standard time we call it the gamers
playground come and join us nice concise
hour and a half we appreciate you you
know thank you so much for having me as
usual thank you brother next time I
appreciate you okay cause uh I really
really appreciate your knowledge your
technology and you know your balance and
we don't get to see a lot of that and I
really like to support you brothers
because you guys are really doing have
you guys have an entertaining show
there's no doubt about it so it's good
to always link with you have a little
gcpio fee connect that was dope shout
out to Delilah HD she said shout out to
both of y'all for supporting the ladies
love being on this show yeah so that was
dope and of course my brethren sega's
own bx's own in the building they're
highly opinionated and never duplicated
ever put Saga bro it's always a pleasure
to part with you bro you'll be
respecting you'll be spending the day
for sure waking up people find you what
you got going on all right so you can
find me everywhere you go to your
favorite social media Network you type
in everborn Saga and I will be there or
you can go into the bathroom and say
Sonic three times
uh you can go to and that's Xbox
PlayStation steam whatever but you can
go to everbornsaga.com right now we have
a sale going on in preparation for the
new book we are going to launch so you
can get all six chapters of The
ever-born Saga everyone you mean to say
that not a full color hold on you mean
to say that not only you are like a
prominent podcaster but you also like do
your own little anime you're Literature
Like what's what's this stuff you doing
what's the biggest organ story what does
it link to yeah I'm gonna put the link
in there because you know people think
you just talking with you you about this
that's what they think but we we got a
whole fantasy uh Universe going on it's
all everything's connected it's four
separate series and they kind of
interact with each other two timelines
is I like to explain it as Lord of the
Rings me X-Men if you want to know what
I'm talking about go to the website I
promise you once you see the quality of
the work we deliver you will you will be
amazed that we are an independent
operation because I think the quality is
up there with the big boys for sure but
don't listen to me go to everyone
saga.com and check it out so like I said
all all six chapters over 300 Pages
well listen we got two games coming out
and the games are based on the comics
and all of the games are from based on
16-bit era genres so we're working on a
2d platformer right now as well as a 2d
beat em up again based off the the comic
series check it out don't believe me go
to everyone saga.com click on any one of
the books scroll to the bottom and
you'll see this little sale we got going
on so check it out uh everyone
soccer.com and everyone Saga everywhere
else and thank you for listening to me
uh talk smack I appreciation a lot of
Excellence today PK now I do that I do
have to run because the missus is
already completed
in the car
San Diego Comic-Con
um moderating so uh please be on the
lookout if you guys are out there
excellent look out for us
um we're gonna it's crazy right it's
it's last minute so I just wanted to uh
let you guys know uh definitely be on
the lookout for that and shout out to us
if you see us out there yeah
um
y'all playing games y'all making games
yeah I hope y'all y'all about this life
excellent y'all just not talk I thought
y'all just be talking
a lot of Twitter talk with you you
really moving out here PK I'm right
behind a king you know what I'm saying I
already know what's gonna happen we just
acting like the verdict's already out
talk to him done deal we just want the
rest of the world into existence thank
you so much
bro
not on this level
these are glorious in 1460.
this bag gonna get us to monetized I'm
not trying to get Snipes
see y'all please enjoy your weekend you
already know solve we got super chats we
got business we got something yeah let's
go all right we got mdy ten dollar super
chats at Super Chat happy Sunday Lords
heading up to NYC in August you
gentlemen have any gaming store
recommendations to hit up while I'm
there appreciate what you do and
blessings to your families
nah I mean J L
um video games New York
uh Brooklyn game Brooklyn video games
yeah
yeah uh Gotham City Games
those are the big ones I mean if you
happen to hit Fordham Road please go
there while you're single yeah
go to Fordham game world go to Fordham
gay World
um where else where else that's about it
for the big stores I mean if you've
never been to the Nintendo store go to
Nintendo store
um yeah that's a great place yeah that's
pretty much it okay uh let me see Robert
Young two dollar Super Chat Sony West
take a move like Microsoft yeah it's a
lot of money a lot of companies a lot of
dope spot gold 17 to pass Super Chat if
it goes through gyms outside with no Cod
deal yeah I can't wait for that
smells like poo
that's a general talk now those are
called those are all bars
Jay Boy On The Run two dollars
trying to run God's Hitman yeah we got
all these goons in our teams
everybody's doing something
extracurricular activities yeah those
are my people out in the kids
yeah get outside two dollars Super Chat
Cloud got free 99 games while Sony got
straight Bill
we got MD mdy again ten dollars to chat
in case you want to see life on the gym
Ryan definitely just got brought down
for maintenance again on a Sunday of a
holiday weekend at some point Bungie
leadership has to be held accountable
for this
I did leave when they get tired of it
yeah I got Corey Tidwell five dollar
Super Chat Jim Ryan had on the R Kelly
mask from hotel during this deposition
yeah you're messy messy
I used to hate when Dee always threw
himself in that wrong
foreign
Microsoft would fold earlier I think he
knew from early on that they told him
like yo this just going for the Long
Haul I hope you know this Jim don't care
he just wanted to yeah
exactly hard to leave five dollar Super
Chat the dev kids issue is overblown PS5
Dev kids are already out the next time
this is an issue would be ps6 which is
years away and I would listen I would
even argue this hey you guys ever stop
and think about why why are these
consoles constantly coming out within
months of each other and why
mysteriously very similar like come on
like they know what's going on
we got the rubber knob five dollar super
terracy this Gap a minute I can see Phil
bring out being petty and offering the
same deal as Sony as they have as they
have everyone else yes I could
definitely see that no I don't think it
inferior deal yeah it's Kings the Kings
Kings one is like burning down the hole
Yeah
basis on a Christmas on a free
assessment good or have you been naughty
that we have no Christmas
that's crazy
stay high FFF two dollars in the chat
attic I love you but them jokes is
killing me what jokes I forgot
so many bags today he was in his name
then we got Rel ski remember for three
months Lord bronze happy born day King
no doubt blessings thank you brother
then we got rubber knob once again ten
dollars Super Chat Jim shat himself
straight
approved without any concessions meaning
Microsoft could pull if they wanted to
Jim saw the spiky bushes Sway in the
wind Let's Chill Bob Manchester gym
then we got Mr two opinionated two
dollars with that we good regardless
hashtag hold the line thank you thanks
I'll be good with it I don't want to do
it without it
pixel bit G two dollars Super Chat thank
you all the back and forth is too funny
yes
having fun having fun I got Mr two
opinion again five dollar Super Chat
going out blasting taking my enemies
with me and if not this guy so they
won't know
we got the movb we got the ammo all
right that's what we grew up on man like
oh my God these guys grew up on this
coomba yeah we grew them up on shut them
down and and
shook there's ain't no such things as
halfway
one of the greats Prodigy the bandana P
recipes that's right even though they
threw them on the summer
[Laughter]
you're gonna do the gods memory like
that even though they have my man in the
tutu yeah I don't do my man she's a
shorty
[Laughter]
damn man
version of Minecraft either the delayed
PlayStation Dev kits might be the reason
for the delay of the next gen release
could be could be oh that's a good point
yeah
risk it for the best game oh that's my
God what are you saying eight dollars we
both heard Jason he's been developing
the next gen since before the launch of
the Xbox series xns what will having a
dev kit possibly change and like we said
the dev kit
the dev kit yes obviously you're gonna
have the innards or technically what the
machine can do but at the end of the day
both machines come out around the same
time and are very similar so one has a
super fast yes that's true that is true
for some reason that includes Graphics
you know a lot for the gradually shout
out to Rich yes the homie yo hit me up
this month we got a link um Australia
you already know what it is that's my
guy right there salute cool dude cool
dude yep I have THX 1138 two dollar
Super Chat Phil the gym
don't mistake my kindness for weakness
bang bang that's the conversation that
could have happened that's for sure
you thought I was somebody that I wasn't
Jim I'm the guy that's in the closet
behind the guy you scared of oh man
the boogeyman wear boots
[Laughter]
hi I'm cells with the one dollars chat
with a little birthday cake wishing king
of happy birthday oh thank you so much
salute it's my 419. you
then we got one bad mother five dollar
Super Chat Things I'll Never bet on Jim
to tell the truth the Washington
generals or sonic to beat Mario
never born happy birthday everybody went
down the ship he gotta say the very
heart don't pump cooling he ain't back
there he ain't gonna back down over
there but Sonic gonna get his hands
cold blooded
we got Raiden blade bypass Super Chat I
just watched the greatest Transformers
movie ever made next to Revenge of the
Fallen and you guys still podcasting you
guys are golden yo he watched the whole
movie we still going yo yeah it's crazy
people watch that I heard it was good I
want to watch it that's what's up it was
I watched it three times
I told y'all all right all right I gotta
let go about buyers yeah you know what
it is appreciate everything wow
it is the best live-action film close to
Transformers the cartoon the movie It's
the closest that we've ever got to you
know what it is a lot of people just
assume that Michael Bay still Associated
he is he produced he produced the
explosions yes okay it wasn't it wasn't
a bunch like you know you get over he
just does it too much too much explosion
stuff like he don't know stories so
thank God he didn't do the directing
this this movie definitely had all the
best pieces yes uh let me see then we
have red and blade two pound Super Chat
happy birthday King David yeah blessings
I've got gamer by choice two dollar
Super Chat happy birthday King keep
holding them
a choice brother they can't force him
[Laughter]
then we got Frizzle five dollars in the
chat you guys still going when I'm awake
sign of a great show Happy Birthday King
you're a legendary Community yes yes
that's it I appreciate that the movement
Creator the vigilance outside yeah
Dragonheart Yogi five dollars
again King happy birthday and listen
you're a huge inspiration to a lot of
folks man keep up the great work Lords
bring PK back to the realm
trust me he need his intro yeah he gotta
get his boss yeah
Jimenez member for seven months Lord
gold happy birthday to the general Lord
Hold the Line King David wishing you
good health wealth and continuing
success let your rain continue for many
many more years to come thank you
brother just trying to get past this
Wednesday when this deal is up
uh then we have you can't find me in the
bushes
with the Lord's great show and happy
birthday King David
just as almost good as this other guy's
name called uh high gas prices
it's crazy what these people come up
with yo they Super Creative you can't
say Amen then you got uh risk it for the
biscuit three dollars
Superfly SSD
[Laughter]
we learned a lot about that SSD yeah we
got booty hunting click
Brooklyn raised and loving this episode
bless up thank you absolutely for the
town too we gotta be careful
you said he was outside before watching
you bro
we hunting booty
Brooklyn stand up Brooklyn stand up
don't stand there because he's hunting
the attic is all fire in this episode
Jesus
[Laughter]
Ryan I hate acting like Phil can't turn
him into an afterthought like 50 did
y'all
like ask about me the young boy don't
know oh
damn damn baby
yo Jim use a Pop-Tart sweetheart you
soft in the middle oh not the 50 boys
oh man the back down
and we got a splendidiferous two dollar
Super Chat happy birth strong King bless
up yourself this the era yes no doubt
it's a little splint difference we got
handheld FTW two dollar Super Chat make
Attic review the steam deck he will turn
these people trying to get me to play
that [__] language
yes we got caught up we're good all
right finally get everybody another one
absolute pleasure yeah what we got what
you got over the deck oh yeah you know
that's Steve deck official right there
Steve that incorporated
this was essentially a one topic show
yeah this is essentially a one-time show
that went on forever but we're gonna get
it popping yo my man let's start with oh
PK we give you an outro but let's start
with um where can the five people find
you what you got going on sir you can
follow me next week bye-bye
You Gotta Eat You Gotta Eat no doubt
Lord soft pulling the six hour yeah yeah
listen I turned my camera off and have
some pizza yeah
I
mean come on I thought this was just too
good and I felt like some people
I feel like some things might be left
out because the distraction is Call of
Duty and not really the the bigger
picture absolutely now I appreciate your
Insight on that brother it was a really
good informative stuff loved it so if
you were seeing soon yeah man big shout
out to you PK and and to ever born and
to K Ashanti guys that are really really
paying attention to the stuff in depth
I'm kind of I'm out of my depth when it
comes to it because I just don't I'm not
interested in the back and forth I want
to see the end result and see the world
Court sort of burn but the minute paying
attention and listening to the you know
to these testimonies and stuff I
appreciate you guys for doing that and
the Insight shows us so thank you for
coming through all the uh I really
really appreciate it and of course shout
out to my brother yeah David yeah love
you brother many more to come
enjoy enjoy brother enjoy and the man of
the hour the born day Cuzo Family
holding the line on his birthday y'all
if you've had that that crown on
six hours strong yo appreciate you love
you you already know you mean so much to
us and it's always good to celebrate and
see you get your flowers the way you
deserve and um one of the still one of
the funniest individuals out there on
the planet and I love your energy you
bring it all the time it always shows up
always shows up consistency no doubt we
could have found people find you what
you got going on well you can find me uh
playing brample
don't get PK man was talking about yeah
I'm getting that too see I'm not the I'm
not the guy
I don't play games
I want to First say
um thanks to the panel yes
um first two you know ever born Saga is
you know my brother from another mother
that dude is funny as hell I'm always
helping always being there you know a
true entrepreneur in his sector and and
always trying to to be come and be
better I love that and I love to be
around individuals just like that shout
out to care Sante for coming through
with his technology that the man is a
wizard when it comes to certain things
and he's definitely going to take me
through the dojo and uh teach me about
this Rob because the user interface is
trash
um
shout out to PK I love your persistence
brother um I did a podcast with you on
runaway Dragon loved your energy there
you hit me in the DMS you was like yo
this stuff is going on and I want to
shoot my shot and be on the the platform
that I choose to watch you know whatever
and I was just like yo thank you so much
but you know Cog does that and the fact
that you said cool took that information
I'ma shoot myself right over to the [__]
and make sure that I get to this
situation shows that individuals like
yourself will never see a closed door
and you will always find a way so I
appreciate you being here and I
appreciate you rocking out the whole
time and also I appreciate everything
that you said because you gave
thoughtful insight and if you're not
following him and and clowns or when
he's on one away dragon show uh you're
not following the right people you need
to definitely be following PK PK is a
dope dude thank you for showing up
brother especially on my born day
um to my my fellow Lords
love you dudes yeah love y'all to death
man and this is just so much fun seeing
how many peoples here watching us having
fun and us actually able to do his wife
he was like you ain't gonna do a six
hour podcast on your birthday right
whatever God say this is one of those
joints yeah see what it is yeah yeah but
would you be fair if we have a six hour
podcast you had something to do with it
I can assure you oh yeah yeah no no no I
was definitely gonna come for the [__]
Arena buffoonery all of that wow okay
usually the first word but we're going
we're gonna move on don't worry about
that part that part was me yes that's
all you yeah
that was the first one the second part
is everybody
yeah job turkey guys that's what we're
going with that's what we're going with
but we had so much fun today so I want
to thank everybody that did show up and
um everybody that's been hitting me up
on Twitter 13 000 followers
I didn't even pop my cake yet so I'll be
popping my cake right now
I'm not gonna say it but you know I want
to give an early shout out the way props
to to call for a big guest we're gonna
have at the end of the month yeah yeah
thank you hopefully I was speaking into
existence yet but uh things are moving
I'm super proud of what we're doing
again happy born day to the Cuzzo it's
always good to see him meet another one
that's love and um just everybody you
know panel was dope shout out to PK
shout out to ever born it was a good
discussion we had the right mix I think
for this topic and it and that's why I
sure didn't feel to Craig's views having
so much fun with all the topics shout
out to solve for taking out all the time
of his day sacrificing the flu and
tremendous adveries an addict for
actually you know hanging in there I'm
proud of you hung in there today with
all the craziness why don't you know
what I've because we've been having
power outages here and I actually wanted
to talk about some of those topics but
by the time I got back in it was already
almost like three four almost four I'm
like nah we ain't doing that like we
just moving on we ain't going back
forward the facts shout out to the realm
y'all killed it consistently with the
likes to love it's it's tremendous take
a thousand likes I'm crazy today like
y'all really show and loved us and we're
really hungry there yeah we're sitting
at 1100 that's insane that's insane look
hit the like button higher hit the like
enjoy your weekend we hit a thousand
you're supposed to slow thigh bro
[Applause]
s.com birddogs.com
he's trying to get out of it yeah y'all
got me playing Final Fantasy
no that was the deal yeah he
self-imposed it on you yeah yeah
you want a whole Buck behind glasses
two boys
we got tsws gaming 2010 next IOP episode
I guarantee it's gonna be wild yes
this verdict gonna be crazy and if let
me not spoil it we'll see what happens
but it could be potentially crazy we got
it thanks to be crazy we got we got
things potentially cooking next week
next week's gonna be the the conclusion
of this case and then uh the week after
that you know they'll have a big guest
yeah
booty hunting click five dollars
why is it a clicking y'all
[Laughter]
trailer was crazy lessons
guys you didn't tell King that I'm gonna
pop out of his cake with my nippleless
shirt off did you
I'm already see King in a sec we should
solve is this yo he in the house he in
your house King hey wifey stabbed that
cake
bottom of the cake oh man how about that
cake you gonna you gonna be going to
another cake plate high up in heaven I
am done are we good song yes sir
everybody okay you good boy
no no no no close out everybody
all right y'all peace
[Music]
thank you